[Music]
do
so
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
here
eat it
[Music]
welcome to day two of the game sports
stage here at e3 2016 brought to you by
airheads bites it is my absolute
pleasure
to kick off day two
with the legend of zelda breath of the
wild we've got daniel from the nintendo
treehouse i'm obviously joined by
gamespot editor timor hussein
daniel what is it i mean you're clearly
repping the brand here
yes i have this like wonderful scarf
that i have luckily so yes and the watch
don't forget the world
how exciting is it for nintendo to be
finally able to show the world the new
legend of zelda oh it's been a while i
know even just having a chance yesterday
to finally reveal the title breath of
the wild which we showed that trailer
yesterday which shows off the art style
this open air exploration game that
people get a chance to experience um and
just seeing the huge lines we've had
outside the booth people are waiting
like four hours to get in and get this
whole experience and even when you go
into it's a full all-encompassing
experience where there's statues
everything like that and just it really
brings the whole story of legend of
zelda to life in a new wave at e3 we've
never done before so i'm really excited
i've seen the statue it's very
impressive i only got a brief look
because it was after hours and one of
the security guards was like get out of
here
but it was really nice i took a nice big
picture of it it's impressive like i
love looking at the color of the new
link in this outfit and yeah it's just
super impressive it's an awesome little
statue but you brought us a gift today
haven't you yes so yeah we showed a
little bit of the game yesterday here on
the stage with you guys but now we're
showing another part um because it's a
very long demo it's actually like a 35
minute long demo so we're going to show
you the second part which is a bit more
focused on the story elements of the
game awesome yes let's take a look
oh we'll take a look inside
it's building attention
to it but yeah no it's just a good art
style for everything um it'll be a
chance to see exactly what is what what
what it what has started this whole
thing going this whole story going along
um
so we'll get up in a second but yeah
it's a chance to understand uh
what that you're kind of just thrown
into this world right off the beginning
of the game right uh don't forget if
you're watching on games.com live e3
i'll be taking a look at the chat taking
a look and uh offering your questions up
to daniel if you have anything that you
want to know about the legend of zelda
open your eyes let us know yeah
all right here we go
wake up link
voice acting as well
so link here just basically wakes up
after a long slumber
and here we are
you kind of just start off here in this
room and basically this shiny object is
kind of calling your attention
uh a chance to see what's going on and
this is where you first are introduced
to the chica slate which is an important
tool in link's arsenal this time around
which is how you're able to use a map
you can actually scan different enemies
and it's also how you're able to store
this power of runes which is something
new to the game
where you actually when you go to the
shrines of trials you'll get a chance to
get runes embedded into the sheikah
slate that you can then use to um like
throw remote bombs or uh freeze time on
certain objects as well and we'll get to
one of those shrines hopefully in this
demo as well and from what i understand
the shrines are different from actual
dungeons right correct correct there are
over 100 different shrines of trials and
there are so those are big and small in
various ways and then on the other hand
there is the dungeons which we haven't
talked much about yet so we'll have more
to talk about it but there are dungeons
so there are different than the strands
of trucks obviously the name shrine of
trial trains of trials implies
challenges are they kind of like
similar to what we'd see in in a dungeon
in terms of a puzzle or is it like enemy
based uh what kind of what are these it
all varies yeah a lot of them are puzzle
based um sometimes the shrines of trials
have a single solution to them sometimes
they have multiple solutions to them um
sometimes you go into a shrine you
realize i can't do this shrine yet right
so you might have to mark it on the map
and come back to it at a later point i'm
a question from the chat they're asking
um does is link gonna have permanently
three hearts as his health bar
or can um and with only food buffs or
can he get more as of right now i'll be
showing you he starts with three hearts
um he will have a chance to eat food to
get those buffs to get the yellow hearts
we showed yesterday um and we'll have to
wait until later on to see how the how
the rest of the game expands from there
oh look at that yeah this is a beautiful
introduction to the game um and you just
don't know what's going on here it
really kind of sets out what kind of
goal with the new legend of zelda game
is is to present this open world you
know we're used to starting off in small
villages and then excellent you know
exploring out venturing out and
discovering parts of the world piece by
piece whereas this is kind of like
here's everything right you do it and
that's why
the whole world is almost like a living
character of itself and you're always
having to move around and discover what
you can and that's kind of why it's
called the breath the wild you don't
know what you're going to discover as
you're going through the entire area one
of the questions i had was like it looks
obviously you've chosen a visual style
that we're kind of used to seeing for
the last fuse all the games but there
was a period when you know the other was
everyone wanted a realistic zelda
whereas you've gotten gone you stuck to
like the the almost the wind waker style
colorful oh is this is this kind of like
the art style that the series is
settling into is this kind of like how
we we perceive this this is because all
the games are going to look for the
future mr newman's always talked about
how every they approach zelly game as a
different it's something new they're
going to try to go after so they
approach it as they want to and it's not
always a permanent style i mean this is
actually based a lot on a japanese
animation style um
it's like a gauche a gouch gouche art
style um more designer on the idea of
looking at an open environment of space
and then trying to capture that moment
in a painting and that's kind of where
this style's a little bit different that
yeah it is reminiscent to a little bit
like a wind waker style but it is its
own stuff every zelda game has its own
little art style even on the wii u on
the wii on the 3ds on the nes they've
all had their own different styles
um so like so that's kind of just people
get to experience each time so one of
our editors peter brown played this um
the other day and wrote up impressions
and it was discussing this guy here he's
kind of like an npc that you can choose
to trust or not or you can even avoid is
that does that speak to kind of like the
broader way that you integrate npcs is
there an element of like kind of
choosing how to
treat these characters and what they
offer you and that kind of stuff yeah no
that's very very accurate i mean that's
the whole point even with the shrines of
trials with the characters you'll
discover all of it is that you choose
how you want to go about this and
explore and again you're right trust
this person not trust this person is he
helping you is he is you don't know like
you've just woken up in this long
slumber and you're in this world and
being called to help um by this
mysterious voice
um so yeah it is up to you to decide how
you want to go through that
okay all right this is our first combat
encounter
and that's true you have to always be
looking for things to pick up um like
right here link has picked up an axe
that was able to use um and yeah and the
cool thing about the weapons you'll
discover um from the enemies you fight
you'll knock out their weapons or defeat
them and take their weapons find
treasure chests or sometimes weapons
will be lying around each of them have a
different attack motion like you saw
there by holding down the attack button
links are charging up and spinning
around versus using a sword you
discharge up and just do a quick spin
um so there's all these different
weapons they'll have different styles to
play with what was the thinking behind
introducing these weapons that kind of
you can pick up on the flyer because the
series legends of the series
traditionally i mean the weapons are
almost as iconic and beloved as the
characters themselves you know like the
master saw the shields the you know the
hook shot the uh slingshot that kind of
stuff so having these kind of almost uh
just random elements like normal average
axes putting in there does that kind of
lessen the kind of impact that weapons
will have and the memorability of these
weapons
um those so we've shown so far yeah the
idea they want you to try experimenting
all these different weapons that's why
they have they have durability they do
break over time um you can throw them at
people as well um so you have to kind of
debate which weapons you want to use
they have different strengths but also
as i mentioned once we get to it you
have also those runes which you actually
have a remote bomb there's one that
controls magnetic properties of anything
so people can pick up an object like a
giant metal boulder and actually swing
it around as a weapon so there are those
kind of aspects of it that of what
you're bringing up from the game before
but again it's that whole idea of every
zelda game in its own tries to build a
different experience
to enjoy
and we're seeing link do something which
we haven't seen him do a lot in the past
which is just jump randomly correct uh
jumping you actually can control when he
jumps and that was a really important
mechanic that uh was changed in the game
um because onuma wanted people to be
able to climb climbing is a big
important factor um as link's been
running around you'll notice he has that
little green circle appearing which is
his stamina meter which is how bobby
kellogg can run for when he's climbing
and right here right now link is
actually sneaking up on this macabre
right here
we're talking about so you can see in
the bottom right corner right there um
there is that pure purple meter there
that's kind of fluctuating that's the
noise meter right um so when you're
trying to sneak quietly behind the
different enemy you have to be careful
about that and slowly try to sneak up on
them if you want to get a what's a sneak
kind of a strike from behind them which
probably does more damage right yes they
actually you almost basically kill these
characters in particular
essentially instantly so here now link
has got another weapon now the traveler
sword so you're always kind of looking
for different weapons and items to use
oh you can only carry up to eight so you
have to actually even debate which ones
you want to carry and hold on to the
weapons can break now yes right yes um
and also
enemies seem to drop them mid-fight yeah
so it's more it's more of a dynamics
more scrabbling around
it's all about that you want to be
constantly foraging even not just
weapons but also another another
important element of the game is cooking
like usually when you run around you hit
grass and whatnot um
hearts would appear or rupees or
anything this time around that doesn't
happen you have to actually go find
things like apples or are
or hunting a boar or a squirrel to get
items you can get together and then you
can eat them raw to get health back but
if you cook them you can make them even
more powerful like more recovery or
buffs that you were mentioning before
kind of like having yellow hearts or
some kind of bonus or
uh the ability to uh take cold
resistance or run for a longer period of
time
um oh right here actually seeing a
really cool cutscene as well um with the
sheikah slate that were able to unlock
this resurrection tower
which is the first time you really
understand how huge this world is
conceptually
and there are multiple towers um as you
just saw from that cut scene so you have
to determine how best to get to those
but right now you're on this plateau
which you can't if you go to the edge of
them you actually can't if you jump off
you'll die because you don't have any
way to get off of this right now
um but you now brought this resurrection
tower to get a different kind of
perspective of this whole world to see
what's going on and see what's happening
so how big is the world and how how how
densely populated is it i know that you
guys have announced there are towns
villages npcs but you're not really
showing them off correct right now right
now you're just starting off on this
plateau um which if um in a moment you
saw a little bit earlier uh link brought
up his map to look at on the chica slate
and that map represent this the plateau
area you're on represents less than two
percent of the entire map uh and i said
i've seen people playing this demo alone
just exploring for uh 15 minutes you is
not enough time to go around this whole
thing this is just now you can see right
here discovering this is right now less
than two percent of the map
um so i'll have what i'll have linked to
in a second is actually pop up the map
again and then zoom it out and you'll
even get a better perspective of how big
this world really is and that's really
important that chica is a really
important tool that you can use to mark
points because i said sometimes you go
to a shrine of trial or some location
you want to come back to you need to be
able to mark those on the map to think
about that is there going to be fast
travel between the points yes you
actually can you once you when you
unlock the shrines of trials which is
why it's important to go to them is uh
you can oh you can shine on trials you
can then uh mark that point and fast
travel to it again but right here now
you have the right of rushing tower
brought back up you're getting a bit
more of the story um from the voice
right now that there's this is a castle
um uh and there's something called
calamity ganon all right it's located
locating this
now then
and now you've discovered you've been
asleep for over 100 years
and now basically you need to help
keep this power contained
before it's too late
so this is like this just a little
introduction to those pieces of the
story to help keep moving you along and
deciding how you want to go through this
whole world to discover what you can
find try to help
so how how are we going to follow
through the story is it just like is it
dedicated missions and quests and stuff
that you can follow or can you take a
really open-ended approach to it and
just do things in different order if you
do things in different order it's up to
you to decide how you want to go through
everything and explore so there's not
it's not it's that's that's the big
change up um that mr arnoum has talked
about is that it is not uh in previous
zelda games all the time it's like this
one this one this one this is a lot more
reminiscent to the original zelda the
nes like if you play the very first game
on the nes when you start playing you
can literally just go to left to right
and you won't get a sword yeah and
you'll just start dying
so you have to be worrying about all
that how do you ensure players don't
don't get stuck in the story then i mean
it's a massive world we've seen
people are going to get lost maybe go
off the beaten path a bit how do you
ensure that they can get back on it
that's something i mean right now we're
just showing this component here which
is just this contained area of the
plateau to kind of work around discover
right now and you're kind of encouraged
to nudge like right here as an example
you just saw the old man come down here
on a paraglider
which is essentially a tool that link
would need to get off of the plateau and
here's the claiming again and call out
um so this conversation right here as
we're going through this he's giving the
old man give a little bit more
understanding of what this is
um and how there's something inside of
this castle that you need to basically
help protect um and essentially he's
going to now offer
like the opportunity to make a trade um
to because because he basically needs a
paraglider to get off um so what he's
going to do is basically see i'm going
to actually isolated plateau and now you
can clearly see you cannot get off of
this plateau
um so basically what he's going to offer
you to do is if you complete some of the
shrines of trial trials he'll baby make
a trade with you okay okay
um so that's kind of a way to encourage
you guys he's trying to say they kind of
encourage those pieces along but you're
right there'll be those moments that
kind of encourage where you want to go
at the same time you can also just go
off the beaten path and do whatever you
want to but we'll get more to that later
on as we start discovering more of the
world and showing more of the game off
to really show how that's going to help
people move along in terms of what the
story is exploring obviously we will you
know the focus will be on link's quest
to you know defeat on container power
and defeat calamity ganon but this also
seems to be one of the most mysterious
links in a really long time we're used
to having
seen you know him grow as a child in a
village but this is like a link that's
just emerged from a slumber after a
hundred years how much of that kind of
backstory and why he's in that slumber
and what happened before is explored
that has that's so weird overall i'm the
same point as you i'm also waiting to
discover that more and see what mr and
numero has to say about the game in the
future um and that is true i mean again
that's why i keep a lot of it comes back
to think about that that original zelda
game because the same way in the first
zelda game you just were kind of thrown
into it unless you read the manual
there's a little bit of a story in the
manual from back in the day
um so yeah so it is more about that
sense of discovery you're not in a
village like in previous ones but as you
said before mr nimmy said there will be
towns there will be more stuff going on
um but we'll get to that at a later
point in the future so this is the one
of the first so the shrine is yellow
right now which is signifying that you
have not gone into a certain shrine um
so actually if you were able to get to a
higher point you could scan around the
area there are other shrines to find
this is the the shrine of omanau
and you can use the chica slate now to
activate it and now once it's turned
blue now you can fast travel to this
location in the future
it's the first sequence to go inside the
shrine of trial
and this is your chance to actually earn
your first rune
and runes are presumably what you trade
with the old man yeah that's that's he
was asking for to see if what you can
complete is chinese that's what he's
offering to trade
is that old man uh kind of showing up
regularly with new items or is it that's
really that's the first time you see him
when you come when you come out and you
see him by the fire
um and then he kind of meets you when
you when you bring up when you come down
from the resurrection tower but you
again you don't know do you trust him
who is he
that's this part of the mystery you
still have left to discover what whose
voice is that that you hear when the
game is playing like who's talking to
you who's guiding you along and you
don't know yet because we have a history
of mysterious helpful people appearing
and then at the very last moments
revealing themselves to be
an important key figure
my suspicions are already kind of peaked
with this guy yes no i'm curious i mean
it's always funny when they have the
name just old man like you're like what
it's it's a very very
yes oh it's linking a beard from the
future yeah there's so many and i'm sure
people are gonna be making their own
assumptions of who it's gonna be and
that's part of the i love seeing that
conversation that people have and trying
to determine what's going on
and here's yes by going into the shrine
of trial here you get now the the the
chica slays now being embedded with that
power of this rune um and this actually
a pretty cool uh rune rune you have here
which is uh magnesis which is the
ability to control objects that have
metallic properties all right um and
they'll have that first puzzle mechanic
to go into this
i have a question from the chat they're
asking uh how will they handle the
dungeons being able to be played in any
order in the past you needed items from
other dungeons to complete them seems
like you'd only need the i need the item
to get in that dungeon that the puzzles
would be a bit easier well that's what
in the shrines we're showing now that
these are the shrines we haven't seen
dungeons yet so that's we'll get to that
at a future point and see what those are
like but the shrines are right right now
the shrines we're showing here in this
demo yes you do get the power of the
rune pretty much the beginning and have
to then decide how to use that to get
through it to discover what is at the
end of the shrine um which we'll get to
hopefully uh as we're going through this
right now um and that's something people
have to discover some will become more
complicated so it'll be harder and
that's the whole point that you might
get to certain certain shrines that you
can't get through yet and you'll have to
figure out how best to come back mark it
come back to it later do i need certain
runes already embedded in me embedded in
the sheikah slate how is that going to
play out and that's something to kind of
figure out so i read online that it's
possible to start the game and
immediately go to the final boss is that
true
well you couldn't right now you can't
get off the plateau yet so you couldn't
go there um and that's something and
you're right it's similar that you might
try to head toward the final area but
you might the enemies you even discover
or the what you start on your way there
might be too hard for you to get through
so you might have to get other equipment
and discover other areas and explore
those areas before you can come back
right the areas you couldn't get to i
asked because obviously you know the
legend of zelda syria especially ocarina
of time has become quite a staple in the
speed running community yes and i'm sure
people are gonna try to figure out yeah
so there's a will there's a way yeah i'm
sure there's gonna be a community trying
to figure out the minimal the amount of
items that you need to get to the final
mission which shrines do you really have
to exactly like i'm sure there's over a
hundred so i'm sure you'll have a field
day trying to figure out which ones you
really have to go through like shrine
two shrine 15 shrine
whatever to kind of go through all of
that
all right i'm afraid we are nearing the
end of our time perfect we're almost at
the end of the shrine right now here as
well let's have a quick look we'll see
how quickly lincoln gets to the end just
to show um
all right obviously basically open this
door
[Music]
denied he's he's still getting you know
waking up he's give him time he'll get
there
for a hundred years i'm gonna sleep for
a hundred years yeah let's check off the
cobwebs and this is where you discover
this mysterious monk um and at the at
least in this demo right now that we're
showing here and at the end of each of
these you do meet one of these monks who
essentially is working with the goddess
helia
and that's that's part of the mystery
you don't you really don't understand
what is that is
so this is now you've proven you
actually completed one of these
and you do receive a reward for that as
well
and then the goddess forever smile upon
you wonderful thank you so much yes
um are you guys talking about a release
date at all uh right now we've only said
it's coming out in 2017. i know if
you're watching my calendar free 2017 um
but it will be releasing on the wii u
and the nx simultaneously wonderful
daniel thank you so much for joining us
thank you so much for showing us
brand new zelda um for more coverage
from this year's e3 make sure you don't
go anywhere stay tuned to gamespot.com
[Music]
one more
so
[Music]
welcome to gamespot stage for e3 2016
i'm lucy o'brien from the future the
years have not been kind i'm joined by
timur hussein and also jf and jonathan
we're going to be talking about deus ex
mankind divided dsx is such an exciting
and really interesting stealth game what
are you guys showing off here that's new
at e3 well today we're going to show uh
the first map of the game which is
called dubai so uh it's the beginning
exposing the the sitting the the the
fantasy of the character adam jensen and
like basically uh establishing the new
world that they're going to uh where
jensen is going to evolve and the second
map or the second uh video we're going
to show is the the breach mode the new
gameplay mode that we uh we revealed
last week yeah so what what is it that
happens in dubai what how has the world
changed since the the last time that we
saw adam jensen well by the end of human
revolution there was a big incident
where a lot of
augmented citizens went crazy and they
turn uh into zombie mode should we say
and a lot of people die and uh and now
we're two years after those events and
now the the dust is settling down a
little bit but there's still a lot of
tension a lot of people from both sides
like naturals are fearing the augmented
citizens and they're trying to pass laws
and segregative laws and put the people
in ghettos and stuff like that and now
you have also augmented citizens that
are trying to make their voice heard and
they're fighting back and adam jensen is
going to be in the middle of this world
uh is working now for task force 29
which is a subdivision of interpol and
there are it's an
anti-terrorist group that is trying to
bring some some peace to to to to the
world and also adam jensen's motivation
to be in that it's to do some good but
also he believes that this agency is
tied to some people in the shadows the
illuminati that are steering the the
society in the direction uh that maybe
he doesn't agree with so he wants to to
to stop them it's something that you
guys compare to apartheid which of
course is a horrible and tragic thing
how do you meld those two things
together both having a powerful and
interesting message while also making a
fun and interesting game to play
uh it's a good question what we do first
and foremost we're trying to make a good
game we're trying it's a fictional world
we're trying to to create an experience
that players are going to dig and
everything and after that the we always
try to have interesting questions uh an
interesting theme to explore so players
can
be immersed in the world can have fun
with the mechanics and enjoy a great
adventure but at the same time we put a
lot of layers trying to to show like the
the different angles of a subject and
let the players choose by themselves
like what they think like we're tr we
try to stay neutral we're not
trying to say uh this is good this is
bad this is this this is that it's
really all about uh putting the players
in the middle of this world and ask them
questions and let the players find their
own answers and and i don't think
we're comparing it to the apartheid yeah
i wouldn't put it this way i mean i i
think by default
there is a bit you know the moment that
you use a term or something that has
already been used
maybe by default we cannot we can argue
that there is a comparison to be to be
made but i mean us um it's not like the
the the will is not to compare it to
what what has already happened but what
um the meaning of an apartheid is um is
a really really good fit uh uh uh kind
of politically speaking for what the the
politics in the game you know so um
that that's that's really what it is
right and it's it's a good fit and it's
it's science fiction science fiction's
always been about um you know kind of
talking about really serious themes and
whatnot um in a projected setting but to
kind of get people to think about their
current issues and their in their
contemporary world we're going to see
some of dubai here and um obviously
dubai itself as it currently is is quite
an interesting visual city um what was
kind of your like approach going into
reinventing it for like a futuristic
sci-fi environment well our goal with
dubai was to kind of bridge the gap
between human revolution and mankind
divided that's really where the map is
yeah yeah and the in the last game uh uh
the ikea smith was a big myth that we
were using to tell the story of human
revolution where uh augmentations were
like the the the future it was the
bright future all what we can be so
golden age enlightenment exactly party
exactly and uh so he carries like with
his wings augmentations trying to fly
high getting too close to the sun
eventually burning his wing and falling
into the sea and now with uh mankind
divided it's kind of like we're ending
the icker smith by adam jensen he's in
dubai it's very black and gold there's
the sunset and now for his first mission
like we saw a few seconds ago is jumping
down like like he's jumping into the sea
to to to start his mission it really
represents the ending of human
revolutionary exactly like all the you
know we've had too much fun you know we
went too far and now we're just crashing
down party's over party's over
and uh so yeah so that it's kind of uh
foreshadowing what's coming into mankind
divided that it's going to be a little
bit more darker and the new art style so
is going to what we call corporate
feudalism like where everything is a bit
more it's based on brutalism and and
things like that and it's all about uh
showing that the world is taking a step
back and is refusing uh uh the new world
or basically the the augmented world and
everything so that is to bridge the gap
between this looks like sets the table
there's going to be a lot of like
conflict happening in this one because
as you say it's kind of it's all coming
to a head which must make it really
exciting and interesting to create these
like stealth scenarios that are kind of
avoiding avoiding these conflicts and
working around them so what's going to
be like approach to ensuring that people
who would like to avoid conflict are
well catered for in a game that seems to
be you know putting lots of combat into
it or creating clashes between different
groups good question yeah well actually
what is important to us it's to let the
players play the way they want like we
have our two primary pillars that are
combat and stealth and sorry
and uh we have the secondary modes that
are uh hacking and social and for us
it's really really important to make
sure that players can play the way they
want and when i say the way they want
it's not just stealth or comeback but
it's killing or not killing or even just
totally avoid confrontation at all so
because you could do stealth and kill
yes right absolutely yes and you can be
combat and not kill uh go and fight and
not and not kill anyone yeah you know
put everybody to sleep and and
neutralize them with uh yeah the tesla
gun and all these kind of things yeah
that's that's one of the thing that we
wanted to do with this game with john
what you just said the fact that we uh
we want to make stealth and combat
more intertwined together in the sense
that and if you look at human revolution
a lot of the tools you add at your
disposal whether it was augmentations or
or weapons uh the their their behaviors
like let's say some of the stealth ones
uh or the non-lethal one was kind of uh
forcing you or was more useful when you
were stealthy but in combat you would
have failed for mankind divided like you
just said like with the gun arms now we
have uh yes the nano blade that is legal
but we have the the pepsi
gun arm we have the tesla gun arm which
are uh totally non-little weapons and
you can go in the fray and use them and
just knock unconscious people and
continue so yeah back to your guns if
you want to everything is a lot more
like wholesome it's a lot it's a lot
more holistic this kind of discount i
call it like the ballet of like going
between your ogs and your weapons or
just stain to your ogs or whatever and
use them non-lethal or lethal and
everything just kind of intertwines very
very well which is a thing we didn't
really have in human rights exactly so
it was really important to offer more
choices within the same realm of
possibilities as human rights it just
flows so much better
what kind of choices do you guys make
when you play do you have a
preference for going stealth or for
going just all out guns blazing i like
i'm the kind of guy i'm like the the
stealthy killer i guess i like to just
kind of infiltrate and you know it's a
very kind of metal gear solid approach
right just kind of infiltrate making
sure i don't get noticed or whatever and
but still kind of take people down and
yeah that's that's what i do and me i
try i'm stealthy too but i'm trying to
uh
to avoid people as much as i can and
just take down
take down the ones i feel i have to take
down but i don't kill them and i just
breathe my way through and i explore
everything and making sure that i find
all the little secrets readables
whatever yeah i play usually i play
quite stealthy but um there's games like
for example it's not a stealth game but
mass effect but i usually try and play
as a paragon and then every now and then
i encounter a character which i dislike
so much that i want to kill that's good
so i bend my rules now and then and do
you kind of like as a developer do you
think about that and do you build that
into the game do you try and you know
put in these situations where you know
we want to try and create a character
that kind of upsets the players who
would traditionally be kind of docile
and try and avoid combat to get them to
engage in other types of systems do you
think about that
well i question yeah i think our
approach is more first and foremost what
we want is to create interesting
characters that you will love to hate or
just love or maybe hate to love
hate to love
and uh our goal yeah it's more to to
create those those different characters
and one thing that we always see is that
uh in our world nothing is black or
white it's all shades of grey so we're
always trying to to build complex
characters that have good sides have bad
sides and we're all different human
beings and we we don't like all the same
stuff so some characters for you might
be like oh i want to punch him but for
some other people no this person is
actually like a good person and i like
uh her or uh m for x y reasons kind of
thing and that would probably generate
what you're talking about by creating
good characters you know that have like
real not real personalities but like
good artificial personalities or
whatever
probably everybody will eventually find
someone that's just like oh this guy's
annoying me a little bit it's like frank
pritchard in the last game yeah a lot of
people like were hating him but some
other people no when you think about
that it's one of the few characters
throughout the entire game that doesn't
lie to you
exactly he's really he's the guy you can
trust yeah but he's an [__] yeah yeah
or wayne oz you know the police guy
which we all hated because it was so
weak and so whiny and everybody hated
him you know so yeah but it wasn't
planned that way
yeah so one of my favorite characters
who i'm wondering is gonna wherever she
make a return is latisha the trash lady
do you remember her
no will she be making a comeback
i really hope she does
she's amazing
one of my favorite things about games
with choice especially like the witcher
or mass effect or
your ability to to romance characters as
well you know that's a way to interact
with characters is that something you
ever thought about introducing in some
way into the deus ex franchise against
you know make love not more our fans are
so good at creating those romances
after the fact we don't have to do it i
mean you just type you know the sx human
revolution fan art you're going to see
some pretty horror some good stuff and
some horrible you want to turn safe
yeah i should do that
but sorry jeff go ahead
um
what was the question
no no no actually we were
it's something that we discuss and
everything but uh for the kind of game
we we were going and the themes that
were exploring we we didn't want to
distract and go into directions that in
the end like it doesn't necessarily
helps the purpose of telling the story
we want to tell and everything so we we
thought about that but for us it was not
necessarily bringing something uh
super important to what we're trying to
do and therefore we didn't do that yeah
this is your new breach mode right yes
that's uh that's breach uh it's a new
gameplay mode and uh what is cool with
that is that we wanted to uh to use the
core mechanics of uh of the sx and we
wanted to have a fresh spin on it like i
have a new kind of arcade twist where
it's just simple uh fast running and
puzzle solving and uh
and everything and also we wanted to
have a fresh look a different uh visual
style explore something
a new art direction exactly yeah and for
us it was kind of like one of our uh uh
lines when we developed it's uh uh we
want to break expectations and for us a
bridge mode was a way to do that so it
ties even though it's left field a bit
it's kind of a virtual reality world
where corporations are storing their own
private information and everything and
you play a ripper which is kind of a
hacker into the virtual world and they
are kind of like the
digital era kind of robin hoods and
they're trying to really expose the
truth about all those corporations to
keep the the
uh the world a better place to keep
those corporations more in line and uh
not abusing of their power and stuff
like that so there's a basic premise and
a uh story lines in there that you can
unravel but it's especially uh built
around like the the fun gameplay in the
pure uh arcade uh experience and there's
a social component to it where you can
challenge friends like you you can send
them a map with different modifiers
different conditions to win the map and
uh if your friend accepts the challenge
and wins he gets the point and he climbs
up in the leaderboard or if if uh he
fails you get the points and you climb
up so it's really fun and that that dual
thing is is what i really like and what
i really like about breach as well
because it's more like bite size uh
little kind of
gameplay um um environments and whatnot
and and because it's it's using kind of
the same mechanics of of the main game
the same kind of augmentations and
whatever what i like is if you're let's
say like a stealth player right when you
play mankind divided and you're you're
mostly having a stealth build right a
stealth atom um well then if you go if
you go play breach the cool thing is
that now you might start indulging into
the more uh uh um
offense kind of office kind of kind of
augmentations and went and have fun with
that without affecting the build you
have in the main game
and also it's our first live mode we're
going to collect the data from players
as they play so we'll be able to to
fine-tune stuff it if needs be and also
we have extra content that is going to
be unleashed after uh the release of the
game which is nice as well yeah
and it seems like you know introducing
this kind of technology have you have
you guys thought about virtual reality
itself you know something that ties both
into this world and is a really big
theme for 2016.
yes
[Laughter]
so next question
but actually we have uh we're going to
uh release a benchmark tool this summer
and it's supposed to come with
a virtual reality experience like just
like uh exploring some of the
environments of mankind divided like uh
i can as a gift to the fans
and just being in uh yeah it's crazy
it's more like a museum mode like
there's
gameplay through um but i mean i'd be
environments that you no
totally lying to you guys if i were to
tell you that idos montreal doesn't have
virtual reality kits uh and that we
haven't played with them or whatever but
uh but uh i mean of course if a
developer now doesn't doesn't have them
it's kind of so you know something
something happened i don't know what but
i'm going to leave it at that
for now for sure well jf john thanks so
much for for taking the time and walking
us through deus ex mankind divided and
for even more uh excitement and deus ex
action here at e3 2016. stay tuned to
gamespot.com
what's up everybody tyrod here with
jimmy thang at e3 2016 and um jimmy i
need to know
i think a lot of people need to know
what the [__] is a teraflop
uh so teraflop it actually stands for uh
terra basically is one trillion so one
trillion uh floating operations uh per
segment yes that's basically what it
means it's the technical term
basically it's uh
a unit of computing measurement how many
uh tasks can it handle at a time
essentially how many floating point
tasks can handle
and so yeah this morning uh you know
microsoft you know unveiled the project
scorpio it's like six teraflops so it's
six trillion floating point operations
per second and that's what i was trying
to figure out i think for a lot of
people
jimmy thing here with scott butterworth
and scott you had the chance to check
out some playstation vr titles recently
can you yeah yeah i know just last night
i was at the uh the sony press
conference that did this whole big vr
event directly afterwards we're showing
a bunch of stuff that they announced
during the press conference actually so
a lot of games we've already seen like
100 foot robot golf and harmonix vr but
also tons of stuff that was just
announced last night cool can you walk
us through some of the biggest battles
that you saw uh so let's see so i saw
final fantasy i saw the final fantasy 15
vr experience uh which is in first
person looks like yeah it's weird it
doesn't really feel like much of a
fantasy game i mean it's just a straight
up like first person shooter experience
basically you're fighting one giant boss
with the help of some of the other
characters from the upcoming game uh but
you can kind of like warp around the
environment but really it's just like
you have the one move controller and
you're aiming at the boss and like just
shooting until it dies and that's kind
of the entire experience you know if
it's going to be multiplayer is that why
the other characters you know i was
asking them about that after the demo
and they really weren't willing to
divulge any other information i asked if
there's going to be you know more levels
or a different gameplay and all of it's
to be determined even the release dates
to be determined so
it was interesting to see those
characters kind of up close and personal
and and to see all that in vr but yeah
it didn't really feel like any final
fantasy game that i've ever played it
was it was a bit of a weird little demo
uh so i don't know if it'll actually
result in a full game but that's what
last night's experience was so wasn't
super crazy about this experience but
then again like final fantasy in vr it's
kind of a shooter
yeah just shooter
vr title gamepl they showed that one was
actually a little bit disappointing too
it's just kind of a very very
straightforward sci-fi shooter it's just
you on a kind of mars looking rocky
dusty planet shooting a bunch of bug
alien type of things okay the
environments were pretty believable it
was really cool to get to walk around
and it does have this crazy peripheral
that was just announced it's basically
the successor to the there was like what
was it the sheer shot the move shear
shot back when the playstation move was
a thing during the ps3 days sure it's
kind of a version of that it's like this
rifle peripheral and it actually has a
joystick and a d-pad on it so you use
that to maneuver through the environment
but you still aim and shoot using the uh
the trigger and the headset i was
talking the other day you said batman
was surprisingly batman was surprisingly
cool so for anybody that's played the
arkham games if you know like the
detective sections where you're
analyzing a crime scene it was basically
that uh but in vr so you could actually
view a crime yeah exactly it's all in
first person so you could view the crime
from multiple angles uh kind of the same
thing as final fantasy where there were
certain spots around the environment
that you could warp to but because it
wasn't action it didn't actually feel as
limiting uh you you could basically just
like scrub through the playback by
twisting your wrist with the move
controller in your hand uh so the whole
the whole experience is framed is
basically a murder mystery where you're
trying to solve the murder of dick
grayson which is kind of a cool
narrative conceit according to the devs
it's only about an hour-long experience
but what i played so far was actually
like pretty cool what else did you check
out uh let's see oh another thing was
resident evil that was great so for
anybody that saw the conference that
room that you see in that trailer that
you're kind of like walking through this
derelict house with like peeling
wallpaper and all that kind of stuff
that's basically what the demo was um i
think this is actually the same level
that's playable on the downloadable demo
on psn but i got to play it in vr so
it's really cool you play with the
dualshock 4 so it's about what you would
expect from the controls in the movement
and all that but you actually can look
around the environment and you feel a
little bit more immersed
welcome back to the gamespot stage here
at e3 2016 here to talk about horizon
zero dawn we've got herman and jb from
gorilla games guys thank you so much for
joining myself and tomorrow
what a fantastic show you had at the
sony press conference what was it like
being able to show the game off to the
world you know
last year we showed that boss fight and
this year we wanted to go in and really
just show the game the way it plays just
it actually is a part of the game it
wasn't a demo and that felt really
really good yeah you really go into the
nitty-gritty of like moment-to-moment
gameplay instead of having this one big
boss fight i think a lot of questions
after the after the you know debut were
like what is what is it beyond this
amazing massive like also kind of
looking scripted boss fight but you
obviously put to rest those questions
showing that it's there's there's like a
massive open world you know you have
these all these options and it was an
excellent view like it was one of my
highlights of of the uh the press
conference for sure thank you thank you
you like this man
we're already getting questions in from
the chat people are asking let's start
with things like um
all the robots all the ais are they all
hostile
so no they're not all hostile there are
more
docile machines so for example the brass
heads that you saw which are the bull
like creatures they don't naturally
attack on sight if you poke them with a
stick they will surely come after you
but generally they kind of doze out and
but the bigger ones especially the sort
of more predatory looking ones they will
attack on site and they're very
dangerous from a narrative perspective i
know the story we have is kind of
rediscovering what happened to humanity
but is there ever like an exploration of
your impact on the machine animals
because like you see these animals and
all the other machines you still kind of
sympathize with them when you when
you're taking these dorsal animals and
kind of killing them or like subverting
what they're supposed to be doing is
their own exploration like of your
responsibility to nature around you even
if it is kind of disconnected because
it's machine you know it was funny we uh
sony made this uh this watcher suit
watcher is the little
the little one
that you first encountered pretty much
and they did it behind the scenes thing
so jb and i walk in
and the first thing you want to do is
pet it it was like an
et moment you want to touch it
and be gentle with it yeah i mean
we have this tendency these days to kind
of treat like machines for example bb-8
as if with the same kind of love that we
would for like a kitten or something
like that exactly like it's it's kind of
seeing seeing the kind of the broad well
they're called broad broadheads but yeah
when you kind of
take over it and and kind of mount it
and that kind of thing i was like oh man
that sucks like i hope i hope that thing
is going to be all right and when you're
fight i mean there's a few hostile
enemies which is fine but like there's a
few docile enemies that you kind of trap
and kind of you you scavenge and use for
resources that were kind of pulling at
my heartstrings even though i didn't
expect it which is really interesting
aylor is very respectful of nature and
of the machine so she doesn't feel like
she's just killing them for killing sake
she's after the resources she needs it
right it's a function she's a huntress
but in a way that respects the prey one
of the things i really appreciate was
when you were attacking an enemy she
kind of you hear her speaking and and
saying like i really need the the
resources before she starts doing that
is that something that happens like
throughout the game is she always
narrating it
so there is a certain amount of
self-talk to also basically bring the
story across but for the demo purposes
of course there was a little bit of
extra talk there to also explain what
was going on okay i noticed there's a
there's conversation options is there
kind of um do they affect how the game
plays out is it a major difference or is
it just kind of more of a
a slight change
more like sightseeing it's just more
like talking to people in real life
you're not changing the world by having
a conversation but there are
life-and-death situations that you can
impact by fire dialogue the main thing
that we want to do with the dialogue is
that it's a form of exploration you're
exploring the world via dialogue and
you're exploring aloysia character and
the other characters around you as well
you can pick up quests and side quests
in the dialogue as well okay stepping
back a bit like you guys are like one of
the most exciting things about and i
think the reason why people like took to
it so quickly was you because you guys
are known as the killzone studio the
first person shooter studio this is so
far different from what we expected from
you guys like maybe everyone's thinking
we'll get a different type of shooter
from gorilla this is such a
you know a pivot for you guys when did
you come up with this and how confident
were you that you could pull this off
going into it was it a case of like
learning as you go along or were you
kind of like confident that you had the
skill set to create an open world action
game
a bit of everything there we um we
started after we completed kills on
three that was in 2011. it's been a long
project we've been working this for
quite a while
and and obviously we're building on what
we learned in killzone there's the
tactical combat there there's obviously
the creating of of gorgeous worlds that
what we're after
but at the same time you know it is our
first open world game it's our first
world that that has quests in it so we
we did hire
some very bespoke teams we hired a
writing team with experience in this
genre
quest designers and all of that is new
to the studio right
one of the interesting things coming
from first person shooters and
understanding combat really deeply and
comet spaces really deeply sort of helps
us to also deliver a new experience to
the rpg genre
and how deep is the rpg genre i mean i
i've seen um interview footage like you
know there's um
uh
damage counts and stuff like that how
deep does that go
so it's not very heavily stats based
it's not basically that every plus minus
where all your weapons basically really
matters it's more broader strokes
but the real opportunity element is more
in the character progression so being
able to build her up there's a skill
tree there there's dialogue options of
course there's a lot speaking to do with
your character in this world i'm
interested in how you balance that kind
of
the scavenging element of it you're
trying to you know gather resources and
create stuff with and people in games
traditionally you kind of get the
satisfaction you portray that
satisfaction by you know increasing
damage numbers so you know you scavenge
you get this thing you build a better
gun and then you see that your numbers
are higher it doesn't look like you're
trying to do that so how do you kind of
you know really emphasize that
scavenging is important in this game
well one part is basically that you're
building up your weapons but a large
part is actually sort of learning and
studying maybe it's not just the
experience of your character but it's
the experience of you as a player that
really matters by learning their
behaviors analyzing them scanning the
robots finding their weak spots finding
the right tools to deal with them and
getting ever better at defeating them
right um
let's talk a little bit about the other
human characters that eli is going to
come into contact with so it seems like
she's she's an outsider she wants to
find out like why that happened to her
who who are the people who aren't you
know aren't being nice to her who are
the people who she's kind of up against
butting heads with
well she's an outcast out of a very
specific tribe right and in the trailer
that we released last week the week
before
uh she's looked after by this gentleman
a very gentle man that that basically
adopted her uh he's an outcast as well
and and so that tribe kind of is her
initial reference but there are other
tribes and it's a little early to talk
too much about the other humans in the
game because that that'll come over the
coming months
but is there anything else we want to
talk about that for now
i think because he is an outcast he's
not necessarily that culturally embedded
in the nora type where she where she was
raised
so that sort of makes her more of an
explorer somebody basically that has a
different point of view and is willing
to accept different points of view in
the rest of the world as well and i
would add that she um there's a lot of
of myth and legend and and lore within
these tribes and you uh you know we're
just talking about the dialogue system
through
exploring that you find out that she's
she's very much a practical person she
challenges those myths that are out
there and she um she's very practical
she's down to earth and and so she's not
she's kind of in the tribe but kind of
outside too she really you do play as
her as a separate person how much how
long has she been kind of outcast and
separated from the thread because i'm
wondering
from birth okay so so so exploring the
world she's almost discovering it in
terms of the different cultures in the
same way that the player is right
yeah well the the nora tribe itself
versus race is a little bit of an
isolationist tribe they don't really
venture out they don't talk to other
tribes they have their own culture they
have their own religion so
first of all leaving the tribe and then
going out outside basically she gets
different points of views and also
there's of course a lot of legends and
mitch myths about how the worlds came to
be like this and every tribe has their
take on it and some of them are complete
crap others basically might have a hint
of truth even so basically looking
through that and talking to people and
exploring it you get to learn a little
bit about how this will will fit
together there's also the mention of
demons
what is that all about so it seems like
you've got so many warring factions here
how do the demons think you see the the
machines in the game they're they're
animalistic looking right they're all
inspired by by some animals except for
that corrupter that you see on the
screen right now and a lawyer actually
doesn't know machines like that she
encounters them
but she's unfamiliar with them and these
are the corrupters they're they're kind
of
old world machines that are unknown to
her okay
so i mean in terms of the world itself
um in the trailers you know there was a
civilization that came before that maybe
got too great collapsed in on itself and
now nature's taking the world back is it
definitely kind of like based on
humanity as it is right now is it an
alternate
kind of world dimension no it's humanity
right it is humanity yeah it is us
where exactly this is
we were not really revealing yet or
though the internet basically has made
some good guesses
some screen uh like frame by frame maybe
some references also makes a lot of
guesses yeah they make it's always a
good concept it must be great to see
that happening though even if it's kind
of off base to see that
you've clearly thought or created this
world that is resonating enough for
people to want to stop and look at a
frame by frame especially as you know
working on art and that kind of stuff
that must be like super satisfying oh
yeah it's really fun basically just
going through the forums and making
people analyzing it one by frame and
then sometimes getting it right and
often getting it completely wrong but
it's fun basically seeing their fairies
questions from the chat they're asking
um are we going to be able to visit any
of the cities like the broken down
cities from before or is it all going to
be wilderness-based gameplay
it's a seamless open world game you can
go anywhere you can go to the mountain
tops you can go to the rivers you can
explore the cities the villages the
settlements
interior spaces
wow everything very impressive
and in terms of like building a world
outside of outside of the game have you
thought about that whether you want to
explore it in stuff like comics or like
you know books novels that's the kind of
thing that everyone's doing now everyone
with the world wants to exploit the
world and
build it with it outside of it so
we're very focused on finishing this one
and making it really good first and then
basically i'm sure basically we'll
explore lots of different ways of
doing things with this universe oh but
it's a great idea we'll we'll take it
back to this also yeah tell everyone i'm
down for some comics
time is big i'm a big comic dude so i'm
always looking forward to it and
multiplayer like have you ever thought
about it yeah i mean killzone
had uh perhaps overlooked multiplayer
like it's it's had his an amazing few
modes like and and
more people should probably have
borrowed from some of them but um have
you thought about maybe bringing some
more multiplayer stuff
we think about a lot of different things
but we've decided very clearly that a
horizon zero dawn is going to be a
single player game right so i'm going to
stick with that and that's
it is already a new ip for us it's in a
new genre uh there's so much newness
that a studio should take on before
blowing itself up so we we decided to
just keep it at single player for now in
terms of the creature design obviously
um
very heavily influenced by real life
creatures what kind of artistic
liberties can you take with them can you
sort of see creatures in real life and
think well if i'm making a robot version
i might do
this or add this uh yeah whether there's
sort of there's of course requirements
from the designers what they want to see
and in some cases where they come up
with really outrageous ideas sometimes
that works sometimes it doesn't what's
been the craziest thing that someone
said no to
i don't think basically we've said no to
anything yet very tricky
we had to basically let a couple of them
go maybe they were a little bit too
ambitious
we've got a very good selection of the
current machines in the game
so the big boss fight that we saw at the
press conference are there multiple ways
to take down that one enemy what i mean
is that kind of like
do you have to have all those weapons
going in to be able to take it down can
you take it down with like complete bare
bones or do you have to have there's a
ton of different options out there i
mean it's the the attacks on it it's got
that arm that for it's kind of a long
range close combat if you will the
signature attack i would say is that
jump on you but it also uses the
environment throwing rocks you can play
with it she does a number of things that
you could do more of for instance and
replace it by some other things right
she's got the uh
the the explosive traps
but there's things like uh like tripwire
you can use you can have multiple kinds
of long-range
there's so many a ton of different
options everybody at the studio that
plays it it's got their own style of
playing it it's never the same i've seen
it played a couple of times on the stage
floor basically by our own colleagues
and everyone deals with it differently
and some of them have become really sort
of graceful where they're sliding
underneath its legs and jumping over it
like whoa i think we've got one qa guy
that can actually play it exactly the
way it was recorded at uh for for the
sony press conference uh but jb and i
couldn't do it exactly like that nor do
we want to it's very it requires skill
um the dishonest guys say that um when
they've been play testing and seeing
people play people come up with
unexpected things that they didn't
anticipate with all the systems working
together have you guys encountered that
at all
emergent game design wow what is the
best
you can anticipate emerging game design
that's where it's emerging
of course we try a lot of things
ourselves we we do start playing with
the systems and then basically ask the
programmers to change it a little bit to
make something weird and fantastical
possible i would give as an example um
we have some of these grazers in there
they have the canisters on the back
uh
they're explo explodable explosive
that's proper english here uh but now
it's kind of become a running thing for
us to get a herd together and shoot the
guy in the middle and then boom boom
boom they all go off and that's not
something that was designed as such but
it just is one of the funnest thing to
do right there well guys thank you so
much when can we get our hands on
horizon zero dawn it's going to be out
here in the u.s on the 28th of february
next year wonderful thank you so much
for joining us and of course for more
coverage from this year's e3 make sure
you keep your eyes peeled to
gamespot.com
what's up everyone we are here at e3
2016. i'm mike mccarty and i just shred
some gnarly pow dude i tried it more now
than you did this is alex's new house
and we played steep the uh recently as
of yesterday
uh open world extreme winter sports game
i guess you could call it by ubisoft and
see uh so we got to play about 15
minutes i think yeah about 15 minutes
and the cool thing about this game is
you got four different sports that you
can pretty much choose from wherever you
are yeah you got skiing snowboarding
wing suiting and paragliding what was
your favorite i really liked the wing
suits i think that's it was super cool
it was really awesome to be flying
through the alps and having to dodge
crags and there's one point where you
can shoot through like a rock hole
and uh i i failed dramatically you
actually managed to do it but yeah so
you have different spawn points you go
to this overworld map and uh there are
different like peaks you start on or
just like mountain villages or like
actual trick race courses uh alex and i
both went up to the the like paragliding
start and the guy from ubisoft told us
not to move because once you quit the
wing suit if you move it all that just
registers as the jump so alex of course
turns jumps onto his face on the
platform and then rolls down the
mountain while i'm left there to
actually be good at the game um skiing
was a little easier snowboarding felt
weird there's definitely a learning
curve it's kind of
for like an open world game based on
exploration it felt very much like it's
a technical game right and i think the
biggest problem we both had with it was
the controls the controls are meant to
be more simulation than arcade so don't
think ssx tricky and so with
snowboarding the jumps are on the
triggers and you also have to tap the
triggers to spin so it's a little it was
hard to get used to yeah and you can go
like with the first person gopro viewers
by tapping lv which i didn't know until
i was halfway through a jump smash my
face uh but also yeah it's you know like
it's kind of eddie mccoo our news editor
also saw he really liked it um but he
was the one he got used to the controls
a little earlier on than we did i think
me and you were kind of more interested
in the open world aspects because you
know the game four is a horizon three
which is also announced right at the
show and that's kind of the same lure of
the open world just exploring like with
driving in that case in this case just
like flying down the slopes and
everything um definitely learning curve
but i feel like once you get through it
that game could be pretty fun yeah and
they even gave us the option to do races
and i'm like nah i didn't want to do
that i just kind of roamed around the
mountain doing like switching between
skiing and snowboarding trying to do
wing suiting trying and failing
spectacularly to do paragliding um but i
actually thought the the first person
thing was super cool because it
it felt a little more like the controls
made sense from that view but yeah i
think it has a lot of promise yeah so
they were telling us that was just like
a small part of the overall map it was
still pretty sizable but you know you
could just roam around if you want to
which is the most appealing aspect to me
and maybe you too but anyway so yeah
that was steep uh that releases december
of this year from ubisoft's anna c for
more news about that i'm sure we'll have
a write-up coming up and for more news
from e3 2016 stay tuned to game spot
i think he worked with a friend of mine
um matt aldridge
yeah
he's i think he said
did you help lincoln clay murder sal
marcano and all prominent members of his
crime family
you're goddamn right i did hold my
head to the bottom of the
[Music]
marks the largest number of casualties
in the ongoing conflict
[Music]
will rejoice when he sees the vengeance
it took me months to figure out that
lincoln had survived the massacre and
was waging a war against sao marcono
there's this craze on the cross heard
you were dead been hearing that a lot
it's over this is never going to be over
[Music]
you shot him once
oh baby
[Music]
hello welcome back to the game sports
stage here at e3 2016 brought to you by
airheads bites joining myself antamor
hussein on the couch today to talk about
mafia 3 we have studio head creative
director hangar 13 on matthew 3 we've
got hayden blackman hello thank you for
joining us thanks for having me what
what's the reception to mafia 3 been
like uh so far it's been great it seems
like i'm you know we're really humbled
to be able to show it and have people
respond so so nicely about it i guess
and you have an insanely huge booth on
the e3 show floor yeah the booth is
pretty incredible i was i think you know
in almost 20 years i think coming here
this is the
the coolest booth i've ever been yeah
i saw it earlier today before all the
crowds had
come in and i was impressed with how
look how it looked then and then when
there's people around it everyone seems
to be buzzing and really enjoying it and
obviously you released a trailer for the
game recently which we were just
watching and it's got a really really
impressive trailer great great music i
love that music i was just telling you
that it's a great choice of music but it
really sells the kind of like the kind
of the quest and the play that you know
the characters are going through to in
mafia well just the vibe i mean the
whole you know
so much about the game is about the
atmosphere and the you know obviously
the main characters mission but the
atmosphere the city the music all that
comes into and just immerses you so
which is why the booth is so nice
because you walk in and you just feel
like you're in new bordeaux you know our
version of new orleans right away yeah
exactly and that's the kind of the main
thing here right it's it's like selling
this this this era that you're in and at
the same time having having a story in
there you got other games similar like
you know saints row or grand theft auto
they have a kind of vibe but this
there's something about mafia 3 that
feels like it's really honing in on the
new orleans kind of vibe and trying to
make that its focus in a way that other
games don't do it yeah i mean it was
really important to us just in terms of
the franchise as a whole i always look
at it see the city is a main character
you know and mafia too that was true in
mafia 3 we want that to be true so we've
really focused a lot of effort into
trying to make sure that the city feels
like a main character feels vibrant it
feels alive um it has there's 10
different districts each of them have
kind of their own unique criminal
ecology their own unique makeup in terms
of pedestrians and the types of
encounters you have there so
that was hugely important to us and then
again the the soundtrack and um i think
you know the other thing's really
important is not just a unique sense of
time and place but also the protagonist
you know making sure that lincoln feels
like you know he's somebody that stands
out a little bit that he's he's a
vietnam vet he's an orphan he's been
looking for this place to belong all of
his life and that was also kind of a key
element for us in terms of not just the
narrative but just the entire experience
also lincoln clay he's a biracial
protagonist you're dealing with
incredibly sensitive subjects yeah are
you guys kind of prepared like
for the scrutiny i guess that's going to
come off of that you know i don't know
if you're ever prepared
um i you know when we went into it we
really just wanted to tell a great story
and create an experience that um you
can't get you know kind of anywhere else
to me that's the value of working in
games to begin with is that we're
dealing with an interactive medium and
we can put you in the shoes of a
character that you can't be you know
none of us lived through you know 1968
really you know living in the south
being biracial all these things are
things that are kind of and being a
criminal on top of that all that's
unique to lincoln's experience so we
just wanted to again create a compelling
experience um
and we're not trying to get up on a
soapbox but if we can get people to
think about race a little bit then i
think we've kind of won you know yeah i
guess the the interesting thing or the
thing that might be worth elaborating on
is how lincoln goes from being a vietnam
war veteran kind of fighting for his
country to transitioning into like
working almost within a criminal empire
against maybe against a criminal but
also kind of like existing in a criminal
world it's essentially going from being
you know this clean you know fighting
for your country type good guy to almost
flirting with with evil like how does he
make that transition why does he make
that yes so the way that the story
unfolds is um again we introduce the
fact that lincoln's an orphan uh fairly
early on in the game and this kind of
concept of he's always looking for a
place to belong you know he's always
looking for some sense of family after
the orphanage closes when he's kind of
you know in his uh early teens he falls
in with the black mob in the city run by
a guy named sammy robinson who has a son
a kid named ellis and they kind of bring
lincoln into the fold and treat him like
a son and a brother
but still he's not
you know he's not sammy's son ellis is
going to inherit the throne you know uh
so lincoln is still looking for that
place to belong and then when the war
breaks out he joins the military and he
goes off for three years uh to vietnam
but that's not what he expected either
and that wasn't you know that's not the
sense of a family and place that he
wants so when he comes back to new
bordeaux his plan is to actually keep
moving he wants to come back he wants to
say goodbye to sammy and ellis and then
actually move out to the west coast um
and then he finds out that sammy's in
trouble with uh the italian mob
owesomely to the italian mob uh and
lincoln's kind of fatal flaw is heroic
quality that turns out to be a liability
is his loyalty he's very loyal to sammy
and he agrees to help out
and then that kind of puts the you know
uh puts the wheels in motion and do you
do you kind of explore how far he's
willing to go to help out a friend
because like we said he has he is adrift
and his his kind of maybe his moral
center isn't defined properly yet but at
the same time he he seems to be a good
guy at heart but when he's forced to do
things like engage with a mob in a mob
you know battlefield type thing is there
ever do you have it so that he's
questioning himself and is he kind of
exploring what's right and wrong as he
goes along
early on it's we're very focused on that
sense of you know he is loyal and he's i
don't say it's unquestioning i mean he
definitely takes charge of the situation
says well this is how we're going to
deal with it because you know again he's
coming back with all this training and
he was in the special forces over there
so he's bringing all that knowledge to
bear
what he does wrestle with and what we
actually hope the player wrestles with
is after the the night of blood after
this betrayal happens lincoln recruits
these three underbosses um one of them
is vito scaletta who's the
but he recruits these 300 bosses and
we're constantly
tempting the player to choose between
kind of greed and power and loyalty with
those characters and so that is one of
the central tensions in the game so
lincoln's wrestling with this because he
wants you know to become as powerful as
possible as quickly as possible to take
down sal marcano who's the big uh mob
villain in the game um but at the same
time if he makes certain decisions as he
goes along he's betraying or you know
not being 100 loyal to these these other
bosses and that can cause some rifts in
that group bringing veto back um
obviously mafia 2's got a big fan base
and it was it was a great game was that
more
in service of like giving fans uh kind
of something to latch onto or is it is
it something that you really thought
about in terms of integrating into a
story to create a wider mafia kind of
narrative and universe yeah you know it
was it was a little bit of both to be
honest right so we sat down and we
started looking at what story do we want
to tell and one of the first decisions
we had to make is is this the same
universe like do we want to create a
cohesive universe
for me i'm really big on that i feel
like we you know we have this franchise
and we have this mafia universe we want
to keep building on it so it made sense
for us to reference characters from the
past film our path game and characters
from you know uh one and two um
locations from one and two um
so uh you know we really wanted to to
make sure it felt like it was grounded
in that universe um we referenced leo
and some other characters and then when
we started digging into it
the big question was well what has vito
been doing right since mafia too and we
came up with a really good hook that you
know we know that he got shipped out
from empire bay got sent away so where
did he get sent well he got sent to new
bordeaux but there's this natural
tension between him and the other mob
boss who runs it because he sees vito is
like this carpet bagger who's maybe
there to spy on him or whatever so he
kind of sidelines veto so for that for
us that was a really interesting
kind of dynamic and it put vito in a
really interesting spot because here he
feels like he's been sidelined and been
punished by being sent to new bordeaux
right and when lincoln shows up um it
gives vito a chance to kind of show that
he's you know he's worth more than maybe
the local mob at least thanks how do you
resist the temptation to kind of
maintain a focus on lincoln because a
lot of people will love veto already
yeah he's got a history and
you imagine there's going to be a huge
part of your fan base like man we want
to see more veto how do you like
give them what they want to see or veto
but also maintain the focus on lincoln
well so for us again
we look at it as kind of almost the
player choice in terms of how much they
want to engage with veto so you have
these three under bosses right and if
you want to give everything to veto and
spend all your time you know kind of
building up him you absolutely can and
it comes at the kind of expensive
relationships with the other two
characters potentially
but again at the end of the day we
wanted to create an experience going
back to that notion that we're creating
an experience that
it feels unique right so for us that's
why lincoln became kind of the
centerpiece and the focus but you know
veto is integral to the plot and i think
you meet him in the first you know half
hour of the game and then he becomes a
steady presence from then on
so you formed a new studio just to
create mafia 3 right what was the
like you going into the project was
there a lot of pressure and how did you
kind of work i remember reading an
interview when you first went you said
you were going to work on some propriety
technology what what came of that and
how was the journey been yeah so uh when
i joined 2k that was one of the things
that i really wanted to focus on was
proprietary tech
mostly just because that's what i'm
comfortable with i you know in almost
every project i've ever worked on has
been proprietary um and then and i
really wanted to work on you know kind
of innovative open world games um so
when and i love world building so those
three things kind of coalesce and when
the opportunity to work on mafia kind of
presented itself it became a no-brainer
because it ticked off all three of those
boxes for me is obviously an open world
and we can push some boundaries with it
um it's world building you know as i
talked about trying to create this mafia
universe and then we were building it
off of proprietary tech some of which
was based on what was built from mafia
too so they you know that team continued
to iterate and and kind of
rev that engine and and then we came in
and we built a whole bunch of new tools
on top of it and obviously pushed it for
you know the the current gen so um but
you know it's not without its challenges
but it's super exciting because there's
you know any problem we face
we can solve on our own we're kind of we
have our you know
our destinies in our hands because it is
proprietary attack and we're not trying
to take you know our vision and shoehorn
it into some existing tech you know is
there a big sharing culture of tech
amongst the 2k studios uh
you know the games are so different that
not really i mean we're you know i think
we have communication and we talk about
techniques and you know share ideas and
and whatnot but um for us you know we
were so hyper focused on trying to
realize this time in this place and this
world and this character and
we had very specific goals for our
cinematics and very specific goals for
our core gameplay um that it made sense
for us to be you know kind of heads down
you know
in realizing this well the thing that's
kind of striking to me is like there's
plenty of mafia source material out
there there's films move you know other
games
books
but
so like if you're creating a traditional
mafia game
which some might say mafia one and mafia
too where you've got a lot of source
material or inspiration whereas this
feels like it doesn't quite feel like a
mafia mafia game there's not like a huge
italian mob type influence so like what
were you looking to for inspiration when
you were kind of building this new
orleans world and well i think you know
one of my goals from the outset was we
wanted to kind of reclaim the term mafia
to mean organize crime in general and to
start to expand it beyond just the the
italian mob obviously they play a huge
role in the game they're you know you're
working for the italian mob early on
you're going up against the italian
oblater you have veto in in kind of your
organization he's obviously you know
represents kind of that romanticized
view of the mob um but once a lot of it
was driven by the time period to be
honest once we decided that we were
going to be in the late 60s
the vibe
changed right that you know when you
have
looking at the mob in the 30s and 40s it
was a much more romanticized thing right
even when we look back on it and it's
like you know you we know that al capone
was a brutal guy but you look back on it
and it's you know we tend to romanticize
it and a lot of the films
set during that era do too and and um
and that was great for mafia too because
that was kind of the inspiration and
that's what they were trying to capture
but by the 60s you know the mob was
finally being recognized by the fbi as a
criminal organization some of the sheen
was coming off of it they were no longer
just involved in you know what was then
called victimless crimes which we know
there's no such thing but the kind of
fun stuff right like oh you know they're
bootleggers right and they and they deal
with gambling and kind of these
victimless crimes which again is a
misnomer but
by the 60s you knew that they were
involved in much harder stuff and and
especially with the drug trade um and so
i think that that kind of sheen fell off
of it people realized it wasn't just a
kind of social club it was a real right
you know kind of dangerous criminal
organization and we're sort of tackling
that and showing that this is the end of
kind of the golden era of the
traditional mob um and the rise of you
know kind of new criminal organizations
that can compete and you know drugs play
a huge role in that we have that as a
kind of sub uh current in our game i was
reading about how the godfather actually
changed the way the real mafia worked
yeah as in it's a lot of its current
systems are based on what was
established in that piece it's a
fictional layer right so maybe you'll
have some sort of assembly so it's like
you'll undo that with your more accurate
portrayal of what mafia means yeah maybe
who knows will there be references to
sort of real world events from the late
60s in the game things like mlk and yeah
i mean obviously uh you know lincoln
clay is a vietnam vet so that's that's
uh always running through the the
background um we're really grounded in
in
1968 um and we reference events that
happen all around that time period so
obviously it was such a turbulent year
with you know the mlk assassination
robert kennedy
um yeah the like uh the democratic
national convention so there's so much
stuff going on that year um that you
know we couldn't ignore all that and
it's it provides this really great
backdrop where it feels like america was
this like powder keg and when you talk
to people who lived through it i mean my
dad got back
actually from vietnam in ninth in
january of 1968 basically right when
lincoln comes back so which wasn't
really a coincidence we kind of chose
that because you know in talking to to
people who lived through that there was
this sense that like man everything was
just on this razor's edge and one thing
could happen and the whole country could
explode and it was just there's this
underlying tension and so we try and
weave that in throughout the whole game
man well thank you so much for joining
us when can we get our hands on mafia
three october 7th october 7th for xbox
playstation 1 playstation 4 pc awesome
thank you so much thank you
make sure for all the rest of your e3
coverage you stay tuned to gamespot.com
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
welcome back to the games with stage
here at e3 2016. joining tomorrow myself
on the couch now
is pete hines from bethesda hello hi how
how do you think your showcase went down
we were
edge of our seats here um
you you know what i i
it seems like everybody liked it but
when you're up there doing it you just
have
you have no idea i can't i can't watch
myself so i haven't gone back to watch
it to see like
i find myself annoying so
but it sounds like you guys thought it
was yeah i mean bethesda have like last
year they pretty much started the
president for starting with the
showstopper like last year was
it turned out to be the best of the
press conferences thank you and this
year it's definitely up there like you
opened with quake
champions i mean quake champions and
it's it's what people expected it to be
i know in here there was like all right
it's quick it says champions is this a
moba there was a little worry people
were like oh god they're doing a moba
and then you showed off what it actually
was and everyone went have a little face
yeah yeah
we've been hurt before we've been
you know i think we try and be pretty
self-aware in terms of what our
what we're about and what our franchises
are about and you know wolfenstein made
a nice transition from kind of falling
off a little bit to machine games
bringing it back and injecting a lot of
life and then doom last month has gone
over really well and folks enjoying kind
of taking
the legacy of of doom and id and
bringing it into the modern age and and
quake champions is you know tim being
one of the co-creators of the original
quake saying look i want to bring back
all these things that people know and
remember from quake and and bring it to
to present-day pc shooter i think the
most surprising thing was how quickly it
came like
doom just came out and i mean it follows
wolfenstein which everyone really liked
and it was critically acclaimed but
there was a before doom came out there
was a lot of talk about whether they
could pull it off whether bethesda could
pull it off and when it came out
everyone was like oh wow they really
nailed it yeah and that's when the
discussion of like maybe they could do
quake started happening and then you lot
just came out and said yep here it is
when did this start happening like when
did you start
and was like the
you had to have been confident going
into it to do it right yeah i mean
certainly um certainly there's a risk
there right if
it
i never felt like it would but if doom
had face planted last month well the
quake announcement is kind of awkward
because it's like
you know this game that everybody's like
oh that wasn't very good and that wasn't
very fun it's kind of hard to get
everybody excited but we were banking on
what happened which is we think doom's
going to be really good when people
actually get to play it they're going to
see what this game is about and enjoy it
and we will have opened that door for
quick champions to step in and say
and here's the
you know the next thing right and and to
be able to sort of build on that
and just to clarify like who's involved
in terms of developing the quake project
because i know for doom you you guys did
the single player internally and then
for yeah it was it was uh id single
player and then id working with certain
affinity on multiplayer and then id
working with uh escalation on the snap
map yeah tom and the folks at escalation
just did an unbelievable job um with
with the snap map stuff and making all
that stuff work so yeah this is also um
some folks at id um
working with with another team okay to
kind of bring some of those resources
because as you said
doom was a pretty big deal and now it is
taking on a lot of the
the the multiplayer aspects along with
some of the folks from battlecry studios
in austin um bringing some more
resources you know one of the things
that marty's talked about is really
wanting to dedicate time this summer and
he talked about it some in his video to
to improving and bringing more stuff to
multiplayer to make that multiplayer
experience even better and expand the
the snap map as well so um it's uh you
know there's there's a lot going on at
that studio but we're excited where it's
headed i guess the
the obviously doom is an excellent game
but a lot of the kind of talk about
multiplayer is that it leaves people a
little wanting because it's not quite
consistent with the single-player
experience so there's a little there's
some fears that i've seen online that
you know the last multiplayer game that
bethesda worked on and he worked on has
kind of like floundered a bit like
there's a worry that
would that transfer over to to quake
like is it they're they're very
different
they're they're very different things i
and and again i i think it's i think
it's a fair criticism i think it and and
those guys will be the first to tell you
that they think
there's a far better version of do
multiplayer than what there is today
and they are dedicated to getting the
game to that point and that's part of
our commitment to
not just dlc but free content adding new
modes adding new functionality to um to
get the multiplayer there to the point
where folks are like okay this is really
good uh but quake champions is it its
own separate set of challenges i mean
it's it's a 120 hertz unlocked frame
rate on a pc um it's um it's a whole
different
beast yeah if you want fast vertical
um
that that's quake champions in it in a
nutshell so what kind of gameplay
experience are you going to go for
because obviously doom
is its success is based on really taking
out the the kind of things that we've
come to expect from shooters and going
back to what we remember shoes being
in terms of
quake champions is its case of doing the
same thing and presenting a quick
multiplayer experience that's in line
with what we remember or are you
planning to use like modern you know
gameplay innovations no i think it's
going to be
a current take on classic quake
gameplay and and adding in
this a bit more in this idea of
champions this idea of having
different characters that you can choose
and each one has a different ability
they bring but ultimately it's about
really fast gameplay um the kind of um
arenas and um and maps that you're used
to in a quake game that speed of
movement super fast twitchy um controls
all of those things you remember from
quake is quake champions um but quake
wasn't the only surprise you had at your
showcase this year we saw arcane's
reimagining of prey yeah so how long has
that been under wraps in its current
form
a long time a while
uh you know as raf said look after
dishonored um harvey and the team and
leon uh started on dishonored two and
roth started uh work on a new project
for them something that he wanted to he
he wanted to you know arcane has been
around for a long time um you know
they're very well known for dishonored
but you guys know they've been making
stuff for for a long time and he wanted
to to have that studio working on more
than one thing and had this idea of
taking the thing that they're known for
which is immersive first-person games
but bringing it to a different a
different style of game and so um
they've been working on it for
for a couple years now at least yeah and
was it a case of
taking what was what prey was prey two
was before and kind of absolutely no
they they threw it out from the start
there is not a single element of prey to
in this game other than
aliens running amok and you're being
hunted by aliens like that prey is
distilling down literally the franchise
to that core element and then arcane
building it back up to this is how we
imagine it this is what um you know we
think it is right and how would you kind
of obviously we don't want to pigeonhole
it but like what kind of how would you
characterize to get the kind of game is
it a horror game is it a cycle
definitely not a horror game i mean it's
it's got a psychological element to it
you you see hints of some of that in in
the trailer here but it's an immersive
first person
action game shooter
it's a systems-based game that arcane is
known for
they're known for creating really
well-realized worlds that where
everything isn't just tangible but has
there's logic and reason behind it this
is
there's a reason why the space station
is the way it is that you that you find
yourself on there's a there's a reason
for the ecology of the aliens that you
um see and are fighting and
trying to survive um and uh yeah it's
it's about a lot of player choice how
are you going to deal with any of these
situations that you're throwing a friend
it's not an open world game but it's
that same sort of open
open level game like you see with
dishonored where you can't go wherever
you want at any given moment but you've
got a lot of freedom for sort of where
what you're going to do next and how
you're going to approach it and there's
a whole bunch of different can you
backtrack in places that you've been
before
yeah
it's um it's gonna offer a lot of um
replayability and a lot of uh rewarding
exploration because again remember this
is a game where you're stuck on a space
station and so you've got to make do
with the resources you have and
depending on the way that you're playing
there may be certain areas that you want
to go to because there's a specific
resource you need or a specific
objective you want to achieve that
somebody else playing a different way
doesn't care doesn't care at all about
and
quakecon is less than two months away
can't wait for the guys to be able to
show more about what they're what
they're up to was there any trepidation
because obviously um it's a quite
similar premise to alien isolation
uh stuck on a spaceship maybe less of
the psychological angle
at a it's a it's a fair point i mean at
a fundamental level aliens on space
station absolutely but i think when
folks see the dead space but yeah but i
think one once folks see what the game
is really about and and what that sort
of minute to minute gameplay looks like
it they're going to be like yep i get it
i get how all the elements fit there's
definitely um
there's definitely a psychological
element there are definitely parts of
the game that scare the hell out of me
but it's not a horror game it's because
of the aliens and how they work and yeah
um
and just those moments of am i gonna
fight here am i gonna flee here how am i
gonna i guess the thing uh looking at it
it does look like you said it's it's you
know it's distilling prey down to its
very essence aliens on the spaceship
which begs the question why why even
call it prey like you could have put out
and put this out there as a brand new ip
and we could have kind of gotten a
praise for doing that but you decided to
stick with prey not pray too but like
pray again and reap it what was the
thinking behind that um
i don't know how i mean i don't know how
to distill down
months and years of conversations around
that but ultimately it felt like the
right fit for the kind of game that they
were going to
make um and and what it is they they
wanted to do okay you also revealed um
skyrim special edition
so i mean what was the thought process
behind i mean obviously we all love
skyrim i've put
far too many hours into that game but
it's fairly recent why why was this the
one that got the remaster and maybe not
morrowind or oblivion sure um i mean
it's fairly recent it is five years old
um but then again dishonored was only
three years ago when it got yeah
although dishonored the remaster for
that was more about well it was the last
new ip we released for the last
generation of consoles so it was a it
was a timeliness of
um
you know being able to bring it to this
generation um
with with skyrim it was
we get asked about it a ton
a ton
and um it felt like
it's still a lot of work
left to do to get this onto the
current gen so there is a time factor
there
morrowind is two generations ago um
so that would have been
i mean a much more massive undertaking
and taken a significant amount of of
time i mean at that point you're
probably basically remaking the game
from the start with how much you'd have
to throw out and and do all over again
um you know we just felt like skyrim is
a great fit that that folks kept asking
about it that the the amount of content
there from a mod standpoint in the pc
community
and what those modders would then be
able to bring over to the console folks
um felt like a good fit so um
look i mean
i played a ton of skyrim at home and i
can't wait to play this yeah when it
comes out even though i've been playing
it
forever since you know well before
before launch i'm getting itchy itchy
fingers again like watching the game
like gets me everything yeah
i still like hearing it so but that's
also revealed um bethesda vr so you guys
are pretty much
one of the big publishers to make a real
big push into vr a real commitment so
you've had the doom experience that's
not going to be transferred into the
full game yeah um
playing a game at 60 frames a second
like
it's a it's a vomit comment like it is
literally just put the bucket next to
the headset and wait about 10 seconds um
so it needs to be a different kind of of
game a different kind of experience
what we've got today is sort of um
during the show is is an idea a
direction some thoughts around what that
might be and showing off some of the
tech and what it looks like um whereas
fallout is just
the game it's fallout 4. i mean it's vr
controls um
still i mean it's not coming out till
next year so there's still a lot of work
and thinking around how all of that's
going to work but it's a first look at
what a full fallout 4 game would look
like on a vr
platform so the demo on the show floor
at the moment is um
you don't you don't necessarily walk
around so much you teleport between yeah
in this build you're not
walking place to place you're sort of
figuring out where you want to go to
next but that's part of figuring out how
how that looks when the game ships i i
genuinely have no idea okay is it just
the on the htc vive or are they talking
right now
we're just announced for the htc vive
whether we would do this for anything
else um any other platform
all things are possible but right now
it's it's just for the htc vive next
year cool
um another quick one we only have less
than a minute left but fallout dlc this
is gonna be is it you've announced three
three three today so we're in beta
testing this week on uh contraptions
that'll be out next week so that adds a
bunch of new um gadgets and gizmos to
add to the workshop uh next month is
build your own vault
and
recruit vault dwellers and run
experiments on them and all that stuff
and then august is nuka world right uh a
bigger
um
a bigger area adding a faction to the
game like a dystopian disneyland yeah
yeah very dystopian um but it
um we'll be talking about that uh
probably a little bit further down the
road but kind of excited for what that
brings from a gameplay standpoint um and
then uh ps4 mods uh still planning on
coming out this month so they're out on
xbox one we're almost done with the work
we need to do on ps4 so that'll bring a
bunch of new content from from all the
great mod creators to play on ps4 was
there a vast difference in bringing like
different challenges yeah
yeah like every single platform has
different ways of handling all of these
things and when you're talking about
bringing something created on a pc and
having it work on a console and all the
sort of rules for
how it behaves and what do you do if
they just rip the
lord of the rings assets and drop them
in there and be all of that stuff has to
be managed and figured out will i be
able to get macho man randy savage
everybody asked that i think i'm going
to have to personally
reach out to please do send an email to
those folks and say can we please have
permission for this modder to put up
this thing because it's i think the
number one to be in the uh request that
and thomas the tank i was going to say
and that's number two yep my macho man
and thomas the tank engine after e3
those would be the first two emails you
have the power yes i will make that
happen thank you thank you so much for
joining us um when is quakecon so we can
find out more details about first first
of august in dallas texas we're gonna
have uh we're gonna be showing new info
on quake champions we're gonna have new
info on prey probably more info on
upcoming doom dlc uh nuka world i'm sure
we'll be talking about more there so
definitely we need to get you guys down
to texas yeah book off lights come join
us
all right thank you so much
guys for more coverage from this year's
e3 make sure you stay tuned of course in
gamesbot.com
what's the play here nathan
[Music]
just follow my lead
uncharted 4 is a powerful game about
loss betrayal regret and redemption in
both its momentous set pieces and its
intimate personal moments uncharted 4
drives its narrative forward with a rare
understanding of its characters its
world and the gameplay tying them all
together it's a stunning combination of
disparate parts it's a breathtaking
marvel of a game by this point in the
series developer naughty dog has led us
across the globe in search of famous
treasures from equally famous legends in
uncharted 4 however we find protagonist
nathan drake leading a quiet life with
freelance journalist elena fisher who
also happens to be his wife they live in
new orleans they have a three-bedroom
house they play video games together but
this all changes with the return of
nathan's older brother sam who was
thought to be dead for 15 years not only
is he alive and well but he also has a
lead on one of history's greatest
treasures the loot of the pirate henry
avery which the brothers have sought
since their early days of treasure
hunting
as with previous titles uncharted 4
revolves around third person combat
climbing and puzzle solving but unlike
its predecessors this game often lets
you sneak past enemy soldiers without
doing any harm at all stealth requires a
more patient measured approach but it
feeds into the idea of a more reserved
nathan as does the fact that you don't
always have to kill anyone here unless
you want to uncharted 4's action has a
symbiotic relationship with its story
there are minor mechanical problems the
cover system can send you to the wrong
obstacle or wall in the middle of
firefights and rarely nathan will grab
the wrong ledge when climbing but these
observations wash away within the grand
scheme of things there's always
something incredible around the corner
to erase the momentary annoyances
in terms of structure uncharted 4
embraces a more open approach with much
of its level design there are small
sandboxes where you climb towers learn
the layout mark enemies and choose to
fight through them or circumvent the
group entirely these areas would hurt
the pace of a lesser game but uncharted
4 keeps tension alive even in its
calculated moments transitioning from
open areas to action sequences without
halting the momentum and speaking of
uncharted 4 set pieces are the best in
the series and among the best
coordinated stunts in the medium just
when you think uncharted 4 might settle
into a steady rhythm it throws something
new at you with high velocity and
incredible power
these sequences give you agency but also
enough guidance to maintain the euphoric
rush of a car chase without constantly
dying
uncharted 4 directs you with its camera
and lighting and also audio cues
characters shout over the din of gunfire
telling you when to fight or when to
just keep running the dialogue makes
sense within the moment everything just
feels and sounds right
and then there's the presentation of it
all the cinematography both in game and
during cut scenes it amplifies the
wonder of this gorgeous world there's
also stunning animation at play and it
sets a new watermark for games in the
way it can illustrate subtle emotions
like distrust or yearning
uncharted 4's multiplayer though ditches
grounded storytelling in favor of all
out chaos you can use what are called
mysticals or artifacts with supernatural
abilities that are taken from throughout
the series you can also summon ai
snipers and medics to aid your team's
efforts uncharted 4's multiplayer
exhibits the necessary creativity to
elevate its already fluid third-person
mechanics
but although the multiplayer works well
and it features a progression system
that can keep you playing past your
first few matches it's not the primary
draw
you hear that fat lady singing the lure
of uncharted 4 is in its remarkable
single player journey how each of its
parts feeds into the same cohesive whole
uncharted 4 bounces between set pieces
and personal moments with such grace
with such skill and poise and affection
for its characters that you don't mind
when the gun stop firing and the smoke
clears and nathan gets a moment to
breathe
yes this is a thrilling adventure
through exotic locations with
spectacular action sequences and a
pacing that pulls you through with ease
i had a smile on my face the moment it
began
but it's also a story about family it's
a story about self-examination and most
of all as its final moments make clear
this is a story about storytelling the
importance we lend our idols legends and
myths how we pass down the ones that
inspire us in its writing in its design
and its understanding of what makes
games unique uncharted 4 is something to
aspire to it's a shining example and
we'll be talking about it for years to
come
[Music]
ah
what where are you
i'm in
here being stabbed with a
fork welcome back to the gamespot stage
here at e3 2016 tomorrow and i are
honored to be joined by yamauchi-san
from polyphony digital to talk about gt
sport
this is gran turismo's debut on the
playstation 4 how is it going to be
different what were the big challenges
of bringing it to a new console
challenge
yeah so being on the playstation 4 for
the first time um you know we had these
objectives that we set very high for
ourselves and that we had high
expectations that we can get a lot of
those things done
but you know to actually go through that
process of you know reaching those
objectives was uh was a lot of work for
us
fans have been
cl they they really want the dynamic
weather day-to-night cycle can you
explain the reasons why they're not
present
so
um you know the dynamic weather changes
and lighting changes was something that
we originally started in you know gran
turismo 5 and six
and uh you know having done all that we
really discovered uh what are the
advantages and disadvantages of having
that system in there
um and you know my ultimate decision was
that you know the disadvantages outweigh
the advantages um and that's because you
know when
you look at the overall quality of the
graphics um you know having that system
there really drops the quality quite a
bit
um so you know we after you know making
the considerations um you know i decided
that you know it would be better in
terms of both game design and experience
if the players are able to set the time
of day and set the weather before the
race and the conditions are maintained
you know throughout the race
so for fans of the series obviously gran
turismo is a huge huge racing series
they're used to having the releases in
the form of a prologue then a numbered
entry in the title
what is why did you decide to go for a
spin-off like sport um a lot of people
might be thinking
it's kind of unusual like it maybe it's
it's a lesser game because it's not gran
turismo numbered seven or whatever it is
so what's the thinking behind using
focusing
but
okay so
i actually get this question asked a lot
so it's a great opportunity to talk
about it um
we actually you know could have called
it seven um and the reason why we
decided to go with sport instead is
because uh the major focus of uh you
know this title is that we're starting
this new sports mode that's really going
to sort of change the racing world
um and if you consider uh gran turismo
one through six as sort of the first era
or the first generation of gran turismo
you know from starting from sport we're
really entering this new era
and that's why it we
when i really considered it um you know
it seemed better to actually call it
grand christmas sport than having
another title
or of you know of the gran turismo as a
number series and you know
we could have easily called it 70 has
all the features it has the size of a
full-size game um and you know when
people have asked me over and over again
this same question you know i i went
back and thought about it and i was like
yeah you know i could have called it
seven it would have been easy to do so
yeah but uh you know that was the
reasoning behind the naming of the title
was there a discussion of taking gran
turismo and presenting like a new flavor
on it obviously your biggest competitor
is forza and microsoft have a straight
simulation racing game and to complement
that they've created this almost like
festival style rally experience and um
was there ever a discussion about maybe
taking a spin off doing a spin-off and
maybe perhaps even sport becoming that
kind of title
yeah you know in for gran turismo you
know all the data all the code that goes
into the title uh is really developed by
the 200 or more staff that we have
working straight out of japan um so you
know it's really uh unthinkable for gran
turismo that we would have uh somebody
else make a spin-off title for example
um because then it wouldn't be gt
anymore okay how do you maintain
obviously you've been working on this
game for this series for so long how do
you maintain a passion like is it just
literally like intense passion for
simulation racing and cars or how do you
how do you keep that drive to create new
games over and over again without kind
of diversifying what they are too much
because the gran turismo that we have
now is very much the lineage back to the
originals is clear like you're not going
too far away usually people when they
work on something this man for this long
they try and reinvent it in different
ways but gran turismo has largely stayed
the same and the modes around it have
kind of changed somewhat how do you
maintain the passion for it and the
drive to keep making it mm-hmm
[Music]
foreign
or
so you know while we were developing you
know gran turismo sport uh we actually
did sort of uh look back at all the data
we still have in our servers at
polyphony uh to see you know what what
was our mindset when we started creating
the first grand thrismo
and you know looking at all this data
and looking at all this information we
you know
obviously we have had the same target
for you know throughout the entire
series over the years
and gran turismo sport is undoubtedly
gran turismo
and i think
it's because
you know we've always aimed for a very
high level in our development um
you know what makes gran turismo
different from you know other competitor
titles out there is really that um you
know that consists consistent uh pursuit
of you know the highest quality possible
and you know we've never strayed from
that uh from that from that objective um
i think that
that motivation to reach that quality
level uh is what what really sets us
apart
for driving sim fans how deep does the
simulation go
driving simulation simulations
more shin castings
okay
so i think there's two things um you
know
this version of gran turismo
wasn't really developed just for the
hardcore racing simulator fan
um you know we really went to great
lengths to uh cater to the first time
you know players to racing games and
also first time drivers who's never
driven a real car before
you know we really wanted these people
to kind of experience you know how fun
it is to drive a car and how beautiful
cars are um we wanted them to that's the
experience that we wanted them to have
so
you know
when you play the actual uh the demo we
have on the show floor today um you know
you could tell when you first get into
the cars whether it be a very low
powered car or a very high powered car
um you know you have a natural sense of
driving that's much much easier than you
know you would expect from a simulator
um it's you know and that's something
that you know goes to the level where
even somebody who when somebody who's
very good at driving drives a car will
still have that natural feel right
wonderful thank you so much for joining
us when does gt sport release
this sport
so it's due to release uh mid-november
awesome thank you so much for joining us
for more coverage of this year's e3 of
course make sure you stay tuned to
gamespot.com
you're watching the gamespot stage
brought to you by airheads
uh
[Music]
please if you're going for a dramatic
entrance to the last possible friggin
second now would be a really great time
come on for a game with so many strong
personalities battleborn somehow lacks a
cohesive identity every facet from their
progression to the visual presentation
feels overloaded with ideas some good
some bad some just confusing because it
throws so much against the wall the end
result is a scattered grab bag of manic
gameplay complex leveling and cartoony
humor in short battleborn is fun but
messy and parsing the experience
underneath can be maddeningly tricky
great more work for me i have to prepare
another underling for imminent mortal
combat the best example of battleborn's
deep-seated identity crisis is its
massive 25-character roster though
technically a first-person shooter the
game's heroes utilize all sorts of
preset weapons abilities and roles that
pull from every influence imaginable
impressively even characters that seem
superficially similar inevitably offer
something unique that makes their
gameplay memorable and enjoyable be it a
particularly powerful super or simply a
higher than average movement speed this
mechanical variety is not only
remarkable it also drives battleborn's
longevity you'll unlock new heroes
steadily and without much conscious
effort so you'll generally have one or
two new options by the time you've
outgrown your current character
unfortunately you might outgrow them
more quickly than you'd expect testing
out a new hero for the first time can
feel a bit overwhelming but as soon as
you overcome this initial teething
period each hero's gameplay loop starts
to grow routine this is in part a
symptom of battleborn's approach to
action its gameplay is fast and frantic
but also light and loose i found i
generally just had to spam the primary
attack button trigger my specials
whenever possible and occasionally
retreat to let my shields recharge
lighting
this is especially true during the
cooperative campaign which consists of
eight loosely connected missions that
feel more like destiny strikes than a
carefully crafted narrative driven story
mode enemies are for the most part
brainless and predictable cutting them
down in droves can feel empowering but
it also underscores the repetitive
simplistic nature of the baseline combat
it's also somewhat frustrating that all
eight missions repeatedly remix the same
three scenarios defend the asset escort
the robot and kill the boss thanks to
the variety of the characters and the
frenetic energy of the combat however
battle war can still end up being a
blast sure the moment-to-moment gameplay
feels superficial but when your five-man
squad is getting absolutely swarmed and
you've already sunk 45 minutes into a
mission and you've run out of respawns
the tension and chaos combine to form a
powerful engine of fun
a word of warning though without other
players combat becomes a slog and
certain objectives become nearly
impossible but hey at least there's
split screen co-op and streamlined
matchmaking outside of the eight
campaign missions battleborn offers
three competitive multiplayer modes and
here the gameplay develops a slightly
more strategic sheen unlike the mindless
fodder you fight in the campaign
multiplayer pits heroes against heroes
which forces you to approach combat more
thoughtfully the modes themselves add an
extra layer of strategy as well
borrowing moba elements to create setups
that emphasize objectives over kills in
practice this equates to action that
feels less chaotic but far more
involving than anything in the campaign
and the combination of distinct
characters and moba inspired objectives
makes battleborn's multiplayer feel
genuinely fresh
this component is by no means flawless
however the added strategic depth helps
but doesn't eliminate the simplicity of
the core gameplay but more importantly
there's just not quite enough content to
make battleborn feel totally substantial
the three modes offer just two maps a
piece and while that's not unusual for a
moba it's awfully light for a shooter
especially one with a relatively short
unadorned campaign there's also an issue
with battleborn's in-match leveling
system the game features several forms
of experience and progression including
individual character leveling unlockable
gear and an overall command rank but the
most impactful system is the on-the-fly
leveling that occurs within each mission
and match in the campaign this system
works remarkably well i never felt
hindered starting at zero but i was
always glad to have my fully leveled
abilities back by the end in the
competitive multiplayer however this
system rewards players who are already
doing well meaning matches can sometimes
snowball into lopsided thrashings
while it may not be as important as the
progression system or multiplayer modes
it's worth noting that battleborn's
writing is by and large goofy witty and
endearing fun fact this stuff used to be
illegal but now that we're all doomed
nobody seems to care
holy crap legendary gear identified holy
sh
it won't appeal to everyone's tastes but
anyone can appreciate the deep well of
one-liners that flavor both the campaign
and surprisingly the competitive
multiplayer
battleborn feels like an elaborate
patchwork of ideas that compete for
attention without necessarily adding too
much the experience with so many moving
parts that never quite gel i found
plenty of things to love but just as
much to feel confused by and ambivalent
about
[Music]
welcome back to the game spot stage here
at e3 2016. tomorrow night are now
joined by dominic butler the lead game
designer on tom clancy's ghost recon
wildlands thank you so much for joining
us thank you for having me it's a big
name tom
costa recon wildlands exactly exactly
but it's it's a game we're very proud of
yeah does it have a shorter name like
internally just wildland just wide lands
yeah yeah
i don't even think the acronym would
work
no i don't have yeah it would be
unpronounceable i think but yeah
wildlands is the easy way to go so what
you're showing off at e3 this year so e3
this year in fact we'll start with e3
last year we brought the game we
unveiled it for the first time and kind
of brought the dream of what ghost recon
could be what you know what that
evolution could be
and then this year we're super happy
because we're able to put it into fans
hands so even like last year we had the
behind closed doors demo and it was kind
of vip invite only
and then now we've got it there we've
it's on the booth it's open to the
public we've got the ub lounge we've got
hundreds and hundreds of people lined up
and it's
the feedback has been incredible right
now because with something like this you
work on it for so long the game's been
in development for almost four years now
and
you you kind of keep it for yourself and
then you show the world you're not sure
first reception was great and then
obviously these people have questions
okay it looks great but what's it going
to be like to play and then they put
their hands on it and
it's great it's the
one restriction that we have i guess is
it being e3 we've got a limited amount
of time with yeah and that's the bit
that is the only like
i wish you could play it as much as we
do this is the build that we've taken
from the floor and this is the bill that
we play every day and we
put it bluntly we didn't have time to
build like a sort of bespoke e3 demo we
took a slice of the game
and brought it with us to e3 and
knowing
the fun that we have with it and the
opportunities we see every day seeing
players get to play that that's the the
kind of the big thrill and that's
something we're going to bring back to
the guys uh in the studio that was like
oh sorry i was going to say obviously
ghost recons
a historic franchise and it's been kind
of in and out of you know the limelight
so a lot of people may want to know like
what is the makeup of the team that is
working i know we talked earlier and
and you have a lot of like classic ghost
recon devs on the team so for people for
fans of the series like yeah absolutely
absolutely well what we have is uh the
game is being led out of ubisoft paris
and i mean ghost recon it holds a
special place in ubisoft's heart it's
one of those like old franchises like
you said it it kind of comes and it goes
and then it comes back again and every
time it does we try to bring something
new you know we try to see like what
could we do to make it uh different and
but still retain that
tactical military shooter still retain
you know the dna what makes it ghost
recon
and really because the team makeup more
than anything else we've got a lot of
guys on the team these were the ex
future soldier guys these are the guys
that have been working on it since you
know for 10 plus years so they know the
brand better than anyone you know we've
got other support teams but they're
coming in to help those guys who really
know what ghost recon is and for
long quite a long time
several games in fact we've been wanting
to make it bigger and bring those
tactical options to the open world but
we've been limited right but mainly by
tech limitations more than anything else
and now leveraging the power of these
current generation consoles leveraging
the power of the current generation pcs
we're able to bring those tactics
with the co-op with being able to play
with your friends
that whole sensation that freedom of
choice to the open world where it just
feels like a natural fit right it's it's
no longer this linear corridor say okay
let's do a
mission where we're gonna attack this
place at night in the rain we're going
to drop in behind enemy lines we're
going to wait for the guards to be kind
of doing different patrols we're going
to avoid the spotlights and go in and
extract the thing or the big explosive
ending to the chapter and you know these
kind of things that we used to set up
typically when we were building games
like that now we put that into the
players hands and we say okay you've got
to get this guy it's up to you and we
you know we give you the options we give
you the tools and like i was saying
before
it's
it can seem a little bit limiting
sometimes when it's a
kind of coordinated demo but when we've
got 20 minutes per person it's hard to
get to show you all those options but
with
items and tools and the drone we see
here and the drone has its own bespoke
progression system the players got their
own progression system
offering
tons of different
it's not even new ways to play it's more
like you can express yourself
through the gameplay
and just play the way that you want
right and that's the thing i think
that's that's really important i mean
from a game design level where do you
even start like you you say okay this
mission i want you to kill this guy
extract this guy
where do you go from there where do we
go from there well it's actually starts
earlier than that where we we look at
building a world first right and we know
we have an experience that we want for
the player in terms of uh like kind of
an overall creative direction
um and that comes from our brand guys
the guys that have been building it for
a long time so they know
what the sensation that needs to be
maintained right in terms of that
tactical approach
and then we see okay what are the tools
what are the things we can give to the
player but also against what kind of
backdrop because this is bolivia it's
the near future it's a kind of what-if
situation with this drug cartel that's
moved in seized control of the entire
place and
turned it into a narco state and it's
you know what would that look like what
would it feel like what would the
reaction of the world be in our case
that's the ghost that's an easy easy
option for us
but it's
we build this world with this kind of
intertwined systemic ecosystems it's not
just a geographical thing it's the
traffic it's the civilians it's the
rebel forces it's the santa blanca how
they've taken over these places what was
a village what was a mining center
and then using that
not just for a kind of visual theme but
also for gameplay opportunities right
because if you're attacking
like a mining quarry or a base that's on
a hill or something that's out in the
salt plains those things are widely
different challenges not just in terms
of like the story says i've got to
extract this guy but even if you just
kept it as extract this guy putting it
in those different situations wildly
changes the gameplay so it kind of
starts before all of that and then we
try as much as possible to leave it open
and to avoid having
kind of uh
let's say a sense of playing it wrong we
don't want to have a that there's a
wrong way to play this game it's if you
want to say let's role play this and go
full tactical sure we're going to give
you all the tools to do we're going to
give you all the options you need you
can recon with your friends you're going
to share that information you can move
in silently the world is going to react
accordingly but if for example after a
time you say you know what we've been
super quiet for a while i want to go big
on this sure you get those options take
off the suppressors get the c4 get the
mines get the grenades put them on the
side of a helicopter fly it in and blow
it up right on top of the camera it's a
ton of fun so the classic ghost recon
games and and even somewhat like stuff
like uh rainbow six vegas there are like
almost like trial and error you get
these tight like almost choreographed
very precision-based yeah whereas this
seems like it's more designed about
going in and then reacting to situations
so there is a sense of the reaction but
the reaction is there it's not let's not
say it's not a punishment and that's the
that's the really key part is it's not a
punishment for playing it wrong it's
more a consequence where you can see oh
you know what we did make a good
approach to this camp we did you know we
did everything
well and the way we wanted to play but
at the last minute i mean in the video
we're showing you here we were going
after el pasolero and the key thing was
he he fled yeah but he spotted one of
the ghosts and i'll be completely
transparent with you we did kind of get
spotted so we could show you the chase
but the chase isn't a scripted thing
right the chase is based on his reaction
all of these bosses all of these major
characters have their own personality
have their own backstory have their own
narrative and their drive and it informs
their characteristics the way that they
play so in some cases you'll go after
somebody and maybe you get close to them
and they surrender immediately and
that's it they're just they're scared
they're they're not violent people they
were accountants or they were involved
in other parts of the business they
don't want to fight and others are going
to hunker down they're going to get
behind cover they're going to start
returning fire others are going to flee
this guy runs and we wanted to show you
that kind of cool systemic chase and how
things can daisy chain and the sort of
consequence the chain reaction of events
that can happen right um and it's it's a
but it's really for the players right so
you'll see in the
top left corner
extract el paso aero right that's there
from the beginning of the video it's
like you just get him get him to the
safe point how you do that is entirely
up to you the boss's reactions remind me
a little bit of the nemesis system in
shadow of mordor the way that each kind
of orc boss reacts in very different
ways right okay
question from the chat is what engine is
this running in so this is running our
own proprietary engine with our own
internal tech
it's a version of anvil next
system that we have built some of our
games on
quite successfully and we're very happy
with it but it's all in-house stuff yeah
okay in terms of
story the ghost recon games like i'm
trying to remember back the previous
like advanced warfare stories like i
think i can't for life with me remember
i remember a series of missions whereas
with this it seems like you're making an
effort to try and tell a story you've
got bolivia you've set up this narco
state kind of thing yep is there an
increased emphasis on telling like a
narrative story with an arc and kind of
you have these ghosts behind enemy lines
they seem kind of isolated from the rest
of the world absolutely i mean we do you
want to feel that threat right you want
to feel a little bit like you are
that spec ops you are dropped in behind
enemy lines you do have a cia handler
who's going to be giving you some
information along the way going to be
able to coordinate a little bit with the
outside world but you are
you're there by yourself you know and
you're having to do it like those guys
have to do it when they're doing
missions like this they kind of have to
rely on their expertise the fact that
they can fly and they can drive and they
can pick up any weapon that's the thing
that these guys really do and they have
to be able to adapt to that situation
they have to kind of seek out
opportunities identify threats and
act on that right and that makes for
fantastic gameplay from our point of
view because it's a bunch of
opportunities it's a big toy box and
without saying you know no don't do this
or you have to do this or okay you want
to approach this camp you have to do you
know take out these two guards then
disable the alarm then do this then just
the way you wish right and there's no
wrong way to play
um we saw in the e3
player full play co-op yep um how is
that going to work is a drop-in drop out
is there a lobby is there matchmaking
so we're not talking too specifically
about the the way we connect with other
players for sure the important thing
i'll just kick it off with is that the
game is playable in solo and up to four
player co-op from the beginning to the
end and we make no differentiation
between i started in solos now i can't
join co-op or vice versa you're always
just playing ghost recon wildlands
you're always playing your narrative
your progression and then as you jump in
and out of other people's games
we have a
quite an interesting way i'm not going
to go into it now of basically merging
our narratives so that i don't auto
complete stuff in your game you don't
ought to complete in mine but we can
still share the experience we can still
grow and then if for whatever reason i
have to leave you guys keep playing
you're not missing out you're not kicked
out to a lobby you're not you don't have
to stop um in terms of
those options for the player we also
have the solo and it's important because
not everybody wants to play with other
people some people prefer the solo
experience that's fine you're not
missing out on any content at all you
will be supported by three ai teammates
and those guys
it's necessary right like the spec ops
guys that we talked to we got you know
still serving guys and retired guys and
different military authorities and every
time they reinforce the fact that
there's no lone wolves there's no way to
do this by yourself so you're going to
need that support that's reflected in a
kind of elevated difficulty in the fact
that it's a really dangerous world you
need
extra fire support or if you go down to
be able to revive you or vehicle support
all of those things that you would have
with friends you're not going to miss
out with uh with the ai teammates can
you control the ai teammates in any way
you give them some direction it's
interesting you mentioned earlier about
the kind of more precision based you
know like door entry stuff right let's
plan this and let's mark charges here
and you wait for my mark and then you go
we don't want to have that kind of
micromanagement it's totally fine it's a
ton of fun i love playing those games
but for our world where we can embrace
the chaos a little bit more and a little
bit more can happen
we wanted to leave it open and make it a
little bit less directed so you give
them basic orders on me attack retreat
hold but you use that same
communication system when you're playing
with friends so it's not like i'm
learning to control the ai it's
it's the way i talk you don't have to
adapt it exactly the ghosts themselves
are they defined characters like are
they speaking and having their own
personalities are they more for like
customization no no no so
in terms of customization real quick
from the beginning you get to make the
ghost your own right so in terms of race
and gender and equipment and loadout and
everything that you're taking into the
field with you
you customize all of that and then you
can upgrade and adapt that as you
discover more tools and options um like
what we're showing at a3 you've got it's
like quite a basic sort of starting
loadout that doesn't overwhelm you with
a ton of options right
um but that's gonna grow that's gonna
you're gonna adapt and you're gonna
build the kind of tool set that you like
in terms of the ghosts themselves they
all have very distinct personalities
they're all completely voiced they're
talking to each other they're commenting
on stuff that's happening in the world
they're commenting on things that you've
affected by your gameplay in the world
because it's a large systemic world so
depending on what you do the world kind
of reacts to that and they then can
comment on those reactions right so as
the santa blanca starts to put
punishment on the locals because you're
fighting and you're trying to fight back
against these guys you're gonna have the
ghost commenting you buy this you've got
regular communication with the cia and
that kind of stuff so it is
something that again we don't have time
to show now but it's absolutely there in
force thank you so much for joining us
for having us when are we able to play
tom can't see ghost recon wildlands will
be released on march 7th 2017. awesome
thank you so much thank you guys and of
course for more e3 coverage don't go
anywhere stay tuned to gamespot.com
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the gamespot stage here
at e3 2016 brought to you by airheads
bytes joining tomorrow night to talk a
little bit about xbox design lab is
monique welcome to welcome to the stage
thank you so this is a brand new
initiative for xbox
um we've never really been able to
customize your controllers to this kind
of degree before
where did that come from like whose idea
was it how long ago um
well it's it's been like a crazy journey
which um actually this idea has come up
over and over for the past like three or
four years um but never before have we
been able to get like sort of all of the
pieces together to do this this very
like front end like um you know
customization experience all the way
through to the back end manufacturing to
be able to deliver these kind of custom
designs straight to people's doors so
um it's been brought up a number of
times but this particular time it's been
about uh it's been about 16 months since
i've been working on this so over a year
yeah we started we first started um
by just going out and talking to fans
about uh what how they would like to
customize their controllers you know
what the best ways to do that might be
and it turns out that color is something
that really resonates with everyone and
you're actually an industrial designer
right yeah what's that what's that mean
for people who might not know an
industrial designer isn't how does that
transfer over being able to give us
these cool looking
uh controllers well industrial design is
um like designed for mass production so
um it's sort of like
where sculpture and color and materials
meets engineering so it's this like
super cool blend of
of
of like art and science i guess yeah so
um
so this is one aspect of industrial
design but um like a typical industrial
designer like would design the whole
product right so you said that the big
thing that fans were clamoring for was
color
how do you kind of decide on
what sort of shades to go around like
not like with it was it within a certain
kind of palette of color was it just
really bright ones you wanted to get
your attention how do you decide well
you know
um it was interesting because we wanted
to do
a really broad palette that allowed um
any of our like diverse uh fans to
express any type of story or any you
know any type of vision that they wanted
to but then at the same time we wanted
to make sure that everything really hung
together and looked looked good together
so it's definitely a lot of
just a lot of work like developing the
specific pigments
we know that people love color for
different reasons like some people just
like they have their favorite color it
might be pink you love pink you want
everything in pink and you're just
psyched to make a pink controller or it
might be related to
a game you play you might
drive a blacked out car you might play
forza and you just want to block out
your controller um
yeah it might just be something cool
that you've seen
so we wanted to provide you know options
for for everyone and so some of the
colors that are more popular like blue
we have three three different blues so
you can do a dark like a dark neutral um
you can do like a the super bright
sporty photon blue um or you can do uh
more of the
more of a pastel blue and they work
great together but then they also work
great with the other accent colors
um yeah green was also a big one for us
it's an important obviously the exact
screen
yeah so we have two greens um
i think the best thing about it is that
like people are already creating color
schemes like i've seen a whole range of
overwatch color schemes to you know suit
every character which is amazing for me
because i'm hopeless at making cool
looking things like we've got some
amazing everything i make is disgusting
and gross it's like white
but like there's like we've got a
gallery up on our website already of
just like game specific stuff and like
theme specific stuff and like being able
to express yourself and have a
controller that's uniquely your own is
it's like it's a cool thing that
everyone can get behind like you never
really know that you want a colored
controller until you hold it in your
hand and it says your name on there like
xx pro sniper 10 or whatever it is
you're like yeah right yeah you take a
closer look at the ones you brought with
you yeah i just brought a few examples
of the kinds of things that you can
build um
yeah so this is just an example of two
blues that look great together
um a bright orange
uh
you know
yeah i thought orange might be a big
color for this year yeah yeah um and
it's it's like a super bright vibrant
orange we've got
we've got grays blues blacks whites like
a lot of neutrals and then some really
fun pop colors it looks like the the
actual names on here are generated by
the same generator that we use for gamer
tags so like storm yeti new sasquatch
new sasquatch what's that one this one's
a pirate dropout like all pirates are
probably dropouts to be fair
so do we get you get a chance to write
what's on your controller right yeah
what is that i'm assuming there'll be no
obscenities how long does that list run
to to make sure that people don't just
sort of
yeah
it's actually the same um the same
engine that we use to check text as uh
we use on the gamer tags all right yeah
so it's an automated right so it's 16
characters so you can put your gamertag
on it or a message
um they make great gifts
i heard so many stories
just working the booth and talking to
people like over the past year
someone was just saying to me yesterday
like uh when my roommate plays he gets
he gets angry and i always ask him are
you angry are you angry so i'm gonna
make him a controller and say are you
angry
you know it's like everybody has their
you know little personal things and it's
like super fun to just pop the
controller off yeah something personal
but it's not just the color that you can
change you can also change the colors of
like the face buttons everything to do
with that oh right i didn't know that
yeah so yeah the individual face buttons
are also customizable right so you can
do the the top and side cases bottom
case um front front area with the
triggers you can do thumb sticks d-pads
abx y and view menu so there are 15
colors um
for the main parts there there's a
subset of eight of those colors for the
thumb sticks and then abxy and view menu
there's there's uh
five and four options so is this the the
new controller that was unveiled with
the xbox one s yes is this going to be
retroactively put into like the original
xbox one controller and is it going to
work with the elite controller um this
controller is compatible with all of the
game systems and this is the controller
that was just announced it's the one
with the the grip on it and the
bluetooth
um
audio jack everything i think it's it's
what's
for people who play in like competitive
tournaments it might be an idea to
create like the most obnoxious looking
one to psych out their opponent like
going there with like a red fiery one
and just constantly waving
as you're trying to play that's what i'm
going to do i'm going to get a an a
horrendous looking one right psych out
my opponents but obviously you can get
some cool looking ones too right or our
team colors yeah they're also
we also saw a look at the brand new
gears of war controller i assume xbox is
still going to be releasing game
specific ones is there going to be any
crossover with these ones i um i guess
we'll have to see how the system
develops you know we've we've put the
color out there as our as our platform
and um we're just waiting to see what
the reaction is which i think it's going
to be great um based on what i've been
hearing at the show um
but yeah we're waiting to see how things
sort of work out and then we'll we'll
figure out what comes next i think you
know the possibilities are endless and
people are going to find their own
creative ways to use the system i mean
there's a big like audience and a market
out there for like decals and that kind
of stuff so is that something you guys
have thought about in the future i'd
love to be able to put my own little
stickers and designs on there as well
yeah we've we've definitely thought
about it i can't like really
you know disclose any future plans but
um it's all you know
there's a lot there are a lot of
different ways to take this so
yeah is there any scope for maybe
expanding it to the xbox one
box console itself
i mean because
you've got the playstation 4 you can
have face plates which is a kind of
customization but if this seems like the
first step
you know to i mean people love it when
things are customized for themselves
right right well we're we're you know
we're seeing how this goes and we're
looking for people's feedback and then
we'll figure out you know what makes
what makes the best business sense but
we
we love delivering you know the the
the products or the visions that the the
fans
want so i think the more
the more people are asking for things
the more likely it is that you know
we're gonna we're gonna be able to
execute on those so what you're saying
is to start a petition yeah start a riot
yeah so the um the customization
software is uh the the
interactive experience is is super easy
and super intuitive and um i don't know
if so you have gotten a chance to try it
out i have yeah i think everyone here
has created their own unique one and um
i think they were available to try at
the microsoft event earlier where um i
did try and make some but promptly got
kicked off by someone with more artistic
talent than me okay okay
yeah so from creation
to shipping to delivery how long is that
process estimated to take i assume like
it's not launching for a little bit so
there will be a backlog right at the at
the moment if you pre-order uh you will
receive your controller in september but
after this pre-order window is over it
will be 14 days between
pressing order and having it delivered
to your doorstep okay that's actually
that's not really good it's pretty built
right it's pretty great for getting your
own you know custom build of of the
controller it's pretty amazing and in
terms of pricing do you know how much it
kind of uh
yeah it's 79.99 um and it's an extra
9.99 for the engraving awesome um very
cool
um what kind of things were there other
things that you ca maybe wanted to
change about the controller with this
program that maybe
weren't um applicable to like a mass
market kind of engineering project
um well we we settled on going we kind
of started the program just looking for
the best way to offer a customization
platform and we settled on color because
it's something that um that really
resonates with everyone it's like we
have this super diverse
fan base playing all sorts of games
different genders different ages into
different things but like everyone that
we talk to has a has this like emotional
visceral response to color so it just
seemed like the the best like most broad
way to reach
everyone um
you've got you've got a whole bunch of
colors here but do you think that you'll
be maybe continuing to add more to them
or is this kind of like the set color
scheme i you know i think as time goes
on we'll we'll have to you know take a
look at the colors and keep up with
just sort of the culture the culture and
and
trends and yeah i think i i think this
is probably going to be an evolving
business for us you must have done some
research at some point to find out what
the most popular color is can you
finally settle that debate oh yeah yeah
is it green uh it
i
i definitely know that in the xbox
community there's like there's an
affinity for green green yeah
but the most popular color it seems it
always bubbles up as blue oh really yeah
people love people love blue it's a
calming calming kind of color so when
you're playing gears of war and just
seeing stuff exploding from you just
have to look down just kind of look down
recenter yourself yeah remember where
you are in life and then carry on like
right or you can you can do red and
black
yeah red and black if you want to
channel some of that yeah kind of yeah
are xbox not concerned at all that
they're moving away from like their
their core branding yeah that's kind of
interesting um you know it was a big
discussion in our studio um you know
should we do this or should we not do
this but it kind of just comes down to
doing things for the fans and like
appreciating the fact that like
people people love to express themselves
you know people find different ways to
do it it's like the way you speak the
people you know the activities you
participate in the clothes you wear the
products you surround yourselves with
and um
and our products are they're
super important to some people you know
they're like a big part of
people's lives so just
kind of creating creating a platform out
of our products like a platform for
expression
we just kind of came around as a design
studio to understand that like that's
something really really special and
something that we want to be part of
um
say yes and no yeah
what i'm thinking is like in the future
if um you could sort of the way you you
can create custom decals and things i
could sort of see that as the like the
next thing that maybe you guys end up
doing with this because that seems like
a really cool opportunity people to
express themselves even more if this you
know takes off and already looks like it
has by the reaction right yeah yeah i
mean it's definitely been a conversation
we've definitely talked about things
like that but i couldn't i couldn't say
that anything's for sure you know we'll
just we're kind of seeing how
seeing how this goes and then
so you can pre-order now right exactly
yeah so you can you can go on to um
xbox
designlab.xbox.com
and
design your own controller and you can
save it you can save it to a gallery or
you can save it to any you know through
social media
and you can order order at any time
that's one super cool part of the
customization site is that you can go
into the community gallery and you can
you can see what people have created you
can be inspired and you can you can
start from there so you can start from a
blank controller if you just want a
clean slate
and if you need a bit of inspiration you
can start from
something that's been created in the
community and then kind of make it your
own how long is that pre-order window
when do you anticipate you'll be closing
it
um i think it's sometime in september
but it closed i don't know the exact
date right monique what person
personally what color controller would
you create going through the lab
you know i've made so many of them um
and then there was a formal beta that
came through the group and i just i
decided to make one for for my son and
he's he's five and he he loves to race a
yellow car he loves to play forza so
i didn't make one for myself but i made
one for him and it was like super fun to
just think about uh what he would like
and what's like appropriate for him
yeah so that's the one that's the one
that i've kind of created to take home
it's yellow it's yellow and gray
it's it's got a little engraving on it
awesome i think i might replicate this
because it's making me feel at peace you
feel calm i'm going to keep it i might
just keep this
well thank you so much for joining us
obviously it goes when when will we be
receiving the first batch of controllers
out in the out in the wild so the first
batch in the wild should be in september
anybody that pre-orders now should
should get their controllers in
september
thank you so much for joining us thank
you and for more coverage from this
year's e3 of course make sure you stay
tuned to gamespot.com
in darkness
i shall be light
[Applause]
[Music]
in times of doubt
i shall keep faith
[Music]
in throes of rage
i shall hone my craft
in vengeance
i shall have no mercy
[Music]
in the midst of battle
i shall have no fear
[Music]
in the face of death
i shall have no remorse
virtual
[Music]
won't be any longer
um
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
oh
welcome back to the game sports stage
here at e3 2016. joining tomorrow night
to talk about recall is joseph stattens
you're the senior creative director of
microsoft studios you're also writing
the game is that right that's right they
let me out of my cage to write this one
so that's been a lot of fun let's talk a
little bit about you know who's making
the games obviously it is a joint
venture between armature studios in
austin but also we've got concept which
is
inafunistan's studio over in japan how
do those two studios work together i
mean the time difference alone yeah is
one working ones asleep yeah absolutely
recore is this great international
project where we've got people in austin
and you know over in japan and other
places around the world too so it's been
actually a lot of fun that's what
microsoft publishing does really well is
bring together different teams to create
something really special i think record
is a great example of that what is
that's involvement in the game so he
he's been involved every step of the way
especially in the early concept phase i
mean he has a real love for memorable
colorful characters and you can see that
in the in the you know characters in the
game so he brought all of that strength
and armature do many things well but
they're great at systems and
like gameplay with the character stuff
it's it's very immediate the influence
in terms of game design and mechanics
that inafune seems to have whether it's
intentional or unintentional but like i
came away feeling like wow this is
there's a lot of mega man in this game
like the way it feels the way the
shooting works and the kind of the way
it challenges you to think about so much
at the same time while you're in combat
and stuff so absolutely yeah it's
definitely one of those games that you
look at and think oh that looks easy
that looks pretty simple it's you know
color matching but when you get into it
the mechanics are actually very deep and
you have a lot of options as a player
not just shooting with jewel but the way
that you control your core bots when you
send them in to interrupt enemy attacks
all those kinds of things we like to
talk about it as having a classic feel
like a classic mega man or metroid game
but brought into the modern era with a
you know modern engine and some uh
progression mechanics that mean you make
it feel fresh yeah i think i think one
of your developers said it like it's
it's a game about shooting but not
necessarily about focused aiming yeah
it's all about it's a lot about movement
and reacting to what's around you and
and kind of like take assessing threats
and then figuring out what you can do to
best manage those threats absolutely
absolutely yeah and i think mark pacini
the game director says that very well
it's not about aiming but it's a you
know it's a shooting game yeah yeah and
like
from a basic perspective like she's in
turn making the making the mega man
connection again she has her gun when
she fires like a spreadshot yep and then
you have a charge shot as well again
like mega man um absolutely so it's
about like doing damage managing like
your your the waves of enemies that are
approaching but then you have this
almost icarus style mechanic in the
corner the color matching can you tell
us a bit about that yeah absolutely so
you can see here uh yellow is good
against yellow it's really at that level
pretty pretty simple but because you
have encounters with multiple color
types of enemies it does get really
interesting to manage the system so
you're using your d-pad to swap between
different ammo types uh you know all the
colors and then white which is sort of a
neutral color that's good for for lots
of different kinds of enemies we're
still playing around in the polish phase
about do we want the different weapon
colors to have slightly different
effects fire rates that kind of stuff so
we continue to tune and it's been really
fun to bring it to e3 and have people
actually play it and give us some some
feedback on that right so the area i
played was very like
you'd get one type of color but i'm
right in thinking there's enemies that
change ah yes there may be i've heard
i've heard i've heard about like
shifting color phases and that kind of
stuff absolutely so there are more
challenging bosses sub bosses in the
game that don't start off they start off
as one color but they're able to adjust
your attacks and permute their colors so
you might be fighting a boss that can
cycle through
all the colors so this section i played
was what reminded me most of mega man
you have this giant enemy that is kind
of like he's my favorite enemy in the
game right his name what's his name well
he needs a better name which i'm going
to go back to redmond and figure
something out but we call him the master
spawner right now he's constantly
spewing as he spawns things so it's like
just this classic mega man style set up
where it's just this floating boss that
isn't directly damaging you it's just
menacing and it's like spewing enemies
and the challenges in kind of making
sure that you don't fall down a pit or
get overwhelmed while also making sure
that you've got the opportunity using
your opportunities to kind of like drop
a bomb in there or shoot him with a
blaster that's like one of the moments
where i was like this is mega man yeah
they're not calling it mega man but it
is absolutely he's called so there are
two types of robots in the game they're
the core bots like the spider and the
dog and the gorilla and then these
things we call core bytes that can be
very very small or very large like that
master spawner and each of the core
bytes and there are many of them in the
game they each have the sort of unique
gameplay hook we're showing off a couple
of them now but when you play the full
game there are lots and lots of
different enemies that you can that you
can fight against it's really fun yeah
the way that we mix and match them up
the encounters get really neat so you
mentioned the core bots and these are
also your companions right the main
characters jewel um she's kind of like
the scavenger type character almost a
little bit so jewel's really simple
story is that she's a colonist sent to
far eden to prepare it for many more
humans to arrive she goes to sleep for a
couple hundred years and expects far
eden to be full of water and trees and
totally terraformed but of course when
she wakes up none of that has happened
all the robot helpers have gone crazy so
she's a colonist but also a technician
responsible for maintaining some of
these terraforming systems
but she's given this big new challenge
that she was never prepared for which is
getting far even back on track
essentially saving it and then we're
seeing one of the core bots there so how
do the corebots kind of factor in we see
him when we first saw the trailer they
were kind of like this cool companion
but they actually
they kind of melded into gameplay way
more than initially than initially
expected right absolutely so when you
start the game as jewel you have your
companion that jewel was sent to far
eaten with each human is paired with a
core bot and she was paired with mac the
blue core in the dog and as you go
through the game she'll end up meeting
seth the the spider and duncan the big
ape frame each of them you can see here
seth has this unique ability to crawl
around spider rails in the world you
might see some spider rails early in the
game before you get seth and you'll be
able to later in the game backtrack to
those areas and access you know places
in the world that you couldn't before so
it has very much that uh metroid-ish
that's the connection to armature right
because that is x metroid prime
developers and that kind of stuff
absolutely so we can expect that kind of
like format where you're unlocking new
items going back rediscovering areas
within areas that you may have already
explored correct um
yeah do you sorry so what are the
callbacks all available from the very
start or is it just you know
you collect them as you go you unlock
them as you go yeah um from the chat we
have a question is obviously with the
color switching mechanic how have you
changed that for colorblind gamers you
know that's a good question and we do
have accessibility testing that we're
doing right now and that's the real good
part about the final polishing phase is
we're able to bring in lots of different
players and see how how they you know
can play and what we can do to make it
more accessible and i don't have the
right answer right now but that's the
phase that we're in right now with the
game right in terms of story that's the
one thing i wanted to discuss like the
area i played was quite light on story
obviously because it's in the middle a
challenge has or the mission has already
been set up so it's kind of isolated but
joel and her role is to kind of like
colonize get prepared the planet yeah
what's the kind of threat that she's
facing is she facing a frame is it just
a game about just kind of cleaning up
right yeah oh wouldn't that be fun that
would be amazing
fortunately it's it's a little more than
that so jewel came to far eden with a
group of colonists
but when she wakes up she's the last
human on the planet as far as she knows
all the core bots or most of them at
least have been corrupted by some
influence that she doesn't understand
right some of the core bots cores have
actually been turned black into the
strange corrupted form
so her first problem is hey how do i
actually get some get some help on my
side to to tackle some of these bigger
problems which is why she starts linking
up with the other core bots but the
bigger problem is
clearly there's probably some big bad
guy who's responsible for doing bad
things to the core bots so she's
fighting against that uh part and also
just
changing the world back to the way it
was meant to be so as you go through the
over world of far eden this desert place
you will also come across dungeons old
facilities buildings structures that
were meant to be
the things that brought far eden to life
those are the dungeons in our world and
jewel will go into those facilities get
them back online but the whole big goal
the big challenge is to rescue far eden
from these terrible storms that are
plaguing it and right
sorry so she as she's walking around is
she going to be talking to like the core
bots or is there going to be some
element of like self-talk because
obviously there's no other human
characters around so if anybody's ever
seen a lassie movie where the boy will
turn to lassie who goes
what's that lassie there's someone down
the well there's a little bit of that in
recore where she is conversing with mac
and seth who speak in this digimote
language we call it but jewel's able to
understand it so she's able to have
conversations with the core bots in the
world um and we tell the story that way
but also some other
ways that we're telling the story that
we're not revealing today but uh suffice
it to say jewel does not just sort of
walk around talking to herself wondering
what's going on but
each of the core bots has their own
personality um and that shows through in
the way that she talks to them and
interacts with them it also seems to be
built into their character's design as
well right was that a lot of fun to kind
of combine the character's design with
the the character that you were writing
at the same time absolutely so i think
um it's pretty easy to make a charming
dog everybody knows what dogs do when
they're scared or injured but to make a
charming spider that was a really fun
challenge from a character design point
of view and seth when you first meet him
with the yellow core is a very cowardly
spider so he's twitchy and nervous and
he scrunches up into a little cute ball
when he's afraid um duncan the big gruff
gorilla is very stubborn and tough and
so
uh getting those personalities into them
was a was a real uh a real treat and
where inafune-san and armature and their
special magic together really came
together you've got a dog in there for
the dog people out there will there be a
cat for the cat people i'm a cat guy and
i'm frankly a bit sad i've not seen a
cat yet you know what i'm here i've had
lots of questions about cat and maybe
i'm biased because i'm a total dog guy
cat people are cool too
we know we know
i suffice it to say that um we would
love it if recourse a success and we can
continue the story beyond the first
version and there are a ton of great
other core bots that we have designs for
that we just didn't have time to build
so what you're saying is cat dlc
that's not a bad idea yeah
so there's an area just beyond this bit
that i played that kind of really
highlighted what i loved about recall
and it's an area where you're kind of in
an arena but the floor of the arena is
split up into three areas that are
catching fire one by one yes and at the
same time you're battling these waves of
different types of enemies that also
have different colors so it's really
about
having so much laid on top of each other
and then just remembering how to use
each part to your advantage and the best
way to use your abilities and movements
and stuff exactly you know we say i
think for a lot of games that it's
deceptively simple it's easy to start
playing but it's really deep and
challenging to further you get into it
you know that really is true with record
you look at it and think oh it's a color
matching game it's going to be pretty
straightforward but no like there are
rooms that are that are tough like real
real challenges and we've had people
come back through the line a couple
times because they really really wanted
to beat the flame room they got close
but they couldn't quite do it once you
get familiar with the controls it's this
awesome ballet of choices where you as a
player have jewel's weapon you have the
core bots you have all their special
abilities and the flame room when you
look at it first like oh my god how am i
gonna like get to the flame room but
once you get into it and start to play
it's it's really satisfying yeah and
that's not an exaggeration because like
i was telling you earlier in my demo
the the person in front of me was dying
so much that i was like i need to call
someone and get yeah okay
i need to have my goal here so i can get
out of it yeah but yeah it is difficult
and and there's also like in my written
preview of it i also kind of likened
elements of it to a bullet hell shooter
yeah because obviously like mega man
jewel has the thrusters on her feet that
she can use to give her some like air
control and dashing and at times there's
so many enemies that are all firing
these lasers at you that you've kind of
like
identify the hole and just like jump and
use your thruster to kind of get through
there so you can get a bit of like
breathing room and then you can use that
so like was that an influence too like
stuff like ikaruga and you know shooters
yeah and i don't know if you noticed
this but there is really no cover in the
game
motion correct so we like to say that
your movement is your cover right for
joule to evade the attacks like the
expanding fire rings or the you know
laser line that'll stun you it's really
all about jumping dashing getting out of
the way so
that movement is you know super
important not just for the platforming
traversal challenge but actually to
survive in in combat joseph thank you so
much for joining us um i know you kind
of you guys are like in the final
polishing stages but give us a quick
reminder of the release date so record
is coming out starting september 13th of
this year for xbox one and windows 10
and it's part of the uh xbox play
anywhere program it's actually the first
game coming out for that so buy it on
one platform play it on the other vice
versa awesome that all works great thank
you so much
and for more coverage from this year's
e3 of course make sure you stay tuned to
gamesbot.com
[Music]
peggy 18.
the augmented era began with such
promise
[Music]
until the incidents turned the world
upside down
50 million dead
hundreds of thousands more maimed and
injured
[Music]
all because a few rich opportunists
plotted in secret to control us
today hatred of hogs has morphed into a
full-blown mechanical apartheid with
violent clashes fueling unrest
the augmented are suffering a genocide
it begins with taking away our rights
treating us as less than human and then
exterminating us
something big is brewing and i need to
cut it off at the source
how can these people always be one step
ahead we've got unlimited power and
money and absolutely no conscience at
all that's how they manipulated the dawn
of human 2.0
made it dangerous
made me
i'm going to use every advantage i have
to stop them
[Music]
my advanced capabilities convinced
interpol to recruit me to their
counter-terrorism task force
despite objections within the team
i'm willing to endure their prejudice so
long as it furthers my hunt for the true
threat not gonna go all wonky on us now
hanza oh yeah if i do mccready
i guarantee you'll never see it coming
turns out my military-grade enhancements
were hiding a full set of cutting-edge
experimental logs
you're telling me i got more implants
than i thought i did
more than your body can handle meaning
my ability to infiltrate
fights
and circumvents
has now grown exponentially
right along with the increasing threat
level
being stationed in prague places me at
the epicenter of terrorist activity
and with blame for the latest atrocity
being leveled in an augmented group
there
the only certainty is that the body
count will keep rising
our territory is fiercely defended
no one sets foot in there
the task force wants me to bring ark's
leader to justice dealing with his
augmented army as i see fit
starting my investigation by
interrogating talos rucker on the
realities of his non-violent approach
could prove beneficial
every floor of their towering complex is
packed with armed militia and filled
with high-end security
but its makeshift construction provides
me with plenty of options
going in full force and guns blazing may
result in casualties but if i want a
strong arm rucker into surrendering it
makes sense to use force
engaging them with modified firearms
explosive nanoblades
[Music]
and using my titan shield to negate
their counter fire as i roll through
like a reinforced tank i have known
exactly the kind of thug you are since
the moment you entered if ark had no
involvement in the bombing it might
justify going in like a ghost
hacking their security systems
using the architecture to my advantage
delivering concussive blasts via the
pep's gun and relying on the tesla's
electrified projectiles to avoid any
unnecessary deaths
[Applause]
a lack of casualties would be a show of
respect to someone like rucker
and might just convince him to
peacefully turn himself in faced with
two terrible choices i choose the lesser
evil
i will come with you
but he and ark represent just one facet
of my hunt for the truth
and i'll need to keep tracking down
leads and making contacts on both sides
of the law if i hope to uncover the true
motives behind these escalating attacks
it's not always about doing the right
thing
or about doing things the right way
intel gathered from allies outside the
task force has me questioning everything
including the true intentions of my own
command
if you're meeting with miller be careful
you walked into another ambush and
miller's not off my suspect list yet
everyone's got their agenda
meaning i'll have to trust my gut when
dealing with suspects how far are you
willing to go to help out a friend in
need
whether i'm working by the book or going
rogue
choice never comes with a consequence
what's the going rate for cops in golem
city you're making a very dangerous
assumption the clock is always ticking
and unraveling the mystery on my own
terms
may be the only way to prevent disaster
there is a moment coming and it will be
soon when all of us will have to choose
a side
as antioch conflicts become a global
concern
prague represents just one square on a
giant chessboard whose pieces are
continually manipulated from the shadows
i have to choose my allies wisely
reminding myself of the greater cause
the elites may obscure themselves in
darkness
but the truth is still mine to reveal
i don't care that they only speak in
whispers
i won't let them have the last word
so
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to the
gamespot stage here at e3 2016. i'm mary
and i'm going to be your host for the
next two full hours and i'm delighted to
be joined by my very best friend and
gamespot review editor peter brown what
an introduction i know there's nothing
better for you and the uh community
manager for bungie this is deej nice to
have you guys here thank you nice to be
here and uh obviously we're gonna have
to start this off by talking about what
everybody wants to talk about which is
rise of iron uh the latest uh upcoming
uh expansion for destiny all of that is
absolutely right yeah rise of iron is a
large expansion to the destiny universe
uh it's coming out this fall february
20th uh we're telling uh new stories in
new places where you'll be fighting new
enemies uh acquiring new weapons and
armor uh making your character powerful
in new ways this is something that we
just revealed just prior to e3
got to have a conversation with our
community on twitch uh interviewed some
of the developers who are also here with
me at e3 as part of our bungie away team
and we're really excited to be welcoming
the guardians back to destiny to
continue their adventures and evolve
their characters in some brand new and
exciting ways yeah it sounds like you
guys have been constantly working with
uh
the players to see and get feedback back
and forth and one of the main things
that i'm sure you guys were very eagerly
anticipating was the announcement of the
galler horn and uh bringing that back
can you tell us a little bit more about
it is it going to be as powerful as it
once was well the galler horn will be
actually even more powerful because it's
going its power levels are going to need
to rise so that it can help the
guardians confront this new threat they
have an all-new enemy to fight uh the
galler horn will be restored to uh its
old prowess it was one of the most
iconic weapons in the first year of
destiny that's right and uh we're really
looking forward to putting it back into
the hands of the players uh every
guardian is going to forge their own
galler horn as part of a quest so
whereas they may be used to waiting for
it to drop as a random reward in an
activity now it is something that it's a
guaranteed virtue uh as the completion
for uh a quest
now tell me a little bit about the
plaguelands zone uh uh what's it
comparable to and there are any new
mechanics yeah the plaguelands have a
bunch of new surprises for players it's
a landscape that is forever transformed
by the outbreak of a technological
plague the fallen have discovered that
force of technology they're using it to
twist their minds and their bodies in a
bid to become machine gods so the
players of destiny are going to
infiltrate the plague lands a zone that
has for a long time been forbidden from
exploration so in rise of iron we're
welcoming them to go into that space
they're going to be all sorts of new
ways to patrol the plague lands there's
going to be new public events things
that bring guardians together who have
never met before to enjoy a moment of
action
new story missions we have strikes we
have raids
rise of iron satisfies every player of
destiny with the infusion of new action
and adventure across the entire spectrum
of the player experience now do our new
fallen foes have any new moves that we
should be aware of that uh current ones
don't yeah they've got some they got
some surprises up their sleeve they
fight in some interesting new ways they
die in some interesting new ways we had
a studio-wide play test on friday just
before we came down to e3 which was
great for me to really be able to put
eyes on what we were going to be talking
about you know and lay hands on a
controller and experience it myself and
it's always great when you're facing a
new foe because when something new
catches your eye and something takes you
by surprise i mean that's that's part of
the destiny player experience it's
they're supposed to be moments that
surprise you it's supposed to be
relatable but also packed with new and
interesting things to you know entertain
and delight you guys have been working
on expansions for a while now and i'm
curious do you feel that you've sort of
hit a stride where you understand what
the player base wants and how to both
deliver upon that and surprise them yeah
i think definitely
we walk and talk differently as
developers than we did the first year of
destiny uh
destiny was a very new thing for bungie
we were certainly used to making
first-person shooters and story-driven
experiences uh but we've never had a
game that was this ambitious you know
with the scope and the scale and the all
you know the
persistent connectivity uh the
persistent character progression you
know we were delving into a lot of new
things for us uh now that we
understand who our audience is now that
we know who our audience is and we know
where we can listen to them and engage
in conversation with them certainly uh
you know there's a collaboration you
know we can take a lot of inspiration
from them um you know we inspire them to
do awesome things they inspire us to do
awesome things uh in terms of hitting a
stride i mean this is the fourth
expansion uh in you know just under two
years so we've delivered pretty frequent
content updates uh of course any player
of a game that truly loves that game
wants more content all the time you know
we'd love to be able to satisfy that
urge but at the same time we want to
create things that we think are worthy
of the passion and enthusiasm that
they've invested into the game that
we've invested into creating that world
for them to explore so it's it's a
healthy balance um we
have people who create experiences like
rise of iron that tell new stories and
expand the boundaries of the world of
destiny we also have a live team and
they're constantly giving players fresh
reasons to come back to the game limited
time events uh even if it's just things
that we did like in april where was like
new gear sets new playable activities uh
bringing new features online we've got
this chroma system now where your armor
can glow in different colors
it's not just about kicking ass and
making stuff blow up it's about a game
that is uh
enabling your own creative expression
yeah because the character that you
create is an expression of who you feel
you would be as a hero in this world i
look at the equipment sets and i look at
my friends who play this game a lot and
one of the things that they're very
attracted to are the armor you know and
the weapons that they get and i look at
those things and the design is so
distinct compared to a lot of other
games destiny is very fashionable in
that sense i feel like i want to know
more about how you go about designing
these things and you know maybe when
something has taken the design a little
bit too far like how do you actually
define like this fits the destiny visual
style or this is redefining the
destination i think creating a character
and and making that character powerful
and making that character unique is an
enormous component of you know the
player fantasy yeah uh you know so the
art team takes a look at the archetypes
that we want to create you know at a
glance you can take a look at different
players of destiny and you can say you
know this warlock that is adorned in
iron banner gear looks like a heraldic
knight they're a champion of the
crucible this hardcore raider looks like
it's wearing the teeth of an enormous
final boss this person is a hardcore
raider uh this person is decked out in
the color scheme of a faction so either
you really love to wear black or you're
interested in the dead orbit lore you
know sort of like this nihilistic
space-faring desperation
so what we want to do is we want to give
players an opportunity to create a
character that they feel reflects
their imagination right and then also
provide evidence and signposts to the
other players of the game is like at a
glance looking at me you know what i
love i can equip my favorite weapon on
my back in the social spaces so i always
walk around with a big belt fed heavy
machine gun on my back so that people
know i'm not about precision i need all
the bullets even specifically i look at
the galler horn and it's got so many
different facets to it yeah it's so
intricately designed yeah like
how many iterations did you go through
when designing that oh god i mean we
actually um
have welcomed some of the concept
artists uh onto the stream and what
would happen
is uh you know they would have an
initial concept someone takes that
initial concept and they literally do a
paint over and they're like this rocket
launcher looks beautiful and it's ornate
and it's awesome and it's definitely
like an iconic weapon that i'd love to
add to my arsenal but i'm gonna put a
lot of wolves on it right you know so
it's definitely a collaborative
experience everything starts with that
spark of creative inspiration it starts
with an idea and a sketch then it
becomes a hard surface 3d model and then
we go in and we add the color and you
know the sparkle and the shine and all
the things that really make it you know
the finished product then you slide that
thing over the sandbox team they take
that and they say and a weapon this
beautiful a weapon this iconic with
these gilded figures and these wonderful
accents this needs to be amazing so
we're going to fill it up with wolf pack
rounds so this thing's going to be a
cluster bomb launcher you know now
speaking of weapons uh will there be any
new weapons in the game that haven't
been in any other games previously
something brand new absolutely yeah we
have all new armor sets all new weapon
sets uh they're gonna be new exotic
weapons uh you know they're gonna be
plenty of things to add to your
inventory to stow in your vault uh
that's essentially
the reward for the action that you'll
find in destiny is you get new things
you add that to your inventory those
things make you more powerful they
change the way you fight we're going to
have new ways for guardians to feel
powerful and to affect the way the
combat sandbox works new perks
new tactical abilities so that's the
destiny player experience you go out you
complete your missions you defeat your
enemies you get awesome rewards that
make you feel like you're evolving and
you're becoming this legendary figure in
the game now there's also been uh
already a raid confirmed is there
anything that you can tell us about this
raid confirmed so we are facing off
against the fallen the fallen devil
splicers are the enemy in destiny rise
of iron they have burrowed deep into the
old golden age vaults that are deep
beneath old russia and they found this
terrible technology
we need to infiltrate their enemy
stronghold and hopefully destroy the
source of their power once and for all
so it delivers that raid promise you're
going to need a fire team of six players
those players are going to need to do
more than just show up they're going to
need to communicate they're going to
need to problem solve together raids are
mysteries mysteries that are solved by
new teammates and old friends and the
less we tell people about the raid the
more the payoff the greater the payoff
is
now
you are now going to have about three
social spaces how does bungie balance
all these different social spaces and
what kind of makes you motivate players
into going into the new one well the um
fell winter peak is the new social space
so that is the uh the abandoned outpost
that was once inhabited by the iron
lords they're these old legendary
figures that used to defend humanity in
ancient times they all sacrificed
themselves in the original confrontation
with this technological plague that is
the major threat that you'll find in
rise of iron different social spaces in
the game
serve different purposes especially
through your progression through the
destiny story the first place you arrive
at is the tower you know it's this
bright hopeful place it's all polished
beautiful banners hanging from the
ramparts it's motivating it's motivating
right like you know that you're
this may be a post-apocalyptic game but
there's still a world worth defending
humanity's still in a pretty decent
place underneath this mysterious
benefactor later on with the house of
walls we'd opened up the reef a lot more
utilitarian very industrial it was a
spaceport occupied by you know the
awoken who was sort of like removed
themselves from human society and uh
that was a different mood for us to
strike like an underground bunker it was
uh very different from like the
buildings which was more of like a hope
feel this was more of a there's a lot of
work to be done still yeah yeah almost
like almost like a pirate port or
something like that you know you're out
there on the outskirts you know and um
we had some different experiences there
you know like that's where you uh
participate in the prison of elders that
would be where you go back out on the
awoken's quest for revenge against the
fallen uh with rise of iron we have a
whole new feel this is an abandoned
place in fact your first step like when
you arrived at the tower it was like
hello welcome to the tower this is your
ghost this is your vault uh when you
first arrived in the reef there was sort
of this ambivalence you know the
non-player characters were kind of glad
to see you uh when you arrive at fell
winter peak you will be immediately
attacked okay because it has been
infiltrated by our enemy and their first
step in creating this new social space
is to capture it to reclaim it okay
these are where the monuments to the
iron lords exist this is where lord
saladin the sole surviving member of the
iron lords has kept their memories alive
and
as all of the guardians are welcome to
become iron lords themselves step one is
to claim that outpost and set it up as a
base of operations from there we launch
off on this new story that sends you
deep into the plaguelands
to figure out what happens there sounds
like there's still a lot to be uncovered
here and i just got one more question
for you is there going to be a
collector's edition uh we're not making
a collector's edition um certainly the
iron galler horn which is uh a different
variant of the galler horns beautiful
black and silver uh you know walks like
a galler horn talks like a gala horn but
it's just in my opinion just a little
sexier and you can get that if you
pre-order rise of iron before we launch
uh but we are having uh one version of
rise of iron that people can buy on xbox
one and playstation 4. and that is
available september 20th is that right
this is absolutely correct all right
thanks a lot dude so uh you heard it
right here uh you're going to see rise
of iron available on september 20th for
ps4 and xbox one and you guys don't go
anywhere we have a lot more coming up
and we're going to be talking to
psionics we have a lot of really good
interviews coming up so don't go
anywhere stay right here
and stay tuned to gamespot
virtual reality isn't a recent invention
but thanks to the efforts of oculus it's
more viable than ever at six hundred
dollars oculus rift is expensive and
when you add the cost of an
appropriately powered pc vr as a whole
is almost prohibitively priced for the
majority of gamers after spending a week
using rift however i can look past the
price tag and see it for what it is a
key to a new era of entertainment it
lets you engage with games in ways that
haven't been possible before instilling
a tangible sense of presence that's
immediately exciting
[Music]
rift and its accompanying accessories
feel like premium products nothing about
it feels cheap or compromised while it's
hard to completely forget you're wearing
it rift never feels like a burden when
you're mentally invested in a vr
experience that said games can still
play with your senses in undesirable
ways that rift can't account for on its
own a drift for example is a game about
floating through a broken space station
your body twists and turns with
simulated weightlessness and this made
me feel so uncomfortable that i had to
stop playing it it's a product of how
good rift is at convincing your brain
that what you're seeing is real and
evidence of the fact that software is an
equally important part of the equation
ript is for more than just games however
and some of the most enchanting and
least intense vr experiences are passive
there are 360 degree videos taken from
locales around the world as well as 3d
rendered short films that transport you
to other worldly locations offering a
taste of what a virtual tourism and
storytelling will be like once vr gains
traction outside of video games in order
to get a smooth and enjoyable experience
with rift you need a better than average
gaming pc the requirements aren't
outrageous and some people may only need
to upgrade one or two components in
their existing pc to get started but to
build or purchase a rift-ready system
will cost at a minimum close to one
thousand dollars raising the entry fee
considerably for some customers oculus
has cultivated a wide array of games and
passive experiences for launch and
everyone who has pre-ordered a rift gets
two games for free one is lucky's tale a
3d platformer set in an adorable cartoon
landscape that borrows heavily from
games like super mario 64. the other is
eve valkyrie a dogfighting game set in
space with racing sports adventure
horror strategy and puzzle games to name
a few of the genres represented in the
launch lineup there are plenty of ways
to explore the potential vr introduces
to video games
of course just because the game is in vr
doesn't mean it's good by default eve
valkyrie for example is littered with
microtransactions that detract from its
initial appeal lucky's tale while
charming and fun pads out its levels by
forcing you to replay them with
alternate objectives after five hours
battling my way through an enigmatic
dungeon kronos is so far an amazing game
that recalls favorites like resident
evil the legend of zelda and dark souls
however it stumbles on occasion due to a
handful of design flaws including the
unforgiving way that it allows you to
walk into pitfalls some of which are
difficult to see due to kronos's use of
fixed camera perspectives clearly vr
games are susceptible to the same
problems as regular games but there's
something about the unique vr experience
that makes up the difference at least a
little bit when i'm flying around in e
valkyrie immersed in my virtual cockpit
soaring through space debris i'm
entranced by how convincing it feels
when you're playing a game on a monitor
the real world is an equal view when
that is stripped away and filled in with
the world of the game you're playing in
vr it's a very powerful experience that
traditional gaming platforms simply
don't offer 600 is a lot to pay for a
piece of gaming hardware but rift is
different from a console or a new
graphics card rift allows you to
experience games in ways we've only
dreamed of up until now and while it
does require you accept a few
compromises in the name of immersion
it's worth it yes you will look silly to
anyone who watches you use it and you'll
potentially feel uneasy after an intense
demo but these issues can't take away
from the fact that rift delivers on its
promise to enable more immersive and
personal gaming experiences than we've
ever seen before
[Music]
do
down
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the gamespot
stage at e3 2016. i'm mary your host for
the next couple hours and i'm delighted
to be joined by gamespot reviews editor
peter brown
as well as rich and megan from crystal
dynamics thanks for joining us yeah it's
great to be here and you guys uh you
guys have something very special to
share with us this is uh not just you
know some clips or some new assets we're
talking about a legacy of lara croft and
tomb raider because it's her birthday
and she is turning 20 years old this
year
it's really exciting for us because we
are you know this year celebrating 20
years of an icon you know lara croft has
had such an impact on culture and on the
gaming industry and on our fans and so
it's great to be able to look back and
celebrate all the moments and you know
megan's gonna share a few details with
you on some of the things that we've
uncovered but
we kicked things off obviously with you
know the rise of the tomb raider launch
on pc in january uh and then we had
laura's birthday the official birthday
in february and then in march we
partnered with game changer charity uh
to reveal our 20 years of an icon logo
so we're trying to do something every
month to to surprise our fans and to
reward them and and we're basically
making sure that we have something new
every single month to celebrate what
we're calling the year of tomb raider
yeah and there's so much to celebrate
not only you know the legacy of the tomb
raider franchise but lara croft herself
as this very interesting and iconic
character that uh is just so well known
not just in the game world but i mean
she has moved through movies she's been
on magazine covers i mean that girl's
been everywhere yeah absolutely and one
of the things that we revealed at pax
east was our first really big drop and
so we revealed an official tomb raider
20th anniversary book which we will have
the cover reveal at the end of this
segment which is so exciting yeah and i
have a big book coming out yeah and i
had the like incredible
responsibility and honor of writing it
so it was a lot of fun it was also an
experience that kind of made me feel
like a tomb raider myself like digging
up all these old assets um so that it's
been a really cool experience writing
that and we also revealed the original
composer for tomb raider one through
three he's remastering and reimagining
the soundtrack from the first three
games and he's putting it together in a
compilation called the tomb raider suite
he's gonna take it on tour with a
concert uh it's gonna be really really
amazing so things like that these these
ways to celebrate different facets of
what tomb raider means to people we're
going to be doing throughout the entire
year absolutely because there's just so
many different ways that you can view
tomb raider or lara croft as this icon
she's gone through a lot of changes over
20 years as most people do through their
first 20 years
you know from the braid to the outfits
to even like her signature flip when she
jumps i mean a lot of things have
changed but uh it sounds like you guys
actually have some old assets that you
dug through that you are excited to show
us yeah it was it was really fun so on
social media we're basically every two
weeks swapping out a new game so we
started with tomb raider one we're into
tomb raider three now but some of the
stuff that we dug out for tomb raider
two was really exciting and i think
we're gonna scroll through some of those
but uh 1997 in tomb raider for
terminator 2 it was just a really really
breakout year for for the franchise in
terms of
transcending beyond gaming um here's one
of the original pieces of tomb raider 2
concept art oh she looks very rugged but
she does have her iconic braid yeah oh
that looks like a comic strip i know i
love it and so yeah 1997 was a really
big year for tomb raider and that's um
when they first got the the first bites
of interest for comics um you know
that's even when they first started
getting people reaching out about movie
potential as the second year of the
franchise and it didn't really it wasn't
seen to fruition until 2001 but they had
animation studios reaching out movie
studios reaching out trying to to gauge
interest
and then eventually they went forward
and started pitching it to hollywood but
it was it was a big year and laura
transcended gaming she became this pop
culture icon
the thing that i always loved you know
mary you mentioned how she's changed all
over the 20 years but there's also
things that have remained constant
things that are just intrinsic to lara
croft you know you think about her
intelligence you know her drive her will
her bravery you know
she has these things that you just
always associate with her whether it's
the classic games from core whether it's
you know the crystal games like legend
and and and underworld or the new reboot
modern you know survival action games
there's always these things that you
just feel like they are just
part of lara croft and make her the
cultural icon that she is yeah and
that's why she's resonated so much with
the fans and and that's something in
particular with the book that i'm really
proud of is we have 100 pages i counted
it 100 pages dedicated to our community
in this book and and and laura as this
character who has evolved
has appealed to the fandom in so many
unique ways
it's funny because they're all very
unique and personal stories and at the
same time they're also like this
universal story of of their connection
with lara and so we explore a lot of
those and it's a it's just lovely to see
how everybody's banded together over
here over the last 20 years yeah series
like uh you know tomb raider you you
look at it and uh and over the years
it's sort of you can say okay where was
gaming at that point in time and where
was lara and they seem to be like almost
in lockstep with one of one another you
know and uh i remember the first time i
played the game it was uh it was on pc
when it just dropped i think it just got
broadband and that was one of the first
things i was able to download
and
i was i was really blown away by the
original game and i'm curious how far
like did you guys get your hands on it
back then when it first came out like
what did it mean to you absolutely yes
that's why i'm in gaming i think i mean
laura inspired me to
you know always be
brave and bold and to it was one of the
things that made me want to work in
gaming because i was so impressed by its
ability to convey emotion and atmosphere
and all these things and it was sort of
the first time i felt represented in
video games and it's so funny i tell it
to people it's like i really didn't have
much in common with her she's like this
really wealthy british aristocrat with
dual guns and super acrobatic and all
these sorts of things but she was a lady
and she had brown hair and that's all i
needed as a 12 year old was to feel
inspired she was super head strong and
like she was just a really rad character
tell yourself i think you're pretty
acrobatic
your eyes climbing like that
she cosplays as larkoff she's climbing
up an ice glacier or something i'm like
okay that looks a little bit i think
that the time i spilled coffee in your
office means i'm a little lost but then
she did a backflip off the end of the
table but i appreciate that it's yeah
it's so much fun though because you know
i've been playing it from the beginning
you know back in 1996 and for me
it it brought together so many things
that i'd never experienced in a video
game not just lara croft and how you
know amazing it was to have a hero like
that on screen that i'd never seen
before in gaming but you know when you
walked into a tomb and that sense of
isolation and just grandeur and the way
that they had changed is how adventure
was delivered and and her attitude and
it put so many things together that
other games maybe had had touched upon
but i've never gotten that complete
package and that was that was really the
year that i started to really fall in
love with gaming and i will never forget
the first time i did the swan dive i
probably i'd probably share that with
many many millions of people around the
world but the first time you do a swan
dive and you're just you're like okay
this is the first t-rex
oh like walking into that first cave
yeah in peru and like there's that pool
of water and i would always run for the
pool water and like hide there because i
was afraid of the bear
but i mean you know i'm really guilty of
this i tend to talk a lot about laura
and lara's amazing and huge inspiration
so many people but the game like you
guys are saying the game was so
incredible and it was so immersive in
this beautiful 3d world that you could
interact with and you could see laura
and and see how she interacted versus
like the first person games and it was
just
such a unique game and that isolation
the willingness to have moments of quiet
and moments with nothing going on but
gameplay was also quite innovative i
mean tomb raider 2 did a lot of firsts
for a lot of games that were 3d which
was like a pretty unsure thing back in
the day back in the 90s that was like
something that they did and um i
remember getting the demo on a
playstation
when you're like in venice and um even
like
as little as swimming in 3d was really
uh new uh wall climbing yeah uh
traversal through vehicles like
snowmobile and things like that those
are all gameplay elements that were just
unbelievably fun didn't matter who i was
i was having a really good time
the mixing of action and puzzles that
you get the highs of being able to shoot
bears in caves but then right after that
you have to use your brain and you have
to figure out how to get something or
the uniqueness of exploration of finding
secrets so it really encouraged people
to go into you know into new areas
absolutely and when you talk about how
you know laura has changed but also kept
things that are intrinsic to her over
the 20 years i think the same thing on
the gameplay side you know obviously
with the reboot you know the modern
survival action
you know grounded you know mature feel
to it's very different for us with what
we're doing now with crystal but rise of
the tomb raider the main reason why lara
can swim in that game is because the
fans wanted that they asked for it and
and we felt like that was the perfect
type of nostalgic thing that we could
include as a way to to pay homage to the
to the previous game or you know things
like the bear or having now the manor in
the cut scenes so you know we i love
looking at it and i love working on it
from from not just a we're
steering this huge incredibly
influential franchise but also as a fan
you know i get to see those things that
i loved when i was playing the original
games now coming back into rise of the
tomb raider as we see lara you know
continuing to progress toward that tomb
raider that we all know and love you
know what i really want to have bring
back is being able to like mess around
in the manor before you actually go out
into the game in the original games you
could always just like hang out in her
mansion and pretend you were super rich
and like get lost in the maze or uh do
all these like different flips and stuff
a lot of people seem to be interested in
it it was just such an awesome thing to
enjoy that had nothing to do with the
game but was fun to do it was so much a
part of her personality and it sold that
aristocratic element to her you know
just listening to the classic piano
music and seeing the harp in her
gymnasium
and you know and there were secrets in
her house if you were like investigating
enough um so it sounds like you guys
have like a lot of stuff that you were
able to cover and you're kind of like
going into the closet of all these
all these moments of history from uh
this wonderful series and you had to
shove it into a book a very small
book how did you do it all in a pretty
large book
it is pretty incredible
i i have to say you know i i cannot
i can't even state the amount of heart
and soul that megan put into this
there's nobody better to write it but
this is literally not just the most
comprehensive book that i've ever seen
on tomb raider but of any video game
franchise ever i mean this thing is
absolutely massive the amount of things
that megan was able to uncover you know
she she can't tutor own horn like this
i think fans of the franchise young and
old of the classic as well as the modern
they're going to find something to like
because there is
so much in the book that celebrates you
know lara croft and celebrates the
gameplay and behind the scenes stuff
around the development that you didn't
know and stuff around the movie that i
had no idea about around the comics
around the fans like megan said with so
much content dedicated to the cosplayers
and the people who do the paper craft
and like there is so much in this book
it is
it's going to be a treasure i guarantee
for any fan i hope people enjoy it yeah
i mean it was it was a really incredible
experience writing it and i have to
admit it was a little intimidating
talking to some of my like my heroes
from my youth and getting to chat with
the core design crew and people who
wrote and designed and the art for my my
game the games that inspired me growing
up it was it was really incredible and
set dressers from the movie and people
sending me photos like physical photos
like do you want it very personal to
put them in the book and it was it was a
really incredible experience so
hopefully people will enjoy it sounds
good it's big so yeah that's the thing
like i have to give prima
a huge
thank you for this because i kept
exceeding my word count and
they stopped saying
they were like just don't worry just
give us what you think the book should
be and it ended up being
350 pages okay yeah they they increased
the size quite a bit
for me which i appreciate well i'm sure
the fans will thank them as well so uh
when can people expect to see this book
on
shelves or so later this year yes okay
so uh late fall time frame is when we're
currently planning to release it but we
did have a little yeah eyes around we
have the cover finished uh we we are
going to be the cover here yeah
something that's really exciting
to cover pretty soon a little bit of the
design of it um but you want to talk
about the design of the 20 year logo and
how we use that on this yeah
absolutely i think that one of the
things that was really important to us
was making sure that when we're
celebrating 20 years of an icon that
when you look at the logo you're not
thinking oh that's lara from this game
or oh that's classic lara versus you
know modern survival action you know
tomb raider lara
so it was a long and involved process um
but it was it was a great and
collaborative process you know with the
with the team and and the artists there
to pull together a representation of
lara that still has those iconic
you know traits that i mentioned so you
instantly look at it you recognize that
silhouette is lara croft
but you actually can't tell you know
which version of lara croft is it
because it's actually meant to be all of
them there's things in there that are
shared across both them there are things
that are unique to each version of lara
croft so we look at the at the 20 years
of an icon logo as sort of a celebration
and amalgamation of
how she's changed over the 20 years so
you can't when you look at it you can't
quite tell if she has a braid or a
ponytail you can't quite tell if that
little silhouette on the side of her is
a bit of a backpack or is she wearing
pants or shorts and are those dual
holsters or is that the single holster
from the new games you know so it's it's
a really neat visual uh play on all of
the different silhouettes of laura and i
don't think anyone has anyone uncovered
the secret message that's inside the
logo yeah the fansites they did
all right sorry they figured it out like
so quickly but i'm not sure i don't
think the general population has so we
can so there's actual secrets from the
logo itself it is all about
discoverability the tomb raider
franchise is about you know finding what
was lost and so in the logo itself
there's actually a few secrets yeah
there's nothing more than a sense of
discovery that kind of reminds me of the
tomb raider series that's really cool
that you were able to uh capture that in
basically like a logo that's just like
it doesn't even have color right like
you've made a silhouette of laura to
kind of contain it because she's gone
through so many color evolutions as well
the bright teal top yeah
there's so many things that are very
iconic color wise to tomb raider whether
it's like the teal of the top and then
since it's evolved so much yeah keeping
the very classic silhouette was the way
to do it
and the red and the gold the celebratory
colors so
yeah okay and and so that's something
that we can expect to see later this
year when it when that will probably be
something you guys kind of have more
announcements coming up we will have
something every single month for our
fans again this this year of tomb raider
is all about finding ways to celebrate
with the fans letting fans tell us you
know we have a video testimonial site if
you go to tomb raider 20.com it's
basically our hub where you can see all
the activity we have going on you know
fan art contests
there's a way that our fans can be
immortalized in a print project that
we're going to reveal later this year so
we just revealed a statue that we're
doing so you can actually go to go to in
like a half hour so we'll have the poll
up but lara croft facebook page and uh
we have a series of statues through
gaming heads who are super super
talented
like gaming statues and it's a six
statue series they're one fourth size
statue
they're large
and they fit together all six of them so
there's three from core design there's
three from crystal dynamics different
iconic outfits and the fans can actually
vote between if they want to have the
tomb raider chronicles cat suit laura
and the black suit or if they want the
tomb raider angel of darkness and that
will be the final statue so much all
right well i think we've done enough
hype let's uh let's see it let's see the
cover um this is the
reveal of the tomb raider icon well
that's the yep there's the icon there
and you can see the the text that rich
was talking about
a little secret message in there and
then there's the book oh nice yeah so we
wanted to keep it like classic and
simple
um but it's the full titles 20 years of
tomb raider digging up the past defining
the future
um and that was sort of a
a play on the fact that obviously
laura's job is always looking to the
past but in doing so she really
intimidated really defined the future of
gaming and and even to some degree
entertainment and and the role of female
leads in gaming and pop culture and so
on and so we yes yeah we're having lots
of reveals
today and we will continue to have
surprises for our fans every single
month so again it's it's the year tomb
raider so every single month we will
have something well happy birthday laura
happy birthday tomb raider and thank you
rich and megan for showing us the brand
new cover of the book thank you all
right thank you for having us oh you're
so welcome and thank you guys for
hanging out with us we have a lot more
coming up so don't go anywhere stick
around stay tuned to gamespot
you're watching the gamespot stage
brought to you by airheads
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the gamespot
stage at e3 2016. i'm your host mary and
i'm delighted to be joined by my co-host
peter brown
as well as hideki kamia creative
director at platinum games and
translator jp thank you so much for
being here
hi now the first translating yeah the
first thing we're going to uh get into
here would probably be the gameplay demo
that we that was revealed uh just a
couple days ago where we show we you
guys showed a huge boss fight as well as
multiplayer uh for the very first time
uh
multiplayer doubles to run the schedule
go ahead uh we were curious of uh what
went into the development process to
make the biggest boss fight that has
ever happened
yeah so um you know the first thing that
you do is you just decide to keep making
it bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger until it's cool so um
we started there and then we started
thinking about okay now how do we make
this enormous thing work in multiplayer
and how do you fight it together with
your friends so it was kind of a really
organic process of taking what we
already knew and just scaling it up to
be amazing
now you're playing as the lead character
drew and your dragon theban uh it sounds
like they have a really interesting
relationship could you talk a little bit
about the dynamic between those two
characters
yeah so the most important part of our
kind of gameplay mechanic is that up
until now in the action games that we've
made you've always been playing kind of
a human-sized character fighting against
enemies and you were the only one on
screen but now we've kind of picked drew
who is an everyman he's a guy from our
world and he's actually really weak and
we've paired him with a really powerful
ai creature and tuban the dragon and so
the gameplay mechanic doesn't become how
can i be a superhero every single moment
it becomes how do i work together with
this amazing creature to kind of cover
up where i'm weak but also accentuate
where i'm strong
uh jp last time i talked to you i know
you were writing primarily a platinum
game yeah still the case are you
responsible for sort of drew's character
and who he is actually i'm not writing
on this one um i'm producing the game
now so yeah yeah
thank you man but um we've actually had
a really really cool set of writers on
this so um kamiya has been kind of
laying out the uh the flesh and bones of
the story and then a lot of the polish
passes and work has gone in um we used a
guy for a little while named rich bryant
who was uh he's moved on to a really
cool project that i can't tell you about
a different company
oh no he doesn't actually work for us
this is one of the places where we
worked really deeply with microsoft um
rich was one of the writers on fable2
and fable3 so and uh after that um
you know rich steph decided to go take
this amazing offer and and god bless a
man dudes amazingly talented uh and
joseph staton from bungie okay um
who had worked obviously on destiny but
basically built the lore for halo
stepped in and also brought one of his
kind of most trusted guys uh clay
carmouche who uh did a lot of the
writing for um the taken king yeah so to
design producing and writing there's a
pretty strong pedigree yeah we've got
really really strong writers on this but
it's still you know at its core kamiya's
story so we're staying true to that
yes now uh going back to the characters
and their relationship uh it sounds like
now you've you've revealed multiplayer
um but do you guys still have a really
strong single player option for people
are you really kind of uh leaning more
towards multiplayer at this stage
yeah so um we definitely obviously
premiered co-op and we're really excited
about that but we realized that lots of
different people want to play games in
different ways and some people want to
invest a whole bunch of time in just
kind of playing something by themselves
and tinkering and tweaking and exploring
every corner of the world and sometimes
that's really hard to do in co-ops so we
support everything from playing by
yourself all the way through the
campaign to play in the entire campaign
with four or three other people as a
group of four
now um when you're playing you are
playing with uh other drews correct um
now because in in the story you are
meant to be this person who's
transported into a world you are the
only drew and this is your own this is
the last dragon um how do you come to
terms in the story of having four drews
and four dragons
called
so we wanted to make a co-op game from
the very start of this project we were
really excited about making a game that
you could play through cooperatively but
we also have this really kind of strong
personality and drew and a really strong
personality into bond and we wanted to
stay true to their story and tell that
story of their bond
a lot of times you could just say okay
there's four druze and there's 14 bonds
because it's co-op game it's video game
deal with it and be really lame so we
put a lot of effort and a lot of thought
into how we could make that
concept of a more story driven kind of
character-driven action game motif work
and co-op and so
it's something that we've tied into the
story and even though we're not talking
a lot about the story of the game right
now we wanted to give people a little
hint and so there is actually a hint in
the gameplay that we showed the other
day at the very end of that video you
see all four drews kind of go up and get
ready to kind of uh put the finishing
blow on the boss and all of a sudden
they collapse down into each other and
that's a hint as to how kind of
the narrative works for having multiple
druids and multiple bombs but still
being core to those characters
that's very interesting
cool i'm super curious about that
yeah and so
you know that's how we pulled off not
just having co-op is just being in this
mode that maybe you go into a boss fight
and then suddenly other people come and
help you out but being able to play
that story-driven campaign experience
but in co-op
uh i'm pretty curious about the
structure of the game overall is this uh
something that is perhaps more linear or
more open-world
maybe not wide open but you know
you know
what
we have a big debate always going on in
the studio about open world because open
world means so many things to so many
different people like it could be
sandbox games it can be you know
segmented over world games it could be
like super contiguous open world games
open world means so many different
things to people we try to avoid saying
it i'll clarify my question here am i
going level to level to level or is this
sort of an adventure that gives me a
little bit of room to deviate and
explore
i know
yeah so we want to have um a world
that's large that you can explore freely
and as you're kind of exploring and
fighting enemies you'll happen upon
dungeons and you'll go into those
dungeons and have like really tough
challenges there great and then come out
but you will be progressing along the
story but even once you finish that
story if you say you want to go back and
try that dungeon again we really want to
give people the opportunity to revisit
the world and to revisit the different
things that they've experienced in the
context of that opening open game did
you a lot of traveling uh via the dragon
is he sort of your vehicle in that
respect
congratulations
so
uh
obviously we're totally aware and we're
in the same way that we definitely want
to hop on a dragon and fly around and
move through the world like that's
absolutely something that you're going
to be able to do but it's not going to
be a given
um
we want you to kind of come to terms
with tubon and you know if you were
somebody who just got suddenly paired
with a dragon how do i relate to this
dragon how do i understand him how do we
even get along before you can hop on his
back and say hey take me down to the the
7-eleven or something right so i mean
there's some crazy stuff going on if
you're just transported to another world
you have to like uh how did i get here
there's dragons i mean i'm sure that's
going to be a process so once you kind
of come to terms and become close with
tubon and build that bond that's when
things like dragon riding open up and
more attacks and kind of how you combine
with each other opens up so we really
want that kind of learning progression
in the game
i'm interested you told me now you you
mentioned that drew was kind of like the
weak character he requires the dragon to
give him strength but he does have some
skills does he not looks like he has
like a scale arm that gave him a few a
few helpful things like some armor and a
few powers could you talk about that for
a little bit
more
yeah so you know we viewed drew as is
obviously much smaller and weaker than
tuban in combat and using working
together with taban is how you're going
to kind of overcome things so there'll
be instances where you'll be kind of
sending him forward and maybe
pulling back a little bit and supporting
him from longer distances or you know
finding a place to hide and setting up
traps like there's lots of different
things that you can do in that respect
but that would get really old really
quick if that was the only thing that
you could do so we gave him that dragon
form mechanic where you have a gauge and
if you press that button you become kind
of one with that dragon and get that
full set of skills and you are now the
superhero and so all of that stress and
fear that you've built up being kind of
small can be just totally expelled out
of your system by just going and
smacking the crap out of something
because you're in dragon form well it
sounds so exciting so it sounds like
that's pretty much all we have time for
today and i really appreciate both
hideki kamiya and jp talking to us about
scalebound and we do not have a solid
release date on this but i believe we
can expect to see it sometime in 2017
2017. yep all right well thank you guys
so much and thank you guys for watching
you're not gonna want to go anywhere we
have a lot more coming up so stay right
here on gamespot
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the game spot
stage here at e3 2016 and this is
brought to you by airheads i'm your host
mary i'm still going to be your next
your host for probably like another hour
and i am delighted to be joined by my
co-host and good buddy peter brown hello
and we also have psionics in the house
we have josh watson and jeremy dunham
hello thank you guys for being here
thanks for having us and i've said this
before but thank you again for making
the i think it's probably the second
game in the history of gamespot that
have made our managers
uh have required specified times that
we're allowed to play it in the office
awesome you're welcome yeah what was the
first time uh i believe it was the
original
i was it was counter-strike oh yeah good
choice yeah it has to be counter-strike
of course i was supposed to say
something else but it's totally
accountable now that we can contribute
to your counter productivity that's
right yeah if there's nothing else it
would it would be that um so i mean
obviously we're here because you guys
released something we've been freaking
out about it's neo tokyo the new this is
a there's a few things going on here not
only is it a new map uh well a new
environment for you guys to play in but
there's a couple of new cars all sorts
of stuff um this is all done in the vibe
of neo tokyo it looks rad it's neon uh
you guys even said uh there's a few
pieces we want to get into here but
there's even like new voice call outs
yes so uh new tokyo we were really
inspired by
a lot of our guys in in the studio
really inspired by blade runner and
japanese anime and that the whole 80s
vibe so we wanted to
capture the idea that you were in
1980s neotogio so we've done uh the
voice over for all the things that
happened in the game we've changed it to
actual japanese so the countdown and
whenever you score good congratulations
all sorts of stuff what do they yell
when you score
uh depends on multiple things so some of
them are like this nice shot but in
japanese a lot of times they say
congratulations and sometimes there's
just a sound reaction but it so really
depends it's a little bit uh a little
bit contextual in that regard but there
are quite a few phrases in there that's
so exciting now um along with that uh
you guys had uh you guys had us oh here
we're getting some gameplay now this is
actually live this is happening right
now we have people playing this in our
studio this is what neo tokyo looks like
we can already see you guys have raised
sides you've changed up the map a little
bit this is kind of reminiscent of the
previous maps you guys released earlier
when you guys were working with the
community um what have you guys changed
to this map uh visually as we're looking
at this actually looks familiar to a map
i've already seen yeah it was originally
in rocket labs and uh when we launched
rocket labs we always said that we
wanted to use that as sort of a testing
ground for new environments and new
arenas and if people really liked it or
took to them we would then fully art
them out and add some cool aspects to it
yeah this was the double decker map from
rocket labs and i remember uh most of
the community saying of all the maps uh
there was like the donut uh
that's what i called it i don't think
that's the actual one
utopia it's a straight up donut
this one was the one that changed up the
dynamic of the gameplay the most it made
it changed it in such wonderful ways and
it made people use aerials and height
and communication with team skills it's
all about uh having that extra set of
height and getting some real nice uh
aerials out of that and so good for for
team score so uh it sounds like you guys
had positive community feedback in this
is this going in the rotation this i
think has been confirmed on twitter so
that's that's one of the things that we
wanted to make sure is that this is not
just for exhibition play it's also for
ranked play it's going to be it's going
to be part of there it's going to be
ready to go on june 20th is when we
really release the patch so it's just a
few days from now
and it's
it's one of our favorite maps even
before we arted it out we just liked the
concept of it because it it still felt
familiar but it also added the new
strategy because of the the way that it
promotes aerials and driving on the
banks i know it was your favorite map
absolutely whatever it was my favorite
when we tested it it really does kind of
work with in tandem for co-op play this
is about working with your teammates to
have a ball set real high and then smash
down so absolutely it might be happening
right now
very good job caveman
um
um one thing we changed a little bit um
when we when we released underpass we
got a lot of feedback about the back
walls uh causing a little bit too much
height so we wanted to kind of normalize
them a little bit so we worked really
closely with the community feedback and
tried to you know we rounded out some of
the edges on the the levels here and and
flat in the back so it plays a little
bit more like the standard maps
and now you guys are also playing with
brand new cars you guys just announced
as well uh tell me a little bit about
them and i have to ask because it looks
like there's neon in them are these
customizable so they are customizable
yeah that's it's just like any of our
other cars that we we introducing gold
you can add flags you can add rocket
boost you can do whatever you want uh
this one that luke is using now is
masamune and uh it's one of the two new
tokyo themed cars that we have what's uh
what's interesting about this is that
it's going to be available to people who
buy the retail version of our game that
we have coming out first okay um just a
sort of a way to to say thank you and
welcome to the community but then we
will have it available worldwide uh
digitally for sale a few weeks later so
everyone can grab it is uh what's the
price options for these is this uh
standard from
1.99 per car and they'll come with uh
six different skins that you can use and
then they'll also have their own unique
set of wheels that you can use and you
can of course use those on any car that
you want that free
oh always free our maps will always be
free absolutely forever and how do you
guys feel about your current pricing
model and how how's the community been
reacting to it seems like you guys have
been adding so much content uh
consistently to try to keep people
coming back for more but then you're
also offering options for people to
personalize their cars a little bit it's
almost got like a tf vibe to it right
where you're like able to
customize yourself deck it out but it
doesn't impact gameplay no and that's
that's the key is we anything that we
charged for we didn't want it to be
something that made you feel like if you
didn't buy it that you couldn't compete
with anyone it's really more about just
feeling like you can express yourself in
the ways that you want to and that's our
whole philosophy that will always be our
philosophy and we think the community
likes it quite a bit because they've we
have really good numbers in terms of
people who are downloading it using the
cars and uh
the things that really matter to the
community as a whole the maps the modes
we don't charge for those we want
everyone to play them and that's that's
always going to be our strategy going
forward and
so far it's worked out pretty well yeah
absolutely when i think about expressing
myself in neo tokyo i'm reminded of my
akira tattoo
are there any of the cars that embody
sort of the uh facets of uh canada's
bike
uh well we definitely uh
yes we have there's another car that we
have in here called esper when this
game's over luke can uh switch to it oh
yeah uh and it's it's definitely
reminiscent of of something out of akira
for sure okay cool um
within within the rules of parody right
of course
yeah because you guys have multiple cars
you have these two but you're also uh
i've already announced two more cars uh
marauder and aftershock so you guys are
constantly pumping out new things here
yeah and those are call backs to our old
super sonic acrobatic rocket power
battle cars they were two of the the
vehicles that didn't make it in the
initial release that were from that game
and so we brought them over and um after
shock in particular was one that a lot
of our fans including some of our top
players like kenobi who's one of the
best players in the world we know
we're trying to get him on speed dial
for when we have the game spot
competition against you guys
he's he's in the building it's he might
be able to track him down actually
speaking of the the game spot i think
josh had something he wanted to mention
about competition yeah um the last time
we saw you uh you were supposed to bring
our challenge back to the team that's
right um we've been ready and waiting
for rematch
i think we have the new battleground now
that's right let's get the squad
together do it let's do it i actually um
i showed them yeah when i visited
psyonix uh
for the reveal of your guys's rocket
labs i got video of you guys calling out
the team and i showed it to the team who
is here by the way and i think we even
i think you can hear yeah we heard it
rob hanlery uh somewhere upset uh we
were thinking about even doing it here
at e3 but it sounds like the actual
people we competed against aren't all
here
so yeah oh you want like a true true
rematch of everybody you guys didn't
have the people available oh so oh it's
us okay it seems like maybe somebody got
scared right before
i don't know i'm sure they're watching
that i mean you guys should look at your
books and make sure that your best
players can make it to e3 for these
types of moments
we'll uh we'll make a few phone calls
yeah it's over we'll see what happens
they're right yeah they're right down in
san diego yeah we can quickly train bus
yeah we are super down for another
rematch these boys have been working
hard and i think they're ready for
another match also i've been coaching
them the coaching has been strong so
we're ready for another
this is uh this is the uh the esprit car
we mentioned though i think that that
has the akira vibe you're looking for
yeah there are a few elements of it that
i can tell are definitely like inspired
yeah it's not one to one but it's not
too far off yeah we wanted that we
wanted the feeling of neo tokyo we
didn't wanted to say this is totally
something you've seen before we wanted
to give it that rocket league vibe and
yeah um one thing that while we were
talking that uh you you may or may not
have seen is the new post game
celebrations we had that are also going
into this patch
where you can jump and you can spin you
could use your rocket and we also assign
titles um relevant to your performance
in the match so if you had the most
goals or the most first touches you know
playing overwatch
i was thinking how great it would be to
have a play of the game or something in
rock league is that something you guys
might be considering down the road where
you can sort of highlight those really
insane moments maybe like a sick save
because those are almost never really i
like being able to be seen later on
replays but but at the end of the match
to really just remind everyone like mvp
so there aren't any guarantees but it's
definitely not yet anyway but it's uh
definitely among the things we've talked
about that's something we do and a lot
of our updates going forward starting
with neo tokyo are really about quality
of life updates things the community
really wants to see things that they've
been wanting us to add so things along
those lines are definitely the sorts of
things that we're looking at yeah you
guys are constantly making updates uh
it's so cool to see the background of
this map i'm like
not distracted the point where i
wouldn't be able to play the game but as
a viewer who's not currently uh playing
it's so awesome to see all the bright
lights and the colors in the background
you guys did such a great job of kind of
capturing that vibe of tokyo and it
looks really good artists work really
really hard on it they spent i think
they probably spent more time on this
map than any of the other ones
um
i'm pretty sure about that they they
this was a labor of love for them it's
one that we've been wanting to do for a
really long time when you visited our
office to uh to see rocket labs for the
first time they had already started
working on it way back then so it's
something that they've been uh
waiting for a long time to get everyone
in front of everyone we're glad that we
finally get to do that
anything else peter
[Laughter]
you know rocket league was in our
discussions for game of the year and uh
last year and we ended up giving it uh
second place in the overall ranking
that's right and and it's the sort of
game that until you play it it's so hard
to really describe just how fascinating
the process of interacting with the ball
is and with other cars and just the
chaos that's there but how you can learn
how to control that chaos yes i think
this is a game that everyone should play
and as someone who really only picked it
up in the last maybe six months i
realized like man i've been missing this
like this is what i need out of a game
something that
i just you know i play and i'm like
alright one more match just just one
more match good then like two hours
later i'm like okay just
well there goes my birthday
it's the same sob story for everyone
here yeah
well that that's what we want though is
we want people to have fun even if
they're losing because we do know that
there it is a game that does involve
skill at the highest levels where people
can really pull off some crazy stuff but
we didn't even know it's possible until
they started doing it sure um but our
goal from the very beginning has always
been just to try to make the game as
intuitive and as fun as possible so it
didn't matter if you were a pro level
player or just starting you can just
drop in and play and understand it how
has the uh the reception been for the uh
the basketball mode
huge huge yeah yeah it's people love
that mode
much more than we thought we were a
little concerned in the beginning
because it is a little bit of an
advanced mode uh given that there's an
entire yeah there's there's even the
intro you actually have to aerial in
order to start that show like that that
mode which is really crazy it was so
funny because the ai didn't know to do
that
so if you didn't all the ai just smashed
into each other when we started
but it worked it worked out really well
for for everyone we people embraced it
and they realized there's a slightly
different skill set you need definitely
and so i i i think that it's like a lot
of the other things we've done it's gone
way beyond what we'd originally hoped so
we're just happy that we can keep
bringing it to people and we're working
on more modes by the way oh i'm sure you
are not talking about them yet but
they're coming soon a bag of secrets and
tricks somewhere um also anyone who has
seen the trailer was probably enamored
with the amazing music you guys do such
a great job with your music i know a lot
of it is done in-house which is even
more amazing because it's just another
he's the guy who wrapped over the hoops
trailer that's
just incredible you guys do that and it
sounds like for people who do enjoy
rocket league music you guys have uh
something else that you're going to be
showing for everyone else so we released
the official soundtrack last year that's
right
along with the release of the game but
now we're putting together a volume 2
that's going to be coming out uh very
very soon within the next few weeks um
and it's going to incorporate all the
music that we've released in the game
post uh our initial launch and then uh
some other things that we haven't shown
yet so that's so exciting pretty cool
yeah it's so good to have those tunes
just like whenever you want them and uh
man they're so catchy that sometimes you
just
just you just listen to rocket league
yeah just to get through the day
josh and jeremy thank you so much when
can people expect to see uh neo tokyo
and then the next two cars afterwards so
new tokyo the map will be available to
everyone worldwide on monday june 20th
for free for free no charge along with
all the other features they're getting
which is the post game celebrations
quick chat customizations uh brand new
rocket labs map all sorts of stuff
they're throwing in there and then the
anyone who buys the retail version of
rocket league which comes out june 24th
in europe and july 5th in north america
will have access to all the new cars
that we showed you everyone else will
then be able to get them for sale
digitally july 18th that's a lot of
dates to keep track of but that's all of
them
pause get your calendars out write it
down
that's right uh thank you so much jeremy
and thank you josh and thank you guys
for that live demo of neo tokyo it looks
rad if you guys aren't playing rocket
league yet i don't know what's wrong
with you
put it on the other screen keep game
spot right here we got a lot still
coming up and we will see you in just a
little bit see you soon
everyone loves a road trip right you
pack up the car set the destination and
drive across a bunch of eastern black
countries with your uncle and a bucket
of water and a car that seems to be
falling apart at the hinges part oregon
trail part mechanic simulator part
papers please this game called jalopy
really is something unique i've
certainly never played anything like it
and it's available right now on early
access for a mere twelve dollars but is
it worth all the travel are you better
off just staying at home let's find out
[Music]
jalopy is a game where you nurse a
four-wheeled banger across a number of
countries you stay in hotels buy parts
fill it with petrol and listen to your
uncle wax lyrical about the good old
days in the fall of socialism but it's
not about getting to your destination
fast it's about getting there in one
piece you see jalopy is a term of
endearment for a car that's let's say
past its best and yours is a leica 601
deluxe a car a car made of parts parts
that can break parts that need to be
repaired or replaced parts that need to
be taken care of for instance the leica
has a two-stroke engine meaning you've
got to make sure there's at least some
oil in there or it's going to run less
efficiently and get damaged more quickly
but it's not all about the mechanics
there's an element of surgeon simulator
in here too this car doesn't drive
itself if you want to pop the hood you
got to pull its lever you're not
required to change gears or indicate
with your blinkers but you can expect to
do everything else from turning on the
ignition to flicking on your lights and
wipers using the handbrake even rolling
down the window to hand border guards
your passport jalopy is charming as hell
and all these interactions lend spirit
to a game that doesn't say much but says
what it does rather well for instance
you can buy supplies and petrol at any
gas station you pass but the first time
i did i couldn't find my wallet to pay
the lady so i had to run back and search
the whole car of course it was in the
bloody glove compartment you've also got
a trunk full of gear to help you along
the way but it works like resident
evil's grid system meaning it has
limited space i mean it's probably nice
to have a bucket of water so you can
clean off all the mud on your windshield
but that takes up a lot of room this
inventory management puzzle is one area
where the game's early access rough
edges are most apparent but in a game
centered around trying to get something
that's broken to work properly i found
myself surprisingly forgiving of these
niggles though less so with some of the
behaviors of the ai drivers or when my
uncle decided to find a faster way to
the other side of the continent
saving and quitting doesn't actually
save your progress but it will reload
you back at the last hotel you checked
into which is just as well because even
in this early version the further you
get the more challenging the gameplay
becomes it all seems rosy on your trip
until you realize you forgot to pop some
oil in the engine and it's eating itself
alive it's a very good sign for a game
when even losing is fun and even when
you find yourself on the wrong side of a
bad decision staring at a broken bridge
miles from anywhere with no fuel in the
rain while the sun is setting you can't
help but laugh like a banged up car it's
challenging but jalopy has a wonderful
sense of charm it wears its inspiration
on its sleeves there are shades of 80
days surgeon sim papers please among
others but jalopy is perhaps above
anything else one of the most unique
games i've played this year if you're
interested jalopy is rough but ready to
play right now on steam for a very
reasonable twelve dollars
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the game spot
stage here at e3 2016. i am your host
mary and i am joined by my lovely
co-host peter brown hello again hello
it's so good to see you and we also have
masa and sho from bandai namco and we're
gonna be talking about uh dragon ball
xenoverse 2 today
awesome uh so uh the first thing we
should probably talk about is the world
um
you guys released a press release that
stated that the world is seven times
bigger than the first game can you talk
a little bit about how that's going to
impact the game
is
uh
right so actually this quantum city is
working as a hub and in the previous
title we actually had tokugawa city
which was more of a village-sized uh hub
and then now now quantum city is
actually working as a city and then now
we're able to actually implement more
new features thanks to the size of this
hub you'll be able to do more quests uh
maybe a number of missions and a lot of
new uh fun gameplay features that you'll
be able to experience with your friends
online so this size is definitely going
to work to our victim yeah i heard 300
simultaneous players it's able to
support is that true
please
all right so the actual number of
players that you'll actually be able to
see
on your screen may not be uh
exactly 300 but yes uh when you're
talking about the number of players that
can access yes we're looking at 300 and
thanks to these numbers you'll be able
to more uh co-op more interact more and
do a lot of more fun things with players
online so we hope you look forward to
that that's awesome and now in the start
of the game i heard that you won't be
able to fly immediately now you will be
able to in the matches because that's
such a core element of the competition
itself but it sounds like you actually
get hoverboards at the beginning uh
is that also accurate no nimbus clouds
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
maybe different vehicles um there's not
much we can say right now we hope you
look for forward to uh further
information but in terms of uh
being able to fly or not uh we're not
just um
on a we're not just uh preventing
players from flying just because we want
we don't want them to uh we just wanted
them to search through and look through
the city in order
and play through and then finally be
able to fly and go to places that you're
only able to go to because you can fly
so you just want players to go in order
maybe just like restricting them the
beginnings that then they can achieve to
get to new areas that's that's a cool
thing now i've also heard that there is
a training school uh that's been
announced does that mean or allude in
any way that there'll be a training mode
right so yes in terms of the training
mode yes we don't have a train but then
this is basically
thanks to the feedback from fans and not
only in terms of the training but we're
really trying trying to listen to the
comments and feedback from fans so
yes
that's fantastic i mean it seems like
you guys have been working in tandem
with uh with your fans throughout the
iteration of the first game making
adaptations for the second game another
thing a lot of people wanted was local
multiplayer split screen um have you
guys uh announced anything regarding
that
feedback
oh
foreign
all right we actually received a lot of
feedback from fans uh yes they were
there were fans saying that they want
split screen but there were also fans
who were saying that um the way we did
local versus mode was good as is because
you're able to look at the stage more
freely it's more larger if you split the
screen there's just small portions that
you can see it's such a wide open field
it's actually quite hard to see um but
in the first game you only had to think
one map for local multiplayer exactly so
there we we are increasing increasing
more stages okay great players will be
able to play in more uh multi uh a
number of stages okay um any idea of how
many uh maps so far or
imagine
all right so sorry we can't go into the
actual
numbers but uh we're actually really
recreating the stages so that it fits
all the local one versus one mode so
yeah um i'm sure that it'll be something
satisfying okay uh there's obviously the
new dragon ball anime series that's out
there dragon ball z super how has that
influenced some of the content in this
game if at all
[Music]
all right so to be completely honest um
the broadcasting of dragon ball super
actually began after we already uh
created the whole concept of the game so
um
uh we're not actually sure about how
many or maybe the content of uh dragon
ball super will be able to include in
the game but we are really hoping that
we can do something
related to dragon ball super so we so we
hope that you guys can look forward to
further information on that as well does
the uh one more question if that's cool
yeah like does the development team have
a strong history and affinity for this
series and uh if you do personally how
does it feel to work with such an icon
like a cultural icon of japanese
himself is a fan so he's really happy to
be able to be involved in the
development of dragon ball game but at
the same time he feels a really strong
responsibility to work up to the um
expectations and hopes for fans because
we know that there are so many fans of
dragon balls throughout the world so now
that he has the privilege to create a
game he would really like to work up to
those expectations lots of
responsibility that's a responsibility
um real quick is there a lot of people
love the transformations that happen
between the characters but um i think
there were only a few races that had
transformations um are there going to be
more transformations in uh universe 2.
you said
[Music]
all right so unfortunately there's not
much information that we can uh give out
right now but we do understand the hopes
from fans and we really understand and
we would like to
you know really accomplish this so
please just look forward to further
information oh we absolutely are looking
forward to it and we're looking forward
to more information about dragon ball
xenoverse 2 and now that is slated for
winter of 2016 correct correct all right
masa and show thank you so much for your
time and thank you guys for watching
that was dragon balls universe 2.
there's gonna be a lot more so if you
want to hear all the latest on that game
be sure to stay tuned to gamespot and
stick around because we still have more
coming up on our live show at e3 2016.
you're watching the gamespot stage
brought to you by airheads
oh
[__] tournament's most immediate joy
comes from something simple two pokemon
physically interacting this may seem
trivial to most but for long time fans
is the opportunity to finally scratch an
itch that's been out of reach for 20
years
in the rpg series battles have been very
static with back and forth wobbles
representing two pokemon attacking each
other
that changes with [__] tournament and
it's a delight to see nintendo's iconic
pokemon finally free to leap around and
trade blows up close
but what makes it better is that there's
a satisfying set of fighting game
mechanics underpinning it all these are
deep and technical but also retain the
accessibility and tactical spirit of the
rpg series
battles are split into two phases which
the game constantly shifts between the
field phase is focused on using ranged
attacks from a distance then at the
right moment using a homing attack to
deliver a powerful follow-up
the beauty of the field phase is that it
creates strategy in simplicity both
players have the same objectives and the
tools at the disposal to complete those
the focus is on firing and dodging
projectiles maneuvering into an
advantageous position and then
capitalizing it's thrilling in the same
way that thumb wrestling is two players
pecking at each other waiting for that
perfect moment to go for a pin in the
dual phase the game becomes like tekken
and street fighter fighting game
aficionados will understand the
mechanics at play here instinctively but
newcomers can quickly get comfortable
with the logic light attacks are quicker
than heavy ones but do far less damage
those blocking high are vulnerable to
sweeps and throws are a reliable way to
punish hurtling
[Music]
and then there's counter attacks which
let you hit back through an enemy's
assault
[__] is a game laced with smart ideas
and design feats but one of the most
important is that it offers depth
without overwhelming new players
the majority of special moves for
example can be executed with a single
button press with specific timing and
more button presses combos can become
complex but they always seem masterable
by beautifully striking that balance
parking is not just a successful
cross-pollination of two game series
it's an outright excellent entry point
into fighting games
on top of the core mechanics are
technicalities that give the game
replayability
for example picking the right pokemon to
battle requires some thought
do you want charizard who is slow and
powerful or weevile which is weak but
very fast
then there's unique attributes and
abilities for each pokemon that can
cater to different styles of play brexin
can increase her damage for a short
period but sceptile can leech health
from an enemy pikachu is great at
applying pressure but machamp can take a
beam
support characters are another of
pokken's gameplay wrinkles and a clever
way to draw from the series's turn-based
tactical routes
it allows players to select a pokemon to
lend a hand in battle
advantages these support pokemon provide
range from directly attacking the other
player to setting up traps and giving
stat
benefits synergy is another new ability
by filling a gauge players can trigger a
mega evolution for the pokemon that have
one or a powered up state for those that
don't in this mode moves are enhanced
and the pokemon also has access to a
synergy burst these are powerful
cinematic special attacks that without
understatement are stunning to behold
pokken tournaments presentation is
lovingly crafted with a slick broadcast
style for its battles and each of its 19
stages filled with eye candy and fan
service the pokemon themselves are just
as full of life if you want to explain
to someone why you find pokemon so
charming this is the game you should
reach for out of the box pukkin is a
fully featured fighting game packed with
gameplay modes customization features
and a comprehensive training suite the
meat of the single player is the ferum
league in which players fight through
five skill tears to be crowned ultimate
champion weave throughout this is the
story of a corrupted mewtwo
which is a nice touch that alleviates
the monotony of grinding through
qualifying matches it's a testament to
the quality of pokken tournament that i
just wish there were more characters
there's more than 600 pokemon now and
falcon tournament features just 16 of
those perhaps this is an unfair
criticism since this number is similar
to what most fighting game rosters
launch at but i simply need more i need
[__] lucha otherwise pokken tournament
is magnificent to look at delicately
designed and rewarding for players
across all skill levels it's the pokemon
fighting game we deserve after a 20-year
wait
finished
[Music]
this is my penultimate oh
welcome back to the game spot stage here
at e3 2016 and this is brought to you by
airheads i'm your host mary and i am
delighted to be joined by my good friend
peter brown also gamespot review editor
oh my oh my
so so
official and philippe from the red
barrels who delights in scaring children
everywhere you monster we like to do
and you do it quite well i was uh
uh
given the uh ability to play your demo
for outlast 2 at pax east
uh scared the [__] out of me uh it's
just absolutely terrifying demo and i'm
sure we'll show some gameplay of it
pretty soon but it's like
you guys create the most haunting
atmosphere and i think you guys uh have
learned a lot from the original outlast
that you're attributing to it we can
already see that you guys are bringing
back the camera with the battery you are
i never
you always it's always in the back your
mind but there's enough batteries
scattered around through the world but
it seems like you guys are carrying a
lot of elements from that original game
but what new elements are you guys
making for outlast too well we worked a
lot on the uh environments and the
settings so it feels like completely new
uh we like to uh have what i call you
know the what what the hell feeling what
the hell is going on and we want to make
sure that that feeling is renewed every
now and then so that it never feels like
it becomes familiar uh with the first
outlast when you get to when you got to
the dlc the asylum almost felt like a
familiar place and we want to make sure
we avoid that with uh outlast too
and now when you're saying you put a lot
of effort into the environments which
you guys absolutely did in the first one
we went to all sorts of terrible places
um and oh like you know kind of
culminates and just horrible
environments like i you know sometimes
you don't even know where you are and
this is uh true in the demo as well
where there were some times where i was
like
am i in a school um i'm in a hallway
there's lockers i'm not exactly sure
where i am but i'm in i know i'm uh
somewhere i don't want to be it looks
like now you're taking us to uh like the
desert in the middle of nowhere but
there are people there there's an
underground cavern what other
environments do you have in store for us
well the game starts in this village
that uh people have been living there
for 50 60 years maybe
we were influenced by the jonestown
incident in the 70s uh jim jones and
doing the kool-aid
thing and uh no there's going to be a
river section there's going to be a
place where people have syphilis which
when it's really extreme can look like
liberals
uh it's going to be underground stuff
please go on
[Laughter]
yeah it sounds like you have like all
sorts of like really horrible and like
speaking of jonestown i mean the people
of this town are clearly on the kool-aid
like they are drinking
they're nuts and they're trying to kill
you they got pitchforks i mean what's up
with the people the townspeople who are
super unfriendly they uh they are
convinced that the end of times are
coming and actually it's gonna take
place uh
as at some sunup
uh so you've got the one one night to
look for uh for your wife trying to find
her and uh they're convinced that uh she
uh she has something special that uh
you you're gonna figure out what what's
happening with her by the uh at the end
of the game and it's really we're trying
to mess with the player's mind so that
you uh your sense of what's real and
what's not uh becomes confused and
whenever you try you you think you
understand what's going on we're gonna
put a new twist at you uh to just uh
switch things up yeah i mean in the demo
already uh as soon as i felt like i was
comfortable in one environment i was
immediately transported into another uh
it seems like you guys are
allowing some creative flexibility
you're allowing licenses to all of a
sudden just be in a new environment
without too much explanation of why
do you know the original outlast was
quite uh successful it was uh both to
critical and fan acclaim uh which is
fantastic do you guys think that that
gave you more creative freedom more
liberty to to be a bit more experimental
with this one well definitely we
allowed us to take more time in the
first game we had to finish it before
running out of money
[Music]
this time we could try uh try some
things make some experiments and we
we just want to mess with the player's
mind and
make something that we didn't want it to
feel like just a longer dlc so
we experimented we did some play tests
about a year ago found out what worked
what didn't and now looking at the
results of the demo it seems that we
found the the right amount of
uh elements that we can mix together
without uh going too far away from the
the brand outlast
and
as you mentioned that you basically had
the constraint of time and time is money
maybe because you have a little bit more
you are able to really make sure you
fine-tune everything before you've
uh i don't know but really polish it up
basically before you bring this up
yeah we're a fully independent studio
and we sold about uh four million units
of of the first outlast so uh yeah i
mean we're the way i see it is that the
first one was like a solid double and uh
this one we want to knock it knock it
out of the park fantastic
now um going back to the original you
guys uh recently released a comic that
kind of bridged uh some of the gap
between the first and the second outlast
uh kind of hinting that i mean are there
going to be any characters that we might
see from the first one is there any like
kind of blending that we should expect
for fans of the original you're going to
see them in the comic books but the the
game itself it's uh it's mostly new
characters and i mean even the guy in
the demo i don't think
does too well
i don't even think i'm going to see him
in the game
oh this is such a great part and i think
this is where we start going into the
underground caverns so we've kind of
seen like the outdoor environment the uh
the village uh
but now now we're getting into like this
underground area and when you look down
this part is absolutely
right that's when you understand that
these people they're
not there for camping yeah
and the player has some really good
audio feedback during these uh cues if
you guys watch the games uh the gameplay
that we have on gamespot you'll hear the
player starts breathing really heavily
when he sees things that upset him which
is often but it's a really nice reminder
that something is so alarming that even
the character can't contain it yeah and
then this time we added the more uh
dialogue for the the main character and
the first one he wasn't talking this one
he will be but it's mostly for us a
narrative tool to just give more
information to the player
uh one thing i'm really curious about is
how uh maybe you're considering vr
support if you are is that a thing
yeah a lot of people
ask us about vr i mean it's definitely
something we have the dev kits at the
office yeah so we always uh
thinking about it but we're a small team
we're 18 people so we got to focus on
one thing at a time we'll get this one
out of the door and then we'll see uh
what we decide to do after that but uh
yeah i mean obviously would be really
interesting to exploit vr with the uh in
the world of outlast of course mobility
is sort of an issue when you're you know
using a first person game yeah with a
joystick that does create some
disconnect absolutely yeah yeah there
are some things that we're doing that
are not very vr friendly of course so uh
what would be best is just to
get build something from the ground up
for vr and not just support or adapt
whatever we already have
how why do you think horror is so
popular in general because it's one of
those things that it turns off a lot of
people it also gets a lot of people very
excited like why is it that you think
that people love to be frightened i
think it's for some people just being
scared makes you feel alive
it's those like natural instincts like
we're never running from predators
anymore
all the time
jack rabbit peter always trying to save
himself i mean like i never really do
get genuinely scared in my day to day my
biggest fear would be like
i don't know money and
just making it day to day but uh yeah
the idea of like you know why i love
horror so much going to a scary movie or
playing any scary games to get that
intrinsic fear that rush the um when you
can feel your heartbeat and yeah those
are emotions that you don't just like
you said you don't feel in your normal
daylights most of the most of the time
and uh so it's fun i mean that's why i
think you you go to movies or you read
books or
to get these emotions that you're unable
to get otherwise art media makes you
feel things
[Laughter]
so what about you when you're playing
your own game do you still get a little
bit nervous at times or is it are you
still aware of how it's working
that's probably the biggest challenge
that you're so into it it's really hard
to pull back and figure out if it's
working or not so i mean at first you
trust your instinct and then you get
feedback from the team and after that
it's play test and
reiterate and redo it i mean you don't
do a game you redo it basically it's
right the first time you you do
something it's never
as good as you hope you would be so it's
just uh you just have to stick to it and
work hard you just get a bunch of play
testers and put them in a room with a
mic and the louder the screams the most
successful you guys feel your game is
i think this
this gameplay clip right here in the
corn fields is so indicative of what
kind of uh different types of atmosphere
you guys are creating here so there are
people in this corn field that are
searching for you uh you got to stay out
of their lights you're hiding i mean
it's a really terrifying moment and as
you can see on the left you can see left
and right audio which is really
interesting because now i'm starting to
use like dynamic audio cues to see if i
can hide from people if they're coming
from the left or the right it seems like
there's going to be more opportunity for
that where you're in even with the light
even when you're using the camera your
view will be obstructed and you have to
find new ways to
filter through the environment and get
to the next area i actually got killed
in this cornfield scene and it was it
was really cool the audio cues ended up
helping me realize what i could and
could not do i ended up hiding in a
barrel and using the audio queues to
realize when i could leave so i think
that's really interesting there's uh and
i think it's really cool that you guys
are inventing that kind of that kind of
these new these new gameplay mechanics
uh for the demo i know the barrel is
really interesting because uh
there are some barrels with water in
them
so it you can't your some of your senses
get distorted
uh but like you said you can use sound a
lot to uh figure out if the threat is
close or
or or gone and it's really in this part
what we were after is trying to make you
feel like the old village is after you
our last one was mostly about one guy
chasing you down the corridor yeah that
guy sucked though this is really bad
and so we're still gonna have that but
we wanna also to mix it up and have
sections that are more open with several
enemies chasing you at the same time
even though there seems to be a village
you um of many people will there be an
overarching villain or one key person
that we will be fearing the most yeah i
think well after the first half last one
we did our force modem having uh uh
main enemies that are very typical um
stereotypical uh are um uh is part of
the brand and so yes there are gonna be
some characters that uh you're to meet
more than once and actually the one you
see at the uh
yeah i remember her yeah
you're going to see her often
she's convinced that the god
has told her to take care of you
some of them almost didn't seem well
they just seemed a little otherworldly
in a sense i mean that girl sure you
could say she's just a kid but she
almost looked demon-esque you guys
obviously are getting a lot of
inspirations from probably other horror
classics things that inspire you like to
grudge or poltergeist what types of uh
things have you guys been inspired by
for outlast uh there's the shining
there's a jacob's ladder
also a more recent movie take shelter
uh we liked a lot i mean basically we
take stuff
we like from very very varied places and
we try to merge them all into something
that feels fresh fresh and unique
but figuring out the school part
figuring out how that ties in with
everything else is part of the
experience uh you're gonna get some
answers at some point and
uh maybe those answers will change also
based on your own perception and
philosophies uh that's really what we're
trying to achieve something that when
you're
you finish it people have different
interpretations and argue about it
even among the team there are different
interpretations of what goes on in the
game so i'm really curious to see how
people react to it
um now in terms of
length of play uh the original how would
you say this compares the original one
in in terms of like clocked hours it
should be a solid 25 30 longer than the
first game so hopefully uh closer to 10
hours
uh then the first one was between five
and seven i think this won't be closer
to ten
great and and that does
you know i remember actually replaying
the first one just kind of get a better
feel for it um i think what's cool about
your game is even though a lot of these
types of games you might not want to
play again because you've seen it like
the jump scares and stuff but because
most of your fear is atmospheric um you
can actually play it again and still get
a really nice vibe for what's going on
yeah i'm always amazed of reading
comments from players who've played it
several times and also we have a
on the first game we had a insane level
of difficulty which you couldn't die if
you die you have to restart at the
beginning and i'm always amazed to hear
players who who've done it because i
haven't
i mean imagine dying right before like
the sixth hour and just being like well
i'll try again tomorrow it'd be really
cool if like when you died it was like
well that's that's the only chance you
had to play the game yeah the game
you're dead
last life exactly
she comes in and kills you in real life
um so
is this this coming to consoles as well
as pc is that correct yep ps4 xbox and
pc at the same time
uh you know the first one we had to ship
them one at a time because we had to put
the pipeline in place but now we've got
the pipeline and so we're able to ship
them all at the same time physical
copies
still in negotiations
[Laughter]
yeah it'd be cool to see other abilities
to get your game because your game is
something that's now quite close to
people they're really interested in
seeing what else they can have and they
want items to go along with it they want
collector's editions or something to
give them physical elements to remember
them to remember this game by yeah and
then and we're uh we're gonna
put up a store i don't know exactly when
but that's part of our plan to have some
figurines and stuff uh it's a yeah we we
it's just the fact you know we're such a
small team we always have to bring back
our focus to production because
otherwise it's easy to get carried away
and
deal with other stuff and just
uh
you know we i remember when we left our
jobs uh we were working in big studios
and uh mostly doing meetings and stuff
like that and we really wanted to go
back to be hands-on and work on the game
so it's kind of ironic right now that uh
you know now that we've done it and
we've got our company uh we are able to
work on the game but at the same time
there are just so many things to take
care of and deal with uh so it's yeah
it's a it's a lot of work but that's
really satisfying at the same time yeah
i feel like it's a huge part of your job
to remind us that you're a small team
all the time
so that people don't get overwhelmed
with their expectations
because we want it all right and like
that's just natural especially with
seeing the first game and having so much
quality with such a small team in such a
small time frame i mean now with all
these uh resources i think people have
uh much higher expectations does that uh
is that something that like motivates
you guys are you uh looking forward to
reactions of the public yeah i mean it's
i guess it depends on the days you know
some days it's daunting but most of the
time it's just a motivation factor uh
sorry uh motivation uh element and uh
uh
you know it's it's it's it's always it's
uh it's flattering when when you read
people that they think it's a it's a big
blown triple a game uh we really have
talented people on the team and uh you
know we uh we just work hard and we are
passionate about what we do and i think
that's what makes a difference at the
end of the day
yeah it's one of the great things about
indie games right you can really tell
the people who had their hands on it
yeah really care because there's so many
small touches that made me get lost in
the noise
production so yeah i think it's the the
big key is to
work on something you would like to play
yourself and that makes a a huge
difference if you if you're satisfied
about what you're making then it's going
to make the the whole difference in
terms of the quality 100 yeah cool uh it
was a pretty good sneak peek what we got
so far we've gotten uh basically a 15
minute demo a lot of people can play and
then uh some gameplay clips out of that
will there be any other things that you
guys will be showing in the upcoming
months for people to look forward to
before you guys release yeah i mean
there's going to be the comic book uh
probably tons of screenshots and
definitely uh a new demo by the end of a
summer probably either pax prime or come
gamescom gamescom nice new gamescom demo
and this was like a pretty good chunk
like a 15 minute demo
really gives you the vibe of the
atmosphere the story so like we kind of
know we are a dude looking for his wife
there's a i think it all begins like a
helicopter crash before that even
there's like some preliminary story that
helps uh explain why we're here and what
we're doing in this world so it'd be
nice to even
get more snippets of that story when we
can yeah it's always a challenge to
you know try to find something that
makes sense as a demo but doesn't give
away too much
uh of the whole game uh but uh yeah i
mean i think it's part of the
i guess as artists you know you want
always the
uh people to play it without you know as
a clean slate you know not knowing
anything but that's that's not reality
you know you have to explain what you're
working on and have people
know a bit about the game before they
buy it
but yes i honestly have no idea what the
next demo will be uh
it's probably going to be somewhere in
the middle of a middle of the game but
uh
yeah i mean i'm really eager to see our
people actually we're going to be
showing some really edgy stuff in this
one we pushed it a bit in the
whistleblower but this time we're going
further and uh
i wouldn't say i'm worried but uh yeah
i'm i'm curious to see how people are
going to react to those things i mean if
it's anything like your demo you're
already pushing the bar in terms of oh
that's nothing
yeah well uh my penis got cut off
i felt like i was pushed
it happened in the demo
show me this demo it's a really cool
there's a lot of gameplay that's coming
up now from everybody playing it here at
e3 and it's really intense to see so i'm
looking forward to seeing more snippets
of it you guys do not have a release
date yet though correct no i mean i'm
pretty sure the game confident the game
will get done this fall but uh we'll see
if it comes out just before the holidays
are right after
okay so uh that was outlast two and
that's on pc ps4 and xbox one sometime
in the fall uh but that's all we know so
far so we'll have to wait to see more
all right well thank you so much philip
for joining us thanks for having me yeah
and thank you guys for watching this is
the gamespot stage here at e3 and we
actually have a lot more coming up for
you but not me sadly this is the end of
my hosting here uh but it's been awesome
hanging out with you guys and please
stick around we still have several more
live shows lots of cool interviews some
exclusive game
gameplay clips almost got through it and
you guys aren't going to want to miss
anything so please stay tuned and i will
see you guys again later
[Music]
few games use live-action cut scenes as
emphatically as quantum break and for
all intents and purposes it's one of the
game's defining elements between each of
its five gameplay based chapters you
have the opportunity to watch roughly 20
minute long episodes which are entirely
optional but designed to offer a wealth
of insight into the antagonist's state
of mind otherwise quantum break focuses
on jack joyce the time bending lead
character played by sean ashmore better
known as iceman from the x-men films
ashmore is one of a few well-known
actors featured in quantum break and
each member's professional acting chops
are put to good use of course quantum
break is intended to be played rather
than merely watched but even if you skip
its optional episodes the best aspects
of its gameplay are suppressed by
frequent bouts of mundanity
combat is the unequivocal star of the
show here driven by time-based super
powers at your disposal at the start of
the game you're imbued with the ability
to manipulate time which allows you to
slow down combat speed up jack's
movement create shields that freeze
bullets upon impact or cast time blast
bombs near unsuspecting enemies
and it doesn't take long to develop a
flow to understand how to link one
ability to the next by managing each
move's cooldown timer you can thrust
yourself into danger to establish line
of sight on an enemy and protect
yourself with a shield while you open
fire when your defense has run out you
can quickly zip into cover and cast a
time blast or continue to use your
firearms while your abilities refresh
there's no one right way to fight and
there's great enjoyment to be found in
experimenting with your abilities not to
mention witnessing the environment react
to your powers as the scene shifts
cracks and glitches out around you
quantum break is a great looking game
with some truly impressive character
models that bring its actors to life and
the time-based special effects are a
constant source of amazement there's
also an incredible amount of real-time
destruction on display which not only
looks great but also keeps you moving
during combat as enemies regularly
destroy your hiding spots quantum break
shooting mechanics however are slightly
less impressive there are times when
your enemies introduce devices that
disrupt your superhuman abilities and
you have no choice but to resort to your
firearms now it would be unfair to
compare simple shooting to manipulating
time but it is reasonable to hold
quantum break to modern third-person
shooting standards you spend a lot of
time in cover during combat and while
it's possible to blind fire your time
blast ability you can't use your guns
with the same amount of freedom you
don't have the option to shoot while
crouched you have to stand up and expose
yourself to other enemies and usually
take damage unless you have enough
energy to cast a time shield around
yourself of course this is an option
that shouldn't be needed when you
already have suitable cover both aiming
and movement feel loose and cumbersome
making the aimus feature the only
reliable way to consistently pick off
enemies when you're not engaged in
combat you're probably exploring
environments for clues and story tidbits
or traversing obstacles during
ill-conceived platforming challenges
again movement is so loose in quantum
break and the combat's so exciting that
it's frustrating when you're forced to
slow down awkwardly scale objects and
leap around sadly quantum breaks
gameplay is essentially divided equally
between combat and hapless environmental
traversal given that the entire campaign
can be completed in less than 10 hours
live action episodes included the
distribution of activities feels that
much more disappointing
prior to the tv show like episodes you
get to make decisions for your nemesis
paul serene which have an impact on some
events in the show and in the game the
effect of most decisions are noticeable
but not truly consequential in part
because the game's cliched potentially
story spoiling opening dulls your sense
of wonder from the get-go far worse
however is the end result quantum break
only has one ending realizing this your
choices ultimately feel trivial and not
worth reconsidering you're encouraged to
replay the game but by the time you
reach the credits it's unlikely you'll
feel motivated to do so so by the end
you know the most important parts of the
story and you understand that replaying
it to witness alternative events in the
middle would require you to retread
well-worn sometimes boring territory
getting to the end of quantum break can
be an interesting ride at times but no
matter how impressive the combat is no
matter how great the game looks there's
no getting around the fact that it's
driven by a story with limited appeal
and hindered by disappointing design
decisions
[Music]
so
welcome to gamespot's coverage of the
electronic triple 2016 how are you doing
welcome to the game spot stage brought
to you by airheads i'm danny dwyer
joined by mr michael mccarty in his
astounding chin
chin wags yes
you are the chinese of them all uh and
graham growing from telltale games thank
you so much for coming on to talk to us
about star wars the force awakens it's
it's absolutely my pleasure to be here
actually okay can we get this because i
used to work in in gamestop right and i
used to love the names of these games
because they were like the longest ones
to get into the computer so was it lego
star wars the force awakens the video
game uh i don't know if we are the video
game lego stars the force awakens people
know what lego star wars is yeah yeah
absolutely everyone's trying to make
star wars games now you've got vince
sampela trying to make us
all you know all these ex-assassins
creed and uncharted people doing but you
guys are og you've been doing this for
yeah yeah i like that uh over 11 years
now right so so yeah we have we have a
history there with you know lucasarts
which is ace because it means that they
we can we we get to tell new stories as
well as tell the story of the movie
which is right which is awesome and
that's your role right a telltale yeah
yeah i uh with traveller's towers i
should point out we always get told oh
god i did do it no it's fine it's fine
because there are still
there are still things that we are
credited on moby games as being tails
they still haven't fixed it but yeah
yeah so i i write the dialogue basically
i write daft jokes for kids which is
which is what i can do because i'm an
idiot so it's i'm perfectly suited to do
that and how long have you been doing it
at travelers tales um i've been doing it
oh gosh about seven years legacy
undercover was my first one oh wonderful
yeah good stuff uh we've actually got
the game running right here yeah yeah
jamie's off screen playing yeah jamie
eden who is my boss far more photogenic
than me but a very modest man so he
didn't want to appear on stage but he's
uh he's playing through here at the
moment and uh this is one of our new
adventure levels which kind of feeds
into the start of the movie uh and in
this one uh you're playing poe dameron
and you are rescuing admiral akbar from
the finalizer okay uh and uh yeah so if
you want to start running around and
this shows off quite uh this level kind
of shows up all our new features we have
these things called multi builds whereby
like in previous lego games you had the
same pile of bricks and you'd always
build the same thing with it yeah but
now you can use a pile of bricks to
build multiple different options and
sometimes it's just for like a silly
little joke uh in this case you've got
two different ways of getting rid of a
diane ogre but in other ones that you'll
have like little puzzles um so it's it's
nice it means that when you replay the
level you're always seeing something new
which is cool um so yeah we really try
to push things forward with this game
yeah i mean i guess that's the sort of
double-edged sword of being as
successful as you guys are is that like
there are we have played lots of star
lego x games in fact at this stage we
played a lot of lego star wars games
yeah so yeah you need to sort of i guess
retain what made those games so
successful while also trying to add some
little flares here and there yeah i
always increase the amount of characters
you can unlock so it's like 200 plus
this time is it really yeah yeah plus
this but this is the first stars game
where we've actually got dialogue um
right because the the previous one
didn't have that and so this one and
we've also had the cast come back and
record new lines first that's right as
in like harrisonville came back and was
han solo for us did you get to write
dialogue yeah i've written dialogue for
han solo in fact greg grunberg who
played snap wexley even came by the
stand and played with himself if you're
part of the phrase um on their uh forest
which was uh which was awesome as well
but yeah yeah like everyone came back
it's yeah it's amazing that's wonderful
uh mike you played a bunch of the star
wars lego star wars games yeah you have
the uh what was the original saga when
they released it was all six yeah yeah
yeah i played that a lot i mean i played
a lot of trailer sales i think marvel is
my favorite one right but i'm excited
for this just because i haven't really
played any force awakens in video game
form yet right that's actually a good
point it's been a long time this is the
first one right well i mean there's a
little bit of it i think in a rival
product
uh but yeah i mean we're the only ones
who are telling like the full story yeah
and then these extra stories as well so
it's kind of you get your full fix with
that except in dark lego form so it's
it's you know it's like it's the best of
both worlds yeah yeah how close are you
sticking to the story i mean it's
usually pretty true to the story but are
you adding in anything uh well we got
the the new adventure levels i mean in
terms of like telling the story the
movie we we stay pretty close obviously
we have to
take certain uh license like there's a
family reunion in the movie which
doesn't go that well right and obviously
that's quite a dark moment but we have
to adapt that so that kids are terrified
out of their skins yes um so we you know
we have a bit of fun with that um but
yeah let's say we have these new
adventure levels which are all sort of
leading up to the start of the movie and
we came up with those uh in conjunction
with lucasarts so yeah how did that
process go because you're basically
filling in canon was it canon i would i
don't i'm not sure if it's kind of i
hear one thing i heard another i the way
i see it is if you've seen the movie
there aren't tiny little lego dudes in
it so i don't know how it could be
good point right i mean apart from some
of the droids um but uh but you know we
totally came up with with them i mean it
was kind of you know we're saying what
happened here or they tell us oh here's
a story event that you can you can fill
in and then we'd sort of bash back and
forth uh design document and then i'd
come along and write a load of idiotic
jokes about it yeah um so yeah it was it
was totally you know in concert with
them wonderful stuff i'm guessing as
this is a lego star wars game that a
large uh sort of focus has been put on
playing cooperatively with people as
well uh oh yeah yeah multiplayer all
that sort of stuff oh yeah yeah so you
you know you've got um two player you
know uh local multiplayer and there's
also things like uh because it's a star
wars game we've got these blaster
battles in it which we've never done
before where you totally have those you
know you know the gun fights with the
lasers and the pew pew pew down the
corridor we totally have that in there
you hunker into cover and you take shots
and you lean out and stuff and we also
like our flight gameplay is way better
like our dog fights in space which we
have later in this demo are so much
better than we've done before we've
really just like upped the ante on
everything
so let's actually focus on the demo
because this is what everyone's looking
at at the moment by the way if you have
any questions at all in the chat uh let
me know either in the gamespot chat or
on the twitch shot i'm keeping an eye on
both of them uh yeah so what's what's
going on here there's a i love the the
water effects in this it looks like i'm
getting my toys dirty every time
he walks into that sludge well you know
as it starts we've ended up in a trash
compactor um and so uh after a couple of
failed attempts we're actually we're
trying to make our way up to this this
exit this at the the back of the room
here uh with the help of all of our
characters and in this case we've
actually built another one of these
multibills i mentioned um in this case
we need to get c3po up to a little
control at the back so
we're using these uh these pile of lego
bricks to to build uh
a lift here to get him up and then we
can smash those those bricks apart and
use the same ones to build another part
right the puzzle
and we have a bunch of those in the game
and uh and you know if you get it wrong
then the characters will kind of talk to
you and go oh no maybe i need to build
this first so it kind of directs you
towards uh the right solution and then
once we get c30po uh up there uh he'll
do like a little mini game and uh we'll
get into our space flight
uh some of the folks in the chat are
asking which version this is this is the
playstation 4 yeah this is ps4 this is
running on actually this is maybe one of
the most fun things i love doing here
especially when when your games comes on
what platforms is this game coming out
you know everything like toaster ovens
um
it's you know it's everything yeah it's
ps4 it's extras one it's xbox 360. it's
ps3 it's it's wii u it's pc it's 3ds and
it's psv wow that's wonderful it's no
psp version this time right uh no i
think we have dropped support for that
i'd have to check to be perfectly honest
but i'm fairly sure we have good stuff
um
actually does the vita version have like
the voice acting in it and everything
yeah yeah absolutely yeah yeah it's
that's it we try and we try and get as
much into all of our versions as we can
yeah because you know it costs a bit to
hire those actors so right you don't
want to not put them in every single
version travelers has always been great
at actually like
like releasing on those consoles and
some of which like i am a ps vita owner
and
there's some good games that come out i
played severed last week but yeah often
sort of underserved markets yeah yeah
but you know a load of people love
playing we've always had it's always
lovely getting letters from the fans and
loads of them they do play them on those
those platforms those are the only ones
they actually played them on so yeah we
we like to
absolutely serve those people so what's
kicking off here so yeah we've managed
to escape from the finalizer but we're
gonna have a bunch of tie fighters after
us so we're gonna try and lose them in
an asteroid field because and you know
it won't be an asteroid field without
someone telling us about the odds of
death in an asteroid
akbar in a jedi starfighter uh yes yes i
believe it is
uh we've also got like a bunch of like
creatures from the extended universe and
things like that um which is cool but so
we have these like these on rail
segments um which are just these you
know like candy filled rushes of
explosions and stuff like that but then
we also have these bits where it opens
up and you have like complete control
over your your ship and you can like
barrel roll and do loop the loops if you
get an enemy on your tail is it a real
barrel roll or is it what we call a
barrel it's not really a barrier okay
well you're gonna have to tell me what
the difference is doing that thing yeah
you got a barrel roll
what is that that one oh okay right it's
not a barrel roll then what is that
thing i don't know that thing it's got a
weightless like a corkscrew yeah yeah
more boring names basically a spinny be
sick in the cockpit
yeah that's what it is well we have we
have you know spinning stick in the
cockpit as a feature in our game
um so yeah we're flying into this uh
this asteroid uh which is uh full of
other these creatures that we're gonna
use to basically mask our escape from in
the first order here it's like a starfox
game right here that's right you know
here's the thing i
i've had an absolute blast playing like
the uh these the shooter sections of the
game i think
i've been doing lego stuff that'd be
totally awesome because i think i think
it's really really good it feels really
great i'm always slightly surprised i
shouldn't be surprised that you know i
work with competent people but but it is
like really good i mean
it's really wonderful how well it works
out and even like the bits where you
know you have full control
they're really cool
um i've got a bunch of questions coming
in okay cool
uh ben leslie five asking is the ps vita
3ds versions different uh gameplay wise
to the console version um a little bit
different yeah in terms of uh the amount
that's in there um like i say i mean it
tells the whole movie but i think
there's there's slightly fewer in the
way of the new adventure levels that
feed into it right but you know in terms
of the actual the level designs they're
pretty much identical
um also folks asking how sort of uh are
there like open worldy type sections
yeah yeah we have we have these hub
levels as you play through the story
you'll normally you'll play through a
hub and uh and then you can revisit the
hub so like you've got the car
resistance base you've got the inside of
the millennium falcon the starkiller
jakku and takadana castle that you can
then explore there's loads of little
silly side missions in there that you
can unlock and then they give you the
gold bricks that allow you to unlock the
uh the new adventure levels right okay
so that's how you get it accessed yeah
yeah so they unlock but then you have to
pay a bunch of gold bricks to actually
play them so
awesome you get to pick and choose which
one you want to do next yeah yeah
so what's what's going on here this is
so hard
uh here we're going to knock out a bunch
of the the tie fighters around and then
uh these special forces tie fighters are
going to appear and they've got these uh
torpedoes behind them and we can use
those to destroy these blockages or you
can see the little crystal there's the
these blockages with purple crystals in
them and uh that's going to release a
bunch of uh aliens into the playfield
and the idea is we're trying to create
enough chaos that we can escape in that
chaos so what jamie's going to do is
hopefully shoot some of these tie
fighters and then snaffle the sweet
sweet torpedoes that they drop
and then you can use those to blow open
these things and you see like the pink
carrots are basically pointing towards
these targets even this looks a little
more open than uh you know like that
last section was rail oh yeah yeah and
this kind of reflects those hub worlds
and the power yeah and we
have a whole bunch of these like there's
one where you're escaping the finalizer
early on and you can you can like fly
between the decks of the fine light and
stuff like that it's like we built this
really big model of it and just shoot
all the gun turrets on it and create all
this mayhem um yeah they're they're
they're
really good
i can't overstate it they're really
great these sections there was uh one of
the wonderful things about this series
has always been that you're able to play
as like so many different characters the
main ones either
so in the force awakens obviously there
are you know a host of characters people
really love there's a host of like sort
of sideline characters as well how many
of these can you is there anyone you
missed like um do you know i mean if i
say no then someone will go well there
was there was a muppet left of camera at
one point that we did but yeah like i
said it's 200 plus and i mean that's not
just from this movie there's some from
you know the previous movies and like
clone wars and stuff like that
um but yeah i mean we even have some
sort of adventures with them like um
there's this character the crimson
corsair who's in one scene it's the guy
who finn is gonna leave with and we have
an adventure where he basically steals
the ship that you use at the start of
this mission in order to infiltrate the
finalizer um so yeah we're trying to
really serve that and you know you can
go and unlock them and play them and mix
and match the parts of them but yeah
basically if they were on screen for
about five seconds in the movie then
chances are we built a lego version of
them mikey can you think of any people
you could ask graham i'm thinking of uh
the
shop simon peggs character the the
shopkeeper oh yeah yeah uncle plutt and
yeah yeah and he's being voiced by simon
pegg so really you got to fight for
simon yeah yeah you've got daniel craig
stormtrooper
uh we do have him yeah we do have them
we have a level where you're controlling
him and ray basically escaping oh yeah
yeah yeah that's good
yeah he's the one that she does the
first mind trick on
no yeah oh that's brilliant yeah he's
not voicing him
i feel like you're saying rumors get out
of hand you probably you could probably
just say yeah we have him and i would
see a stormtrooper hear the voice be
like i guess that's different in that
case yes he did come back
sweet you heard it here
oh that's excellent that's it that's the
demo done so yeah we're just going to
talk awkwardly over this screen now
that's great
uh
you're out like real soon oh yeah june
28th thanks for that by the way usually
at e3 it's like great thanks for coming
on and see your game at e3 next year
yeah but when we'll announce the day 20
exactly uh but yeah you guys are out in
a fortnight or so right yeah yeah june
28th on everything yeah so presumably
it's finished uh i hope so i'll have to
phone the office and check
awesome do you guys do any dlc at all
with this stuff yeah yeah we got these
uh these really cool um uh extra uh
adventure levels that kind of sort of
span off from the main narrative like uh
we've got one where there's a couple of
pilots who basically crash and startler
and they have to get across the
starkiller to escape the planet before
it explodes and yeah a bunch of others
um it's really cool stuff good stuff all
right graham before we send you on your
way what is uh when is it out on my
platforms i literally i don't even ask
to see the enemies then was i just june
28th on everything uh you know xbox 360
uh xbox one ps3 ps4 wii u pc 3ds and ps
vita awesome green from travelers tails
thank you so much for coming on thank
you for inviting me and thank you very
much to jamie for putting on a wonderful
display in the behind that really well
that's great
all right we'll uh we'll be back in a
couple of minutes folks we've got hitman
episode 4 coming on next we're going to
talk about cer park the fractured
butthole
david cage is coming on to talk about uh
detroit become human
apparently the wild hunt is going to be
on stage while we play some gwent
apparently he's going to be playing
gwent which is fun kingdom come
deliverance that really uh exciting
kickstarter out of prague eagle fight vr
from ubisoft and mr shaffe is coming on
to tell us all about why we should play
psychonauts in virtual reality plus god
of war at the end of the show loads of
stuff uh right here on the gamespot
stage so don't go anywhere be back in a
couple of minutes
[Music]
i love battlefield and as a longtime fan
of shooters i finally had a chance to
play hover junkers on the htc vive
the vive unlike the oculus rift makes
use of physical rooms and has players
running around a square between sensors
in the case of hover junkers the square
could be the multiplayer lobby which was
a small bar with a robot bartender al
a platform at the shooting range
or your actual hover ship used in the
multiplayer combat arena
selecting a gun and holding it with the
htc vive controller was initially very
thrilling you could flick open the
cylinder and look through it you could
turn the gun over and look at the
details from all angles they even
scribbled words between each cylinder
groove and the revolver better than that
when you fire the gun you actually need
to use sight picture and i found myself
closing one eye to line up shots as they
do on the range i would say that one
adjustment the game probably needs
though is the ability to seat the gun
higher or lower in the palm of your hand
the virtual hands in the game are tilted
a little bit too far forward than my
natural hand which meant i had to [__]
my hand back further than i normally
would to get good side picture after
practicing at the range mostly shooting
and doing manual reloads i hopped into a
round of multiplayer i must say the
stress of reloading trying physically to
get to your ship's controls and
selecting weapons to shoot back was
fantastic similar to the active reload
mechanic in gears of war you have to
split your attention to many different
actions while under stress this
simulates the feel of shooting a real
firearm better than any other 2d
counterpart except maybe a receiver a
game specifically designed to simulate
how a firearm works mechanically now for
the downside of physical shooters in a
real room the cover on the hover
platform is about belly button height so
players have a few pieces of junk
initially to build around them but as
that gets blown away you have to duck
down to get below cover while fantastic
in vr in reality you're constantly
slamming your knees into the hopefully
carpeted ground
this game should probably come with
tactical knee pads
also you're constantly spinning around
to engage targets and getting wrapped up
in the htc vive's physical cable
this is not only a tripping hazard but
could break the vive if you stepped on
it the wrong way and let's be honest
there are a lot of middle-aged gamers
now you could actually rent your back
playing this game overall though hover
junkers is a great proof of concept
after playing it i firmly believe a
borderland style game would be possible
in vr
movement controls being handled by your
left hand worked really well and going
from a hover platform to just accepting
your virtual feet gliding across the
landscape wouldn't be that big of a jump
vr is incredibly expensive and no
particular fully featured shooter is on
the horizon but hover drunkers at least
in concept makes me hopeful there is
nothing in 2d gaming right now quite
like picking up a gun in vr closing one
eye and squeezing off a few rounds
[Music]
[Applause]
hello folks and welcome back to gamespot
coverage of the electronic triple 2016
i'm danny dwyer joined by michael
maherty and is a standing chin
i love you you beautiful man torben my
friend we're here to talk about him i
was about to say tobias reaper i'm not
sure if anyone ever calls him that
anymore i think that got thrown out with
the first thing
that briefly right yeah
maybe one game i don't know uh agent 47
has had a wonderful renaissance this
year yes in the form of of hitman yes
just season one hitman yeah yeah um
let's talk about that first of all
because there was sort of you know i
guess a bit of as you know anytime you
release a game in a sort of a non you
know just boxed copy there you go
there's a bit of confusion about it uh
talk a little bit about i guess the
impetus behind releasing hitman as this
like purchase and then episodic game um
so this goes back to absolution right uh
i was on absolution i was working uh
with the guys who built contracts mode
which was the create your own target
thing there um and we shipped it and
very quickly as you always do with the
game you discover things that
are perhaps not as good as they could
have been or things that you designed as
diligently as you could but it turns out
that when you put tens of millions of
players into it stuff is not working the
way
um
the the three things in absolution that
were kind of
troubled were uh the disguise system
that was maybe a bit too punishing a
little bit difficult to understand right
it was uh the scoring system that got a
lot of flak because it was stupidly
punishing and finally uh the contract's
economy was just busted um
and
the problem with the way we built that
game the problem with
the way we understood how to build games
at that point was almost like packing uh
packing a trunk to go on a trip right
you stuff stuff into it and you stuff
stuff into it you get your friend to sit
on it so you can close it if you open
that thing again it's going to explode
yeah we shipped it and then we thought
okay what can we do without opening this
trunk again um and we managed to get the
disguise system kind of fixed but we
couldn't touch the other things because
it was just right too much and the other
problem with packing for a trip is that
once you've hit your first waypoint you
realize you brought all the wrong things
precisely yeah precisely so
um so a bunch of us sat down and we
thought what are the things that we wish
we could have done
and we we identified things like the
ability to kind of go into a level and
make game mechanical changes like for
example saying okay suddenly these guys
are going to enforce disguises or you
can't climb the side of the building or
you have to do the whole thing in five
minutes but not knowing ahead of time
what everything would be but have like a
framework that will allow us to inject
new rules you'll recognize these from
escalation mode yes idea of
complications
we
wanted to be able to go back and create
and inject new
game design into levels like new targets
and
new security setups and
entirely new activities in the levels
which is what we've done with the summer
bonus episode by creating the film set
and marrakesh by night yeah um so it was
like in that scope of things that we
arrived at this understanding that we
wanted to have a game
as a platform right i mean it sounds
like an awful buzzword but this this
idea that we could touch these things
in a way that didn't require us to patch
constantly
and that brought us kind of to where we
are today where we have episodes that
come out and bring a new location and a
bunch of setup and we have
weekly content drops of escalations or
challenges or elusive targets that
can really change the level the one
that's live right now in e3 actually
goes into that back area of the palace
where usually dicker meets novakov and
you break his neck and chuck him in the
river like one thing that happens there
we've lifted all of that out and now
there's a party there right and all the
people who could normally get in can't
get in and
there's a whole piece of setup there and
our ability to do that or even our
ability to go in and do things like
marrakesh by night that you see there
which is much calmer
cooler more
more welcoming marrakesh that is on this
scale of things that we can do
with this game platform that we've come
up with yeah it's always interesting to
me
the episodic structure itself i'm always
kind of skeptical about when i hear it
at first but uh you know in retrospect
this game just really works with it
because it like the way people talk
about this game is so different than
like when you talk about the earlier
hitmans you know you play through the
entire game someone says oh i saw this
this is how i did this this is how i
completed this objective or i use this
disguise but this game it's like every
single episode that releases is just
under this really tight scrutiny so that
people really learn it like the ins and
outs and that's really interesting to me
when i come into work and i hear like uh
pete or reviews that are saying like
yeah i just played this again and i
heard i just found this and like you
really learn it inside out i'm assuming
that was your intention maybe yes um but
it
it was
i think the the big realization for me
with releasing this game now
is how
it almost seems we consume games now
right when we release something it's
live and it's streamed and people have
passionate opinions about it and um we
watch this and sometimes we're sitting
there thinking should we fix this like
moment to moment yeah it's like no wait
and see how it settles
um an example of this uh in the um
sapienza level uh you can unlock this
breaching charge device thing you slap
it on a door you trigger it it'll blow
the door and blow a safe and that kind
of thing uh game mechanically it's a low
yield uh not was a non-lethal explosive
right but people worked out that it
actually had a very very high physics
impetus okay so then an elusive target
comes out the first one
the target is the forger at one point he
walks out onto a balcony so
one of our fans works out that if he
takes a fire extinguisher puts it out in
the garden on top of this breaching
chart triggers the breaching chart the
fire extinguisher smashes the guy in the
face and kills that's awesome in a game
mode with permadeath right yeah yeah and
it's like
what what did you think as designers
when you saw that um
it's designed
it sounds facetious right but it goes
back to to the the infamous uh traffic
accident kill in a new life in blood
money which was like at the dawn of
youtube where
someone uh figured out that if they went
into the specific level and triggered a
specific series of events the target
would panic call for his backup run out
into the street and his backup would get
in the car drive over hit him and kill
him
and it's like
we did not script that we didn't design
that it was like an emergent result of
hundreds of hours of like abuse of the
systems and that led to contracts mode
in absolution right and in many ways
it's it's informed a lot of the design
decisions that we've done on the new
game which are embracing the fact that
there is craziness and we're seeing
sapienza yeah running here this is the
film set this is um a superhero epic uh
sci-fi movie being shot in sapienza the
target is a film director uh it's a lot
of fun because he's an old school guy he
does his own stunts he likes
pyrotechnics and uh physical effects and
that's a dangerous lot
of 47 on set yeah to mike's point i mean
the hitman games were one of those games
that replaying levels was always fun it
wasn't like you were just constantly
trying to get to the next one but there
also was this element of you want to see
what happens next so it was almost as if
the game was sort of pulling your
attention in two different ways it was
like play with the sandbox but also hey
next see what the next one is yeah yeah
so in a in a weird way
and again it it goes to like gamers
don't know what they want right because
like people are probably saying like i
want to play a full hitman game i want
to pay 60 dollars not to wait but you've
actually allowed this like the players
to breathe and experience the level and
play with that emerging gameplay and
trick things and you know in a way that
like the game is such a long time it
feels like this game is coming out every
two months or whatever because it's like
a new thing did you expect that that
would happen or
were you worried that there would be a
backlash to like why are they asking me
to pay for 60 for one level and
promising me the rest
let's be honest right it was on us to
prove that this was a thing that could
make sense that it was valid not just to
wait for everything to come up
but
i think you're on the money right people
are
people are realizing that they have time
and they feel
kind of liberated to go in and explore
and discover the fact that everything in
our games is built up around the context
of the level the progression system and
the challenge all of this is about
mastering a level um but talking about
liberation
that was kind of a
an interesting outcome of the escalation
design escalations are like these little
multi-stage missions where we say kill a
guy dressed as a waiter with a saber
okay can you also do that if you've got
to hide the bodies in 90 seconds can you
also do that if you have to delete tapes
if they spot you yeah can you also do
can you also do can you also do right
kind of a horde mode for hitman
but what came out of that is that it's
liberating because there's no fiction
there's no reason why 47 is doing this
right it's mechanics the mechanics are
fun and going through a level
and then suddenly encountering the fact
that hey right you can only carry this
weapon in this disguise
why
have fun with this challenge
and it's liberating and helps i think it
helped me right when i first played the
prototypes of this to
to realize that hey the basic mechanics
of this game are a lot of fun right we
do tend to kind of get locked into the
fiction and and the fantasy of this
ultra powerful assassin yeah and
sometimes it's when we livestream it me
and travis are our community manager
when we live stream it it always goes
south yeah
travis proximity bombs
but
it's fun because it just lets you play
with the mechanics
yeah sorry about no let's just say yeah
i like to use a dumb metaphor i was like
comparing it it's like comparing the
earlier ones to like novels whereas this
is a collection of short stories and you
can get attached to them individually
but then also like the overarching
structure of the entire game is still
interesting like there's that through
line that kind of connects them all yeah
i don't know that's always that's been
interesting to me since i started
releasing it it's also been i think
key to the way we're trying to imagine
our our story and our development of the
narrative in the game because
absolution was
an interesting study of the character in
kind of like
a particular kind of story very grind
house gritty how many lives will you
take to save one kind of high concept
thing
maybe not super
approachable from the point of view of
blood money but
with making this one we i think we made
the decision really early on that we
didn't we didn't want to do a hero's
journey with the guy right right we
wanted to keep 47 the stoic cold guy in
the middle and tell stories around him
right which is wonderful which is like i
always find it funny that there are two
hitman movies because hitman to me has
always been
like a cipher for like the player to
just it's like a game of chess right
it's like all of these mechanics so to
me the fall was never and like again
there were some wonderful moments
throughout the franchise like just
thinking about the the coffin scene with
the credits running and all that i like
hitman one has some like wonderful
moments in as well with like his origin
story and all that stuff uh but yeah
it's like i guess you guys picked your
poison you went okay you know what
people notice the video game like the
escalation mode is a perfect example of
that we know it's a game like we know
it's we know that there's there are some
games where you shouldn't see the puppet
strings but it's perfectly fine in
hitman to know what where those purple
strings are and then to sort of mess
with them
precisely that i mean it's like this
giant clockwork machine and when you've
mastered it you know if you stick the
thing in here
this machine will tear itself apart and
your two targets will die and no one
will be blamed and you can do it in less
than a minute
and that's that's as designed
i could talk to you all day about this
i'm sure mike could too uh we have to
cut this one but before you go when is
the next so is this technically episode
four
we call this the summer so this is the
summer bonus episode episode four comes
after this is the midpoint it's out uh
july 19th on your preferred console or
digital platform awesome wonderful thank
you so much for coming on i really
appreciate it best of luck with the rest
of hitman season one thank you uh yeah
and best of luck with if there is a
season two i'm sure there was people
seem to be chewing this one down so
thank you so much for coming on i really
appreciate it uh thank you for watching
everyone uh make sure you get those
questions in sorry i was uh hogging
torben there for for that segment uh
we've got uh jason on in a second to
talk about starpark the fractured
butthole i know a bunch of people
looking forward to this one so stick
around back in a couple of minutes
you're watching the game spot stage
brought to you by airheads
[Music]
all right boys let's rock and roll
as someone familiar with the series star
fox zero is immediately confusing on the
surface it appears to be a modern
extension of star fox 64 but zero plays
by its own rules it relies on the
gamepad's display and motion sensing
capabilities asking that you divide your
attention between two screens one for
flight and one for shooting which
fundamentally changes how you play the
game zero has a few tricks up its
sleeves when it comes to vehicles too
including the walker mech transformation
for your r-wing jet you also have access
to a slow drone-like copter in the gyro
wing which packs a tiny tethered robot
that you can lower and navigate through
small spaces to access computer
terminals once lowered you look through
the robot's eyes using the gamepad's
screen to pinpoint your target and hack
away though it's a process that's more
tedious than it is enjoyable
more than anything else in xero piloting
your r-wing is a joyous experience your
booster jet communicates a great sense
of speed as you twist in midair and flip
around behind enemies leaving bursts of
energy in your wake you also have to
contend with tight spaces tipping your
wings at just the right angle to slip
through small gaps and avoid
environmental
back perils
the landmaster tank from star fox 64
makes its return as well but new to zero
is the ability to transform the land
master into a jet though it doesn't
match the speed or maneuverability of
the r-wing it's a welcome bonus that
makes piloting a slow tank a tad more
interesting in practice
most stages in xero are on rails where
you move forward at a constant rate in
other scenarios typically boss fights
you switch into all range mode and take
full control of your r wave and it's
here where xero's complicated control
scheme becomes a center of attention and
not in a good way now in theory zero's
controls allow you to be a more capable
marksman picking off enemies with
greater speed and accuracy than before
the catch though is that you have to
look away from your tv and focus on the
gamepad's first person cockpit view
while your vehicle flies unattended
you have the option to press a button to
shift the cockpit view to your tv but
even so the same disconnect applies
though you may find some success aiming
with a third person reticle when flying
through linear stages is actually
terribly misleading rather than indicate
where your shot will actually land the
reticle in zero's third person view is
representative of your line of sight
from the cockpit once you enter all
range mode you have no choice but to
switch between first and third person
perspectives here the camera becomes
unshackled and floats around your
vehicle rather than directly behind it
your over-the-shoulder line of sight is
stripped away although you can lock onto
enemies that come into view it's only
the camera that's affected not your aim
and it took hours to become fully
acclimated to zero's new rules but it
did eventually click
while i still resort to feeling out my
aim during linear levels i'm more
comfortable and effective in all
arrangement the high learning curve was
enough to make me put down the
controller and walk away more than once
early on but every time i came back my
skills improved my relationship with
xero did get off to a rocky start but i
was in a better place once i convinced
myself to forget everything star fox 64
taught me and accept zero on its own
terms now the new controls don't
necessarily make for a more fun space
combat game and i found myself wavering
between excitement and apathy when going
through the campaign no matter how you
slice it star fox has always been a
series about flight and movement and
zero dilutes that formula by forcing you
to prioritize shooting that's not to say
you never had to fire at enemies in the
past but the act of aiming was tied to
movement which in practice maintained
the ever-present joy of flight now the
act is tied to a complex control scheme
that's a mild but regular source of
frustration
zero saved in part by its presentation
blue skies and verdant hills with
crimson enemies give way to vast
expanses of outer space the perfect
canvas for lasers and radiant stars with
the added gravitas from the soundtrack
and the quips from your allies during
battle zero often echoes the star wars
film's great battles albeit with a cast
of cute and furry heroes
no time to celebrate we've got a fight
on our hands
the old material is handled with care
and later levels do a good job of
standing out with new mission designs
and set pieces that feature impressive
scale by the end of my first playthrough
i was eager to go back and retry old
levels in part because i wanted to put
my newfound skills to the test but also
because xero's campaign features
branching paths that lead to new
locations my second run through felt way
better than the first and solidified my
appreciation for the game while i still
don't love the new control scheme it's a
small price to pay to hop into the seat
of an r wing and dive back into combat
zero is a good looking homage with new
secrets to find and challenges to
overcome it doesn't supplant star fox 64
but star fox zero does the series legacy
justice
[Music]
hey folks welcome back to gamespot stage
right here at the electronic triple it's
time to talk about fractured buttholes
cannot wait for this one
oh sorry just a single one fractured but
whole jason's two words i'm so sorry
uh thank you so much for coming on to
talk to myself mike absolutely about
your beautiful fractured butthole uh
congratulations you uh did a great
little bit on the whole the whole place
falling apart when you come down here
fracturing right around me
how was your how was your time on the
stage trying to wrangle trey and matt uh
it was it was fun it was exhilarating i
barely remember it like it was sort of
an adrenaline rush yeah we had uh
did a single rehearsal right okay and it
was not anything like the one we did
live so it was pretty pretty fun it was
good uh the main thing is just
uh
we meet
very very very regularly so like all of
the game design meetings we basically
were like let's just go up there and
kind of have a meeting i was like i have
some prepared videos that i kind of need
to make sure we hit so you guys will say
some stuff and everyone i'll go
backstory we should talk about backstory
because there's a really great video
about it
yeah what's that what's that
relationship like i guess like how
involved are it seemed like they were
incredibly involved in the stick of
truth writing the whole thing yeah is
that the same case here i mean they
right uh they're they're like the
creative directors and the lead writers
and like the head editorial and it's
like
they're super duper involved uh like
i think that they could be making
a movie they could be making another
play but yeah choosing to sort of divert
all that energy into making a great game
yeah and it was really interesting
watching sort of the series after the
stick of truth because there was so much
random video game related stuff yeah in
there like you could tell they were like
visiting
websites and reddit and stuff like that
yeah i think that you anytime you watch
an episode and you're like where do they
come up with that yeah it's just what
they're thinking about it's just what
they're they're very personally doing
and it's either the boys they're saying
stuff or randy's saying stuff
so what's it been like for you then
working you worked on sick of truth as
well right uh i was working on rocksmith
at that time oh okay cool all right so
what i guess what's the what's the sort
of impetus been around doing the sequel
has it come from those guys was there
sort of unfinished business left in that
or have you guys dragged in like a bunch
of people who hadn't wouldn't have
played a south park game before and you
kind of want to service them again well
i think it's a few things like
ubisoft was really happy with how the
stick of truth was received and then i
think south park was like well i mean
people liked it but
what if we did it even better right and
like oh well we wouldn't want to do that
and it's like well but if we did do it
it would be about superheroes because we
really we liked the [__] and friends
like yeah
what would we call it and then i think
he's like the fractured butthole
okay we have to make that because now i
want to see that on a giant billboard
and i like and we'll get ubisoft to pay
for it
[Laughter]
done
you just completed it recently right
yeah i didn't i've been putting it off
for so long for some reason that my
roommate's like all right he heard me i
hadn't played it he's like okay let's
play it yeah and just like from the
outset i played undertale right before
that right and they're very different
games but they're also like
kind of play with what you expect from
rpgs yeah very much like in the classes
of stick of truth especially because i
don't know what's appropriate to say on
the stage anything trepidation we
already said fractured butthole a bunch
yeah i guess so um but no it's you play
as a jew
[Laughter]
no it's uh and then well obviously the
whole when you're picking your name or
whatever he's like are you sure it's not
douchebag yeah i believe you entered
douchebag is that correct yeah no i
didn't yeah i think you entered
douchebag all right confirmed douchebag
so so what type of sequel is the
fracture butthole then is it like are
you are you using those same rpg
mechanics uh and layering on a new story
or yeah trying to move some new stuff in
there it's
you're the new kid still from stick of
truth so like the familiarity of the
town and everything will feel really
good but uh i think already sick of
truth ended up being largely uh sort of
satirical about all games and this is a
a little bit satirical about movies and
entertainment in general and just sort
of everyone it's funny that everyone
like that's just a normal like
mass-market person at this point uh
understands an origin story and conflict
and crooked cops and like what you might
need to do to be a superhero these days
and just like the citizens of south park
kind of getting caught up in the kids
game and just being a part of uh their
their sort of fantasy
so does it play similarly to to stick a
truth kind of will people be used to
that i mean because there is an element
of if it ain't broke don't fix it there
but then you know you're making sure you
want to get something i mean you were
able to finish stick of truth pretty
short order and like i think we still
want that level of you know ubisoft has
games that uh can take you a lifetime to
completely totally do everything and
there's no shortage this one this one i
mean we want it to it's big but we want
people to not feel like they're i'm
never gonna be able to finish that right
and that's nice um
so for fractured i think that
the combat is obviously a big change so
the last time it was turn-based just uh
you each stick on a side and this time
it's still turn-based which gives us a
lot of flexibility to get in jokes right
timing and have you to have the time
to hear the joke delivered um but it
also we went into more depth so we
we really were talking about it kind of
sucks that when you're able to like
explore around south park but then we
have this little cutaway and then you're
kind of fighting in an approximation of
the place you were just right yeah yeah
we're like we really want to just have a
fight in that kitchen we want to have a
fight in cartman's kitchen and we want
to have a fight on main street not an
approximation
and so in order to do that we're like
well why would you have to no longer be
able to move if you were just exploring
so yeah okay well let's move and then i
realized oh my god i just quadrupled or
maybe a tuple the amount of animation
work we have to do but totally worth it
because now you can like knock each
other around and really
uh just watch it
okay yeah
um slow down time when you fart uh it
changes the turn order if you do it
during combat so in a turn-based game if
you can manipulate the turn order it's
one of those weird things of the boys
are always imagining that they're
superheroes but somehow they're always
kind of also
having a real impact on the world so
yeah there's there's a sort of weird
mind game of are you really farting so
bad that it's breaking time or is
everyone just agreeing to switch up the
term current order
oh sorry do you still have like
character archetypes you choose from for
your character like not classes but kind
of you know
we have classes actually because we we
took the superhero
class types that you might play in like
a super hero tabletop rpg um and so you
can be a speedster blaster
uh or like a brick so you could be like
a thing quicksilver
uh cyclops and sort of mix and match
those powers so that you like have a
defensive thing but you can be move fast
and shoot blasters because you're kids
and you're just sort of like revising
the rules based on yeah yeah okay okay
you can have another class
but you know you have to have this new
kryptonite or whatever like just they're
just making stuff up yeah yeah yeah
there's a bunch of questions coming in
so many of them i cannot possibly say uh
but keep them coming in uh did you
change the town of soundpark asks is
thematgory uh or is the map the same so
yeah how do you even like deal with that
considering like it exists or there's a
cannon you as the new kids still live
next door to butters right and butters
lives next door to eric so it's that
sort of familiar stuff is there but then
at the same time uh we needed to add new
businesses so
uh because
in a superhero show you need that sort
of like dirty place that you go to so we
have like the
peppermint hippo which is their uh strip
club and uh buca de fagucini which is
their italian restaurant
is the peppermint hippo in any way a
play on spearmint rhino never heard of
it
that was a place we saw recently
we're in like santa barbara on the drive
down to see the connection
yeah yeah all right uh but like the
we have the ruins of soda sopa are still
built up around kenny's house from the
last season so you can sort of see like
season 19 blending into this version of
south park um
i was going to ask something and then
you mentioned the spearmint rhino thing
completely gone out of my head uh i
guess when trey and matt were on the
stage they talked about the uh kanye
west
yeah uh sort of the teaching moments
yeah that might be does that actually in
the game that that exists that is
actually in the will help the gay fish's
mom get to heaven okay
so
it's gonna be emotional for everyone
it's like it's like internal it's like
you have a game within a game yeah
almost yeah yeah i mean they've added
like in the last game you go into canada
and just sort of the stuff that kind of
takes your expectations and subverts it
like we're we're definitely still
finding that sort of stuff and just
trying to get you to just not just do
the same thing every moment uh do you
have any idea like what games those guys
play did they ever come to you and say
like oh look i've been playing a bunch
of this
well that's what makes it really easy to
collaborate with them is that they are
both big gamers so just like you know
when you're working on with game
developers and you're like well you know
like this i was playing this this
weekend and all they did this really
smart thing the same exact way like
right right now not not because of a
ubisoft thing matt stone is playing the
division like crazy so like that's a
really good touchstone for us to talk
about oh well the reason they did that
and we could do something like that in
our game uh really unifies that language
trey has been playing a lot of rpgs um
but he also plays a ton of tabletop
games right so he's a dungeon master and
runs his own campaign oh really um and
uh for
for him then a lot of those mechanics
and a lot of those like tactics things
that we're doing are also things that
he's sort of you know just like a good
game design lead he's like well you know
let's prototype it in a little board
scenario it doesn't get irritating when
they're like because like to me that
sounds like every person on the internet
ever it's like oh you should have done
it like that like i really like this
part of like the witcher could you like
stick that in yeah when you have
editorial control you could totally say
that if you
i got a bit of like it was like stanley
parable-esque stuff with cartman
narrating over yeah
yeah so what you're seeing there is
actually cartman uh has an interactive
backstory with you so
you go to cartman who's the [__] and he
is trying to build up his franchise and
he wants you to be a marketable
superhero because he wants
you to to be a part of making a billion
dollars for him uh and so that means
that you need to have a compelling
backstory and what we did is we used
that interactive backstory to actually
train you on your new powers got it so
if you unlock a speedster uh rather than
just throwing you out in the world like
you were a jew and you're like i have no
idea what that's gonna mean but it's a
long-term consequence and now you're
locked in right what's the big big like
all role-playing games yeah so you
choose speedster and he gets to like did
you like those powers would you like to
try something else like no matter what
you're never going to be in time to
stop your dad from how much can i say
you just want to say whatever you want
yes
you'll never be in time to stop your dad
from [__] your mom okay like no
matter what that's that's the the
problem with being
uh a superhero that's just you know has
that painful origin story
um sparks be asking uh will the new
upcoming season of star park influence
the game or vice versa is there any
crossover does that sort of stuff happen
uh i mean there's like elements of the
seasons you can see in the game i mean
we're coming out in december and south
park season two will be 20 will be
running from september to december so i
think it's much more likely to hit dlc
than it is the game just like because
they don't know what they're doing in
season 20. right now like legitimately
no idea they will walk in in september
and go what's on our minds and let's get
that under the screen in six days i feel
so old that there are 20 seasons of
south park like that's i remember being
like eight feeling like i was like an
old person like an older teenager when
it started out i guess it's been
ridiculous and yeah i think people have
sort of grown up and had their
minds twisted by it right
who do you who buys this game then do
you think because like i don't even know
who the audience for because the
audience was saying everything for
everybody
because like to me the audience for
setback is like people like our age who
grew up watching it but presumably there
are like younger folks watching as well
one of these weird things about stick is
that like we start seeing people playing
it online and then they start playing it
because they saw someone else playing it
online and sharing those videos and then
they're like man this game's so great
did you hear they made a cartoon out of
it you're kidding me
wow that's such a weird way to approach
that like we just never really
anticipated it so now with fractured we
just like we want we want moms to play
it and that seems like it's a weird
thing like well moms it's like no man
moms
have become moms while south park has
been right and oh god has been running
right oh my god so someone's dead
right and now but she's still into south
park totally get in there and play
because we're trying to make something
that's both like a good game and like
gamers are going to feel like cool it's
a tactics game and i get it right but
you know if you just want to experience
it you shouldn't be intimidated and like
all those jokes are there for you as
well that's the thing like the first
would stick it kind of seemed initially
like it would be tough to sell right i
mean you have south park fans which will
go for it right then like people start
playing little by little they're like no
it's not just a south park game it's
like like a good rpg is that like i
imagine it's a little
easier to wrap your people's heads
around uh fractured butthole right on
the side yeah second time around and
they kind of know what it is right yeah
yeah there's a level of expectation that
we're definitely gonna have to hit it
and go beyond it and i think we
definitely do that with combat and being
able to explore the environments and
really you know we've just improved on
everything the the farting is more
visceral and interactive than ever
before dynamic there's emergent farts
now right yeah i'm sure they are
definitely analog farts it's really
important that like both analog sticks
are controlling sort of a sphincter and
gas pushing sort of right yeah yeah
really yeah emergent sort of
visceral as you said yeah next gin man
yeah it's wonderful what a wonderful age
we live in yes just thank you so much
jason no problem brightening up my
afternoon uh south park and fractured
butthole uh when is it out on animal
platforms december 6th on playstation 4
xbox one and pc just in time for the
holidays right thank you so much for
your time really appreciate it enjoy the
rest of your electronic triple uh we'll
be back in just a minute folks thank you
so much for all of your questions
especially the ones i could not pass oh
my god
a bit of a change of pace we're gonna
have david cage on in a second to talk
about detroit uh become home and become
human so stick around
[Music]
it's all right
is
[Music]
is changing
so much
[Music]
is
everything is on
[Applause]
[Music]
everything is on
it's all right
[Music]
[Applause]
3.
[Music]
hello welcome back to gamespot coverage
of e3 2016. i'm delighted to be joined
by mr david cage uh i guess the writer
director creative lead yeah or whatever
uh detroit
at the same time all of these things
great to have you here
thank you for having me thanks so much
great to see detroit as well once again
um if you don't mind though i want to
talk to you about
one of your earlier games uh one of my
favorite games just briefly before we uh
uh omicron the nominee oh my god quantic
dreams first you're that old yes i know
yeah yeah
the gray hair i turned 30 this year um
but i love that game and obviously
earlier this year we lost david bowie in
january um and that was i believe the
only game that he was was in or the
other things yeah um so what was it like
working with him do you remember is
there
memories of it well it was my very first
game really and um yeah i remember the
first time we met actually i mean uh we
were supposed to meet in the publisher's
office in london
and um i thought it would never come i
thought all this was just you know would
never happen
and actually it was like 10 minutes late
right and we were all looking at our
watches thinking oh he's never going to
make it and then 10 minutes later he
arrived and he apologized for being late
because of the traffic
and he came with a young kid
he was maybe 14 years old right and he
said okay this is my video game expert
is my son uh duncan jones yes we became
of course the director that we know yeah
of moon and of course world of warcraft
and so it was really funny because i met
both at the same time yeah we had a
wonderful collaboration together that
lasted a year right and he wrote about
12 original songs and um and i had the
pleasure to direct him in studio because
he would play two roles in the game so
it was it's a fantastic experience of
course as you can imagine and he was a
fantastic person right that was actually
how i found out about david bowie
because i i i had never found his music
and then i remember walking into was it
the bar where the band is playing for
the first time and it takes control away
from you and absolutely does the music
video and then i was like what is this
yeah yeah my auntie found out and bought
me a david bowie album then so i
introduced you you did so thank you so
much oh my god for giving me the gift of
david bowie
to
um quantic dream obviously you've
created a bunch of games since uh
fahrenheit or um indigo prophecy
depending on what side of the atlantic
you live on absolutely um the last one
we played was uh beyond two souls right
uh another collaboration with a bunch of
famous
actors yes one of the interesting things
about detroit seeing it in initially is
that there doesn't seem to be any
familiar faces we don't have a willem
dafoe we don't have um any sort of
celebrity uh in it at least so far is
that the case well you know our goal has
never been to look for the most you know
famous people to get them in in our
games it was just to find the right
actor for the role and uh in this case
we worked with a bunch of young but very
talented actors and the first one we
introduced at paris games week is the
character is the character of cara yes
incarnated by a young actress called
valerie curry
and uh she was in a tv series called the
following recently and she's a she's a
fantastic actress and of course she was
cara in the shorts that we did by in
2012 long time ago now
so same actress and here at e3 we came
with a new scene and we absolutely
wanted to come with a playable scene
because you know with our games it's
time we we introduce a new game the
first question we get is how does it
play because it's it's still quite
mysterious for some people to know how
you can play a story driven game
so we wanted to come with this playable
scene in introducing the character of
connor who is uh
incarnated by a another very talented
actor called brian decker
let's talk about some of your i guess
influences that sort of create this
world uh what type of world are we
looking at here obviously you know very
you can talk about things like blade
runner in terms of the sort of like
android uh sort of human relationship
thing happening there um but what type
of world are we looking at in detroit
how far in the future is it what what
does detroit look like so detroit we
call it a neo-noir thriller it's set in
a near future in the city of detroit
michigan of course
and uh it's important for us that it's a
near future it's not sci-fi so there's
no flying car no laser gun it's just all
world but 20 years from now and this
this world in this world the technology
allowed the creation of androids that
look speak move exactly like human
beings except they are just machines
so they took most of human jobs as you
could expect and so there are millions
of them all across the country and the
story starts where when some of them
start to show strange behaviors uh some
of them leave without any reason others
kill themselves which is very unusual
for a machine
and others start to be aggressive
against humans and we're just at the
very beginning it's very few androids
having these dysfunctions
and
we are going to discover
why and what happened etc etc what was
important for me was to take a different
angle than than most stories about
androids i didn't want to tell another
story where the humans would be the good
guys and they would need to face these
evil androids and have a virus and we
need to kill them before they kill us
it's been done before very well
i wanted to create a story where we
would play the androids and see the
world through their eyes and from their
point of view and maybe they're the good
guys and maybe we are the bad guys it's
always an interesting part of your games
is the or i suppose maybe the more
modern ones is that the idea of playing
the story through multiple perspectives
presumably that will also be the
absolutely we play more than one
character we introduce again kara and
and conor is the second character that
this is playable and who knows maybe
there are more
wonderful yeah i'm sure we'll find out
over the coming months um yeah the demo
you showed i guess there's this thing
when you the games that you create are
always so
striking and so sort of like film-like
that i guess maybe audiences sort of
we assume that they're incredibly linear
and that there isn't much choice because
that's the case for most video games
that sort of take that route um was
there sort of a very determined um
mission to sort of show that okay here
is one small scene and this is like the
various different ways in which it plays
out absolutely i mean
we
we want to create an experience in which
the player is not only the actor of the
story but he is the co-writer so
basically based on his choices his
decision is going to tell his own story
and his story is going to be different
from from someone else's story
and
all this happens through gameplay so we
only didn't want to tell the story
through cut scenes we want the player to
play and as he plays he tells the story
and that was really our starting point
and a real real motto for for every
decision we make we wanted to create the
more we call this bending you know for
bending stories right uh but it's
branching narrative and basically we
wanted to create the more bending game
we have ever created that quantum dream
right well is that always the mission
for the next game because obviously you
know with heavy rain that was that was
the sort of modus operand that was the
mission it seemed and then with beyond
two souls
similarly but you know in a different
way probably you know game after game we
we don't like formulas in a way we try
to reinvent what we're doing we try to
challenge ourselves and we have the
immense luxury of having time and
support from from sony to try things to
experiment and and maybe fail maybe
succeed maybe find something or find
nothing but at least we can explore and
try and
each story you want to tell must find
its own voice its sound language in some
some way and uh so game after game we
try to find the best
gameplay the best interface that will
better feed the story we want to tell
and for detroit it became very obvious
from the beginning that that would be
the best choice having different points
of view um
also having characters who can die which
is also something very interesting
because i never felt comfortable with
game over
in video games to be honest especially
when they are story driven because it's
always a strange thing
this game over situations where you die
and then we go back in time and you need
to replay this again until you play the
game the way the game designer wanted
you to play which in
in a in a fighting game is fine or
shooting game but in a story driven game
doesn't make any sense right
so what we tried to do was to give a
narrative consequences to your
failures
and
make sure that maybe you will be injured
maybe you will lose something maybe you
will miss an information or or something
or maybe ultimately your character can
die but there will be a logical
consequence to your failure and
consequence significant consequences on
the narrative your games are you know
they're that they're
different as individuals if you compare
one to the other they're different but
people know what a sort of aquatic dream
game is they know where you're coming
from um
why is it do you think that even though
you've been making these games and they
have been successful and selling and
seem to be well critically uh sort of
acclaimed or received why is no one else
making these games
is that weird to you like you know i
think the situation has changed a lot to
be honest with you since we started
because when when we really initiated
this new jar maybe with indigo prophecy
um we were pretty much alone to believe
in this story driven game with branching
narrative
and i remember very well that it was
very challenging to convince publishers
at the time to sign this kind of
experiences because they said well there
is no shooting in your game what kind of
game is it going for
so
we are now you know 10 years later and i
think things have changed a lot because
now we can see some story-driven games
arriving uh and uh and we can see most
of more and more storytelling in all
kinds of games right even in shooters
now you have a very strong story and you
have virtual actors and they try to
bring emotion
so yeah i mean heavy rain was a game
that sort of you know back then you guys
were the first people it seemed doing
this sort of like facial capture voice
within the game i mean it seems like
it's happening in every game now
absolutely uh is it easier for you guys
now because there's like
it's not like you're creating this
technology to put in your game it's it's
more ubiquitous is it is it easier to do
that now is the technology become sort
of more
yeah you know it's easier and harder
it's it's easier in that sense that
because
other people are doing it then you know
what the benchmark is and what you want
to improve compared to others where
where you were on your own i mean you
were setting the benchmark by yourself
so it was like hard but it's more
challenging of course because now there
is a lot of competition and there are
some very very talented and skillful
people out there doing great things so
it's uh it's some pressure on the studio
but but it's a very interesting
challenge and overall i think it's a
good thing for the industry right as a
wall that that we compete to tell the
best story and have the best characters
in our games
and does sony support you i imagine
quite well in in this endeavor
absolutely i mean we came here
10 years ago in 2006 and we had this
short technical demo that we created
that was called the casting that you can
still find on youtube and actually we
never worked with sony at the time and
we just show them this little piece and
and they said okay we would you like to
be on sony's booth at e3
yeah of course
that's a dream coming true
and um they put the demo on their booth
and it's been very successful and got
very positive feedback and then they
came back and said okay
what do you want to do after that was it
[__] them heavy rain was it was that
the video of the lady in the kitchen
absolutely
absolutely and uh here we are 10 years
later and it's been a wonderful
relationship honestly with them for 10
years
they really supported us
always supported us and even in our
crazy ideas even whether games are late
or cost more than initially planned
which never happens to anyone in this
industry but still they were very
supportive and um always pushing us for
innovation and and you know being
creative and letting us what we wanted
to do i mean total creative freedom
which is incredibly rare these days yeah
i mean and also so sort of as you as as
a writer and director
like you only get video games take a
long time to make um and you only get to
make a certain amount within your
lifetime yeah was this a story that you
always sort of wanted to tell is this
one you've had on the back burner when
you were making other games like heavy
rain and beyond did you always want to
do your sort of take on on the android
human relationship
no
but but but i think the the you can only
i can only carry one story at a time
and but i know that this is a story that
i need to tell
but um it's it's one thing at a time and
there is a moment where you you carry
more stories than you but there is a
moment where there is one right and you
know it's the right one it's the one
you're going to fight for over the next
three four years of your life and uh you
know that you cannot leave without
telling that specific story and it it
slowly grows in you it's and it becomes
something obvious at some point and you
know you have to do it
and i guess i've got a lot of questions
sort of i'm sure you won't be telling us
too much about it but about detroit i
mean the word detroit in america as well
means something it you know that you
can't sort of think about that without
you know thinking about race relations
and sort of like um
i guess like socio-economic issues and
things like that and obviously we were
talking briefly before we went live
about you know sort of what's happening
in europe at the moment as well
do you feel like you want to tell those
types of stories within your games is
there any of that in detroit itself or
sort of because that's it's a difficult
one it's like do you want to have the
responsibility of burden of talking
about these things
you know
i chose detroit because i was very
fascinated by the history
of this city it was an industrial giant
in the 20th century and then it went
through very hard times
and now it's trying to be re born again
uh somehow it has also a fantastic
history
of
as you said racial you know issues um
the cultural aspect is also amazing with
the motown and all the great rice yeah
of course coming from detroit so it's a
fantastic place but it's also a great
city with a great history and
this idea of being very high and losing
everything and coming back right
is so strong and it's such a human story
somehow so that was a starting point for
getting interested in in detroit and
then we said okay we cannot write about
detroit without going there i mean of
course you can go on the internet and
grab some pictures and then you know
google earth it and and
there are lots of ways today yeah
but the thing is that you don't
feel the place you don't know the people
so we we traveled there spent some time
um there of course we visited the
abandoned factories and the abandoned
churches that everybody knows in all the
urban fields type of areas
but at the same time we we saw some
wonderful things we met some incredible
people
and um
the fox theater for example in detroit
is one of the most amazing place i've
seen and it's it's right in the center
of detroit and it's incredible
and and the people there
are full of energy and they're
struggling and they're fighting but they
they are revitalizing the city in a very
interesting way and all this combined we
came back from detroit really thinking
yeah this is the place where we want the
story to happen
but this is a very sensitive thing
because
and that was also very important to us
is that if you choose a real place yeah
you need to do it in a very respectful
way
because this city has its own history
there are people living there and they
they love their city or this is the
place where they live i mean you need to
pay attention to that and be respectful
and not just use what you want to use
for your game and throw everything away
so
we try to do it um and and we'll see but
um i hope that people in detroit will
feel proud of this game and and and the
way we use their city lovely um last
question david thank you so much for
coming on the talk talking a lot right
now no it's great like i mean i could
talk to you all day it's always
fascinating to speak at somebody like
you um last question what games are you
playing right now what do you have much
time to play games at the moment are you
very busy what have you played in 2016
uh oh i played a bunch of things a
little bit less this year because the
detroit is taking pretty much all my
time at the moment i'm playing a little
game on ios little game
great game it's called a human resource
machine okay
and it's
that sounds like work a bit it sounds
like work but it's actually a very fun
game to be initiated to programming
right though that sounds very boring
described like that but actually it's a
very fun game and if you like puzzle
games on ios you should check it out
because it's really surprising in many
ways excellent there you go game
recommendation from david cage himself
thank you so much sir for coming out it
was a pleasure looking forward to seeing
more of thank you
thank you thank you so much for watching
we'll be back in a couple of minutes uh
another change of pace we're just
talking to david cage about detroit next
we've got our friends from sede project
red on to talk about gwent stay there
we're back in a second
bravely second end layer is a sweeping
adventure across celtic myths pirate
legends and science fiction fairy tales
poor writing and force plot points do
impede the journey's momentum but its
vivid world and sleek combat are strong
enough to overcome the weight dragging
it down
as the sequel to 2012's bravely default
endlear returned you to luxendark a land
of arid deserts and snow-capped
mountains throughout your travels you'll
upgrade four characters engage in
turn-based combat earn new specialist
classes and prevent the world from
crumbling around you the story serves
mainly as a means to pull you between
lux and dark's locales offering new
macguffins on a whim as you navigate
class struggles and solve a variety of
political disputes along the way nobody
important
we're just looking for a man named go
[Music]
go
ah go get it the new guy at first and
layer's variety is suspect it's hard to
tell whether it's a wild western a
medieval journey or a dystopian sci-fi
drama but after several hours it's clear
the game is using the gamut of genres to
introduce aesthetics and characters just
for spectacle's sake at this point i'm
content to let it unfold curious as to
what i'll see next and layer's
characterization and dialogue don't
reflect the same ambition though in fact
its main character a young cavalier
named eugeniolja is cloying from the
start his catchphrases arrive during
emotional moments his reactions to plot
twists are rarely believable his
optimism and candor remain static
throughout never drawing any real
meaning from his sense of innocence and
naivete few of endless characters
display much dynamism but you as the
embodiment of the poor writing choices
that drag the adventure down end layer
also breaks the fourth wall several
times throughout often during pivotal
plot moments and it feels forced every
time these meta moments which i won't
spoil here are interesting concepts on
their own but the story doesn't earn
them they cheapen what little drama the
writing already struggled to impart cats
are everywhere cats see everything and
what they see i see
while endless narrative fails however
its combat succeeds the turn-based title
brings back the brave and default system
established in its predecessor by
defaulting each character enters a
defensive stance and saves up brave
points which allow them to use multiple
actions in one turn do this without
defaulting though and you're useless for
the next several turns endlear benefits
from this risk reward system much like
bravely default did there's an inherent
tension when choosing between careful
defense and all-out aggression the now
eponymous bravely second ability also
reprises its role the mechanic allows
you to stop time granting one character
an extra action during that turn further
increasing the possible ability
combinations against your enemies it's
especially useful against tougher bosses
where each turn carries more weight than
it might otherwise and all of this
combat is built on the franchise's
recurring job system jobs and the array
of possibilities surrounding them are
bravely second's lifeblood as with the
game's varied locales its class system
borrows from a plethora of genres
there's a templar there's an exorcist
there's even a cat person there are 30
jobs in total and each character can
equip two at a time by combining the
passive abilities of one with the active
attacks of another you can create your
own disparate subclasses to further your
goals endlear's class system is as much
about experimentation as it is execution
[Music]
actually acquiring each available job
however leads to problems in endlear's
overall structure although many classes
are unlocked through the main storyline
some are tied to optional side quests
that pit two npcs against each other by
choosing sides in the conflict you opt
to fight the opposing character thereby
gaining their job for the remainder of
the game this is conceptually intriguing
but it often creates situations where
the job you want is at odds with the
character you agree with end layer
forces you to play story above gameplay
or in some cases the other way around
without spoiling too much bravely second
does allow you to retrace your steps in
order to collect every job title in the
game's latter half but the dissonance of
the earlier side missions halts the
momentum of the globetrotting plot
[Music]
on that note the sequel's late game
hours are far more enjoyable than those
of its predecessor the pacing is
constant throughout here and you witness
different areas from those of the first
half it's a far cry from the
backtracking and tedium of default
waning chapters despite endlear's new
quests though and the variety of locales
on display here it's worth noting how
familiar the sequel can seem as a whole
for large chunks of the game you're
revisiting the same cities and dungeons
as those from bravely default and the
combat despite its sleek design doesn't
make any major improvements on the
well-established formula these
complaints don't affect endlear's
overall quality but considering the time
the first installment took to beat its
sequel imparts a sense of deja vu more
often than i prefer one could argue it
feels more like an exceptional expansion
than a true sequel but in the end
bravely second transcends the
limitations that it's poor writing and
redundant storyline create it's a grand
adventure in every sense of the phrase
whisking you across exotic environments
and satisfying your curiosity every step
of the way it has its restraints but as
the story closes on the plains of
luxemdark bravely seconds grasp more
than matches its reach and yet we never
know when the enemy will strike again
stay vigilant
wait a minute
[Music]
hello and welcome back to gamespot's
coverage of e3 2016 i'm your host daniel
dwyer uh delighted to be joined by mr uh
michael mccarty and uh damian moniere
from said project red you're getting
better every time i'm i'm determined not
to get cd project
people's names wrong uh pronunciation
marching told yeah well i think i think
i was calling uh mikhail mikkel for a
couple of years
uh and thank you um everything from the
wild hunt
for coming on to uh talk to us wild hunt
leader that's great look at that you
even have a lower third
the spikes are a bit unfortunate because
that's sweet yeah
there's a room over here
thanks um it was great to see the uh the
side of the fig being covered in in
gwentz it was wasn't it it hasn't been
finished yet it is right now okay really
yeah right just in time thanks a while
uh for for your great unveiling here on
the gamespot stage uh of gwent
it is a full video game yes uh so before
we get into gwentz can i ask you quickly
you actually made gwent for the witcher
3 right you were part of the team that
did it yeah yeah i designed it with a
mate of mine and then once we had a
prototype um
over a weekend in post-its right because
we didn't have long to come up with a
prototype then we enlisted some people
that
had uh basically the spare time to make
it because we were very busy with
witcher right pretty big game but we
knew we wanted this thing and
so we had jason who was our coder and
some artists from the marketing
department so yeah there was basically
two of us working on it so i guess you
know you took out dice poker out of what
you do you were like thinking of
something else to put in there yeah well
we knew we wanted a uh a card game
because we like card games yeah let's
have a card game no time to design it so
we sort of
outsourced some ideas came back not
quite what we wanted so at that point uh
adam badovsky
who's the studio director said look
we're gonna need to upgrade dice poker
which was still one and at that point i
was in his office and i said i'm sure we
can do better we can come up with a card
game in a weekend exactly sure exactly i
had no idea i was just so upset that we
weren't going to get it done it's all
right let me do it for you and uh he
said fine it's friday evening come back
on monday morning
that was exactly my life
as i was with rafael i made and we're
like yeah sure no problem right and we
exited the office they were just like
in tears um well we did it so we came up
with something the only prototype
and then uh yeah because we knew we
literally didn't have time so we made a
better prototype and started playing um
gwent against some people that we knew
the team needed so coders and so on and
we said look do you like this do you
want this to be in witcher
if so then we gwent needs you
it to work awesome all night long
basically for this and you made it
happen we made it happen that's the
thing went always been really special
for us and then after releasing uh walt
hunt
we received literally thousands of
emails and no exaggeration like
thousands of emails
from fans saying hey you know good game
how about standalone
yeah and it was great i mean you had the
physical copy as well and the expansion
pack as well for us that was it that was
the end we didn't think
we weren't sure that people were gonna
like it that much and we liked it
and then for the second expansion they
said okay we need more gwent i said okay
i can make a skellige deck right i had
it prepared in my head in case
and uh we did it
bit of p but that was a way for us you
know what goodbye everyone we know it's
the last one so here's an op deck have
fun with it and then they said okay
let's make a proper style uh well iron's
getting a little bit restless here so i
kind of want to get the game started
get going all right with the fat thumbs
yeah it still works fair play we
actually made uh we made an eredin deck
oh wonderful congratulations yeah
he's just
so right now we are against northern
realms as you can see there's quite a
few things that changed yes ui
but we wanted to keep the core
mechanic of for example
10 cards uh at the beginning definitely
redraw that yeah nice one
you got some wall hand riders there now
you can redraw up to three actually okay
tweaked a few things uh this one is a
cool car this is one of the fan's
favorite can we have a look at roach
oh wonderful
so roach basically
you might want to redraw her because
roach actually comes on whenever a hero
card comes on the board she will come at
a random
point on the board
just like
in witcher yes
so monster
versus northern realms looking at two
different tactics i i know you guys are
familiar with gwen right but well a lot
of the people who are watching on the
stream if you're not familiar it's dead
simple you've got uh you're on me
that will go on the battlefield fight
for you your army being your deck being
your hand you get 10 cards at the
beginning
and that's going to remain your hand
until the end of the whole game so you
have to manage
your units you have to know
when to bluff and
the goal is basically to have a higher
value than your opponent i think that's
that in a nutshell basically yeah one of
the wonderful things about this is you
sort of you know you have on your deck
and that can change obviously but you
know there's an element of like
sometimes it's even advantageous to sort
of intentionally lose one of the rounds
just so you can make sure you're the
amount of times that the startup thing
went that i was like i won the first
game and i was like yeah yeah you got
like four cards left uh a nightmare yeah
what do you want to make it as expensive
for the opponent as possible
uh so right now
i don't want to say too much because we
have someone off screen uh playing right
yes i don't want to
say what we have in our hand but
i
cause eredin's french by the way if you
didn't know i'll probably probably say
i'm typing
he's not gonna he's not he doesn't say
anything he just nods and
chokes me
and then yeah
why are you guys doing the hotel actors
here
so
there's also like a single player that's
right so what we did is uh like i said
gwen has been a special project from the
get-go and when we said okay let's make
a standalone
unfortunate uh
standalone uh we basically said okay
we're gonna do it we're gonna do it
properly
uh let's go speak to the lead writer
from the witcher are you on board do you
wanna help us come up some cool stories
maybe some stories that you hadn't had a
chance to tell which are
not necessarily
uh gerald's stories you know then we got
uh matthews tomaszkiewicz lead quest
designer that's how you say his name
that's how you say it
or something yeah yeah
uh i say it with the french accent
sounds better but it isn't so
he
yeah he
and his team came up with some pretty
good quest i think for the witcher i'm a
big fan of their work so do you play as
geralt in those are you playing as in
the tutorials right now you will the
stories
not necessarily it's stories from
different point of views
each faction gets its own sort of epic
10 hours long oh wonderful it's oh it's
brilliant you get this beautiful map
that you can explore with your character
and basically every
every uh clash you could say
is resolved through gwent right so the
way it should be the way it should be
every that's how we do it at work
whenever someone's upset we're like
and so yeah you interact with things we
wanted some elements from the witcher
that we loved and that the fans loved so
you interact with something the way you
interact with it
maybe like say a ruin
you choose to explore it and interact
with people a certain way you may get a
card or a solder that will join your
army and then you carry on
um you might come across a village
that's been attacked by the wild hunt so
you will maybe start on round two
with frost already and some right and it
becomes a bit of a puzzle here's your
hand how do you beat the guy in say x
number of moves oh that's cool so i
guess you're sort of having fun with the
the balancing within those games
we wanted to not just do a port in
multiplayer we wanted to add this really
i think i hated where they pick it's
being used
do you have another word for epic epic
fun uh come on writer mike mccarty uh
massive nuanced
no that's not the same thing let's say
massive yeah expansive get this massive
expensive single player
uh campaign marketing that's why we keep
you here
well that's the thing i think i don't
think i'm alone in thinking uh i mean in
retrospect i know better but i don't
think i was alone in thinking that you
were just pulling gwent from the game
and then you're going to release that as
its own standalone thing but then now
you have all these layers you have an
actual story to go along with it it's
like a fully fledged game yeah we never
do the bare minimum yeah we've got to
work better we've got to draw i know
yeah you guys you've played the
expansions yes yeah they're quite long
hours way more than twenty yeah whatever
ridiculous uh they're working to the
bone over there in warsaw and we work
ourselves too far we do it because we
love it honestly i know it sounds like
i'm bullshitting but that's true
we do it because
you know fans give us the energy to just
keep going
and it comes across in the game i think
so
so so we're we're in the draw at the
moment this is the the final round i
believe yeah this is the one around
quite a few cards he just played a
scorch a classic why would you scorch
why look dude who made the game
you can't just pontificate to everyone
who played it it's fine he plays whereas
the guy off screen i mean it's a pretty
good move but you don't scorch roach
all right go on
i mean let's try and wrap this up see
who's gonna win
yeah i mean good for the riders eridan's
not used to losing i mean he's not
losing to geralt maybe
[Laughter]
maybe have a look uh i don't know
because we only have units anyway pop
the leader pop yourself
pump yourself
there you go there you go
both decks had roaches so
yeah these decks are sort of
and again
sorry i don't like to lose when we do a
live thing nothing scripted these are
you know i don't i actually don't know
where the other guy has in his hand oh
yeah the game starts off still very
approachable very simple
for people that i knew as well to gwen
but we worked really hard on the the
curve because originally witcher 3 we
thought you know what let's just if
people
find or
buy
cards right super op just let them have
a full hand of hero cards
why because
it's a single player gerald at the end
of witcher 3 you're up here and yes
owning
the same with gwen it was just
it was a is gonna feel powerful yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so we thought it was
good obviously now as a multiplayer
dammit what have we got oh no that's not
good he's gonna get upset so what's
happened here for the folks who don't
all right so what's happening is 52 to
19 your opponent's got no cards left and
his leader to uh to use leader abilities
sort of this one-off
ability you can use once in a match and
eredin's got two cards might as well
play them so look at what happens
go
new spies we've added newspaper things
that yes
that is great we have new spies spicer
cards that allow you to draw uh more
cards from your deck because obviously
like we said we only get 10 cards at the
beginning so those cards are really
really important
oh we've got this
we've got this come on come on do it
maybe you know 140 to 19. that's quite
the yeah that is
yeah the guy of screen knows what he's
doing
and this card is one of the uh one of
the new special cards we have
wildhand leader that you know what you
may as well rage quito
we have an age great you want to raise
questions you have a rage quit button
yeah i've got to help him because he
doesn't
[Laughter]
no don't don't ruin our set
yeah he can forfeit and rage quit
such a good job i mean who was it that
that bet you i mean the only there's
only ever one person that's ever let's
bring you at any one time bring him on
oh man history repeating
geralt of rivier congratulations amazing
yeah you need to separate these two nice
work here okay shake your hand girls all
right wonderful all right thank you so
much from said project already when is
it out when can people play it getting
better no thanks for having us you know
we love you guys in the office no
worries when can people play it gwent go
sorry when's that uh it sat in september
i got so excited
playgwen.com so it's uh out in september
xbox one and pc first and uh yeah please
we need everybody to join and destroy
our servers
we made it for you guys so we need your
feedback
dot com garrett and damian thank you so
much for coming on uh we'll be back in a
second as long as our set is still here
with a kingdom come deliverance so stay
uh stay around and we'll be back
hopefully in a minute peace
hi there folks chris waters here outside
the la convention center where the
video game convention e3 is in e3 is in
e3 is in full
citizens of the world
may we have retention
method of communication you so dearly
love is a scam
invite has been selling your data to
government agencies they've provided
clandestine access to information
security firms
they will use your own stolen
information against you
they will attempt to change your
behavior
we are looking at the single most
powerful population control tool ever
created
if you are a willing activist or someone
who simply wants to defend your freedom
of privacy
join our cause as we dismantle invite
we are dead sick
join us
[Music]
so
hmm
[Music]
which prompted many myself included to
hope i never see another tiny hamburger
again in my life it just goes to show
that at a show as big and complex as e3
anything is possible for more of the
latest news from e3 and expert analysis
on what it all means stay tuned to
gamespot.com i'm chris waters signing
off
[Music]
so
hey folks welcome back to game spots
coverage of e3 2016. i'm very happy to
be joined by toby from warhorse sir
uh you guys are responsible for one of
the most successful video game
kickstarters certainly one of the most
successful coming out of the czech
republic uh tell us about your game
kingdom come deliverance um yeah thank
you for inviting me kingdom come
deliverance is a medieval rpg set in
bohemia in central europe and we try to
create a game that is as realistic as
possible and it's historically accurate
as possible so we try to tell a story
that actually really happened in central
europe and it said that the life is
telling the best story so we are going
this way and yeah that's what we are
working on and as you said in we
kickstarted we were kickstarted funded
in 2014. now we are on track so it's
kind of a kickstarter success story
because this is happening and also you
asked what would you ask for like it was
around a quarter of a million and you
ended up getting it we only wanted three
hundred thousand british pounds right
ask me how many now that is five hundred
thousand four hundred thousand dollars
something like that let's say something
like that and we got that actually after
30 hours and after after 25 days we had
1.1 million uh
british pounds and that was like we
well
we were surprised of course we thought
that people might like this idea of
course otherwise we wouldn't do that but
the
good feedback we got even from america
germany yeah uh was amazing so yeah this
has been a fascinating project to sort
of watch because the game that you're
creating is one that like i'm i'm not
surprised you got that much backing
because it's a very sort of underserved
part of the video games market even
though you know the sort of like
realistic take on this like part of
history is really popular around the
world
well yes it's well you are right well
and on the other hand no one did did
that before which is kind of
if you took if you look a lot a lot of
rpgs have uh have this medieval setting
so you have swords and kind of stuff but
it's always combined with dragons magic
and which is cool well i like it i like
the witcher i like skyrim i like those
games they are awesome but we try to go
another way we try to go to we're trying
to want to show the real medieval
setting so we have
a landscape that really existed we have
castles and churches and monasteries
that really existed back then we
reconstructed them all we have a 16
square kilometers map of real land mass
with heights and valleys and mountains
and stuff we have npcs that really live
back then so that's our reason that are
noble persons that actually did
something in in the world and in
shape the future or shaped our today's
europe so that's really interesting and
we're trying to show that we want to
show the people how the medieval life
looked like like really looked like what
topics did they cover what problems that
they have what political struggle there
was in europe maybe one of the first
like real like say national problems
between bohemia and today's germany
right yeah that's that's something you
want to cover forgive me if i'm wrong
but you also have kind of like a
survival needs system with eating and
sleeping and actually kind of stuff like
that exactly we have this as well it's
like it's not in a big extent but
there's a big part of it a small part of
it you have to eat and sleep in order to
stay healthy uh healthy you can take
food in your pockets of course but it
will spoil during time right this is a
fun story i was fighting one time in due
to a presentation i was fighting and
this guy nearly killed me and i wanted
to restore some energy and i had old had
only spoiled radish in my pocket so i
ate that uh poisoned myself and died off
and it's like
it happens this game comes across like
almost like a medieval armor or
something where it's like it's it's it's
pushing so much into realism that it's
just compelling that you guys are
creating this so like even is there
something like 16 different points of of
like storage or clothing on your
characters exactly exactly it's kind of
like this you have an armor system
you've got horse armor as well
it works like that that you have a
different slot system we have it's it's
16 slots you can layer different parts
of armor over each other and every part
of armor or fabric or material is good
against another type of weapon attack
slashing stabbing something like this
and you have to combine it in a smart
way because for example a full plate
armor if you think about that
it's a full blade armor soldier has
something like a medieval tank really
right yeah yeah and with a sword you
just can't penetrate this guy you can
smash him and smash him stab him but the
weapon the sword will bounce off so
think about this situation take a mace
crash him to death inside his tin so
that's what you have to do and with this
layering system you are physically
really layering let's say a soft
gambeson as a strong full blade and with
this you're customizing your armor and
that keeps your life because health is
nothing you can level in the in the game
everybody has the same amount of energy
health but it's the armor that keeps you
alive and right uh as you said the armor
is
not some strange number in your
inventory but we are calculating the
physical collision between your weapon
and the piece of armor
okay so that's why we have 16 slots make
sense of course because you can
customize this however you want but if
you hit let's say if you're completely
naked and have only a full plate helmet
for example and i hit you with my sword
in the helmet you will survive that but
if i poke you in the stomach you will
die yeah that's what we want to have in
the game or that's what we have in the
game already so we have we are only
um calculating the physical
collision between your weapon and the
piece of armor but it makes sense
because if you have a full plate armor
guy in front of you and he's not wearing
a helmet then where are you attacking of
course the head whereas it's unprotected
and your shoes won't protect you from
headstrikes
it sounds like we might be dying a lot
um
yeah and no well we want to make it of
course we want to make uh one-hit kills
of course if you hit the head but on the
other hand it
it's a game and it's a fun game it has a
big epic story inside and we don't want
to make it so hard that it's like
unplayable anymore so there's of course
the compromise as i said as realistic as
possible but it's not a medieval
simulation but it's something that tries
to give you a good feeling about that
area and it has has it compromises but
of course if you are bad if you have a
bad armor there's someone coming you
will die a lot of course so prepare so
what is the sort of moment to moment in
terms of like what is your do you play
one character is this all single player
do you have quests is it open is it
linear what are we talking about here we
are talking about an open world rpg a
single player open world rpg where you
are playing a particular person called
henry he's the son of a blacksmith
his character is not a hysterical person
but the entire frame is
but you are playing a guy that is living
in a city which gets attacked by an uh
foreign king the king of hungary and the
interesting part is that this really
happened so right this is something that
if you open the textbook it's really
there and you will
the city gets attacked your family get
murdered the city get destroyed
everything happened and you have to flee
from this place first you are driven by
revenge you are getting in the service
of a noble who gives you quests who
gives who who tells you what to do who
brings you back on the feed but then you
will first you are driven by revenge as
i said but first you realize uh first
you
after you after you realize what is
really going on is in this place because
there's a political struggle you will
have to pretty much save bohemia kind of
but or be part of it you're not saving
like you're no superhero yeah yeah
you're just one of many so is there is
there larger battles there as well well
it's we want to show real medieval life
but it's also important to know that
large battles is something you might
know from a lot of rings or something
from millions of soldiers this is not
something that happened really in back
then and it wasn't even happening now
and like every weekend right yes exactly
we'll have
uh castle sieges for example that's a
important uh story thing in the game but
it will something will be something like
the cherry on the cake or something yes
so it's not gonna be happening maybe two
days it's a big moment let's say
uh
super fast sorry go on yeah you're about
to say that's what's going on i just
want to say that this is a monastery
which is actually
really standing right now in czech
republic you can visit this place this
is really looking like that and the only
thing we had to do is we had to send our
team there take reference pictures of
all the stuff
recreate it and reconstruct it because
it looks kind of different today it was
destroyed partially but this church we
are standing in right now looks exactly
like wow
with this pictures we have a full-time
historian in our team we have a painter
in our team who's recreating those
buildings we want to
show you the real medieval experience
how it really looked like in bohemia or
europe in in the 15th fascinating stuff
the [__] thing is sorry the funny
thing it was under construction in 1403
so there's a construction site as well
oh man they're just saying so that's
wonderful uh those monks didn't look
like they were wearing a lot of armor
could you just if you wanted just stop
one of that i'm guessing it would be
too much but this is like an extreme
important part of the game you will have
to
you have to investigate some guy who's
hiding inside this monastery and you the
only thing you know that he has a scar
on his face so but you have to go inside
and find this guy but there's no way how
you could enter a medieval monastery
without like getting kicked out
so you can either sneak in do the ninja
games sneak in during night but you have
the disadvantage that you cannot talk to
these guys because they will kick you
out you can well that's a brutal way but
you can just go in there and murder
everyone
which is like one of them is the right
guy so well
presumably quite hard though it will be
quite hard and you will have a great uh
great impact a very bad impact on your
um
reputation people want to kill you
people want to imprison you
everything you do in general in the game
will have some kind of proper reaction
so everything you do should call you
should face the consequences but the
third thing is actually what you what
you said with the monks you can actually
enroll in this monastery and become a
monk something like a game inside a game
oh really because you have to get inside
pretend that you actually want to become
a monk you do monk duties be like
praying several times a day eating with
them i was going to ask what a monk duty
is just we had an agent actually because
we wanted to have the monastery yeah but
uh we had to research which research
what research what they actually did
there how often did they pray how can we
put quests inside does it make sense to
go there inside was it possible so we
have our compromises we have our ideas
but that's what we want to show and here
we
fly it away we flew away to to a castle
right now so we are inside a noble place
so our
painters strike again yeah right painted
this everything is hand painted by the
way so on one hand you have this epic
story you want to tell on the other hand
you have to as far as i would say this
epic visual so it looks
it should
the big goal of kingdom come deliverance
is tell epic story and um raised the
immersion bar to a level that never
right and it's interesting because you
need to be there well we have a lot of
games that go back in history but they
always seem to you know sort of you know
maybe they have to because the types of
game they are they sort of toy with the
history they're playing in you know
assassin's creed is wonderful you go
back to akra and damascus and all these
places and that's awesome super
fascinating yeah and i grew up in a
medieval town in ireland it's a thousand
years old and it like a lot of this sort
of stuff like reminds me of where i grew
up and i would love to have been able to
take a time travel back that's what i
hear often that it looks when we have
forests for example some of you might
know our forests look well really good
as far as i would say but people are
actually telling us wow this is this
exactly looks like when i'm looking out
of my backyard
it looks like a real forest if you just
do a screenshot it looks like a picture
and that's what we want to achieve we
want you give to give you the illusion
of a real living world with an ai system
which runs the world where everything
everyone has his daily cycles everything
is working somehow and with the visuals
that you like look there and say wow
this is something i totally believe yeah
a lot of people in the chat asking what
platforms this is going to be available
on uh yeah we are working right now on
the pc version but of course we are
planning for ps4 and xbox one as well so
these three are the the aim platforms
and yeah
that's something we want to release in
2017 and here you can see uh rata castle
that's a castle that's also still
existing in czech republic it looks a
bit different but people need to
understand that in medieval times a
castle was not a cinderella castle or
minas t rate or something like this from
lord of the rings but this is how it
really looked like and this is how we
want to transfer it into the monitors
yeah yeah yeah very sort of functional
it's like what do you mean as in the
castles they're sort of like now we look
at them as uh tourist attractions you
know whereas like yeah obviously much
better i think the castle is an
important place and you will even siege
it because of the story you can't say i
want to see to this castle because i am
bored or something yeah but it will be
connected to the story because
if you open the textbook it was really
sieged yeah that's wonderful stuff uh
when will we see kingdom come
deliverance i know you guys been working
on it for years i think there was an
alpha for backers last year exactly
okay we released the beta in march and
we want to release the final game next
year we don't have a precise date right
now but 2017 is our
release window right it's a nice big
window yes i like it toby thank you so
much for coming on and showing us thank
you very much
absolute pleasure uh we'll be back in a
couple of minutes folks the uh folks
from eagle flight from ubisoft to be
here in a second to show us off one of
their virtual reality games stay there
back in a minute
[Music]
they say that
battle
changes you
it makes you stronger
more ferocious
a monster in the night
watching
learning
hunting
each time i enter the pit
i emerge
reborn
put the devil on the other side
and i will show up
adapted
and prepared
to fight
[Music]
one
so
[Music]
hey folks welcome back to gamespot's
coverage of e3 2016. i'm delighted to be
joined by olivier palmieri from ubisoft
uh sir you are showing one of the many
virtual reality games that ubisoft are
working on at the moment um eagle flight
you guys were on during the press
conference a couple of days ago what's
it been like getting reactions from
people uh for uh seeing this game for
the first time so reactions are really
amazing people are amazed
by how
intuitive it is to control the game but
also how precise you are you can be in
the game because we are really using the
most of a vr
the game is really comfortable but
you pick it up in a few minutes and in a
few minutes you become an expert of
light you don't need a complicated
control so yeah reactions are very good
so far so you've been working at ubisoft
for a long long time almost two decades
you've got your you know finger involved
in everything assassin's creed to far
cry to the splinter cells and rhema um
tell me about the sort of the the
challenge there is with virtual reality
with like with making a game like this
you said you did quite a lot of research
and development on this before you got
it off the ground so before we started
the project we did six months for our
research on vr i wanted to make sure
that we use the most of uh of the art
sets and and vr in general there was
also this uh
problem of discomfort that can
be in vr so i wanted to make sure that
we can have lots of motion
and be very comfortable for most
and also use the mo the the most of vr
in terms of
accessibility like being very intuitive
so everybody can pick up and enjoy being
a bird being an eagle flying over paris
at the same time being very precise so
you can be very precise you can you can
go into tiny passages like in the tunnel
you can see here
uh so it's uh it's a combination of
several elements to that makes the the
most of your uh
most vr games or at least a lot of the
vr games we're seeing early on have
tried to restrict motion as much as
possible you know
it's all about sort of small minute
motion what what made you guys go in the
complete opposite direction
i couldn't believe that vr was doomed uh
right in in a way to uh to be only
seated experience non-moving experience
i was convinced that you it was possible
it should have been possible it would be
possible
to have lots of motion and and live the
dream of being a bird being an eagle
flying
and do that in vr so uh
i went uh
up to the road and through the wall and
we research we read studies to to
understand why there can be discomfort
and what we can do so we have many
techniques today
we have the big you can see and the beak
and the eyebrows
we have what we call the blinders with
the the black element the blackness that
comes on the sides uh dynamically
depending on
certain conditions in fact it's uh uh
when you need it it's hiding your
peripheral vision right dynamically
it's also about the motion that is
forward with no inertia so there's lots
of
combination of elements that make it
makes it possible that's fascinating
that the the beak is actually an
important sort of thing for is that
something to do with how like we we we
have our noses there at all times
our equilibrium or something yeah yeah
so uh in fact our brain is is used to
see our nose all the time and it grounds
us in the world yeah in vr the issue is
that when you put the vr at set then you
don't see your nose anymore
so we did during the the rnd phase we
also did another experience where you
were a human and we added the nose and
it was really helping to ground the
players and help him with comfort
so we found the equivalent in an eagle
universe it's a good thing you have your
big and it's really grounding you in the
world and gives you a referential also
for the world to to to know exactly also
where you are as i told you the game is
very precise so it's also helping you to
to gauge where you want to aim and uh
yes
like a crosshair you've got in the into
your face yeah exactly yeah i got the
chance to play it and
you watch that footage and it looks like
okay but will it really look that good
playing but it's really just you look
where you want to go you have the
controller which is doing like you know
you can shoot out those sound waves when
you're playing the multiplayer mode but
i mean immediately i was kind of
dropping down like into like those
alleyways and then coming back up out of
courtyards and there's like a sense of
momentum that feels awesome so we've
talked about the game in i guess in the
sense of like how it controls and and
virtual reality and all those important
questions which especially people who a
lot of the people who watch these
streams have never had the opportunity
to put those headsets on uh but let's
shift a little bit to the gameplay what
exactly is going on in eagle fight it
seems to be like almost like a game of
football between a bunch of different
birds
okay so in fact the full game has
three parts let's say the first one is
called the free flight so it's for every
everybody to pick up the headset and
enjoy exploring the city from a new
point of view the eagle point of view
then we have a single player mode a
story mode and finally we have the
multiplayer mode so the multiplayer is
about it's called capture the prey so as
an eagle you have to
you have to
capture your prey and bring it back to
your nest to nourish your
your
little eagles egrets
and so there is two teams competing in
paris
uh to grab the prey and deliver deliver
it first to the nest uh what's paris
looks a little bit different we see like
il de france and notre dame here but it
looks like
there aren't many humans around anymore
yeah so the world is set 50 years after
humans left
the city so nature is reclaiming the
city
animals are
are getting back in the in the city so
there is actually a zoo called the zou
de vansen uh close to paris and the the
animals escaped from that zoo and that's
where you can see giraffes and elephants
and zebras in the city when they're in
the city so it's really uh nature taking
back the city and it's not it's not
apocalyptic i don't like this war in
fact right yeah it's truly uh positive
it's nature taking back the city and
making it beautiful it's like pripyat or
something or like a tokyo jungle it's
like a kind of like a good thing um
so i guess who are you playing against
you said like the multiplayer game are
we talking about playing online
predominantly i'm assuming because
virtual reality headsets it's not like
you have six of them lying around yeah
so that's another thing with here
we really wanted to make to to show that
vr can be social
so it's a multiplayer game
you have teammates with you so it's two
teams of two teams of three players it's
six players in total
and uh it's a social experience and uh
so when with your teammates you can uh
cover your teammate another one can play
the sniper and everyone can be the the
runner you know like he's grabbing the
prayer and
runs into the city go inside the tunnels
and under the bridges etc uh and yeah
each player can
have its own uh strategy and tactics to
to make it happen
how do you sort of i guess keep an eye
on what your teammates are doing a lot
of the time because it looks like it's
quite it looks like you'll have quite a
lot to concentrate on because you're
going to try and make sure you go in the
right direction so how do you sort of
keep your eye on what they're doing and
work together as a team
so in vr you have a large field of view
though so it's very easy when you climb
up in the sky to see what is happening
that's what we
we have in the game in fact
we chose paris because it's very organic
it's uh you have very tight streets but
sometimes it's
often it's very useful to climb uh in
the sky and to have a very good overview
of the city and where are your teammates
where are the opponents where is the
prey and it's really that gameplay of
going up in the sky then diving
into the tunnels diving to to get the
prey uh and that allows you with the
large field of view to to see uh
what is happening and where are
everybody cool and mike you said you
played this packet was it gdc or was it
here at e3 it was the oculus event
before gdc so i don't remember the beak
was that implemented at the time yes no
it was okay yeah i just didn't notice it
it was yeah it's probably it's natural
because you it replaces your nose so
it's like it makes it feel like an
extension face right yeah as opposed to
just this huge block on your eyes right
maybe your nose just looks like a beak
when you're from your perspective maybe
i just feel like an eagle all the time
uh what did the moment-to-moment
gameplay feel like to you if you can go
back then and remember yeah no the the
multiplayer mode he was mentioning uh
pray yeah pray yeah the rabbits yeah you
so you pick up the rabbits and then you
want to just it's like capture the flag
essentially but you know you have these
sound waves you're shooting out right or
maybe not sound waves but some waves
okay yeah and then you could hit another
eagle and it'll puff into like a cloud
of feathers but you know
you wanna get the rabbit but you as soon
as you escape you start you want to like
make it hard for people chasing you or
because then a lot of people will be
above the buildings waiting for you to
come back out so a lot of times they're
going through alleyways or up through
these like the cathedral attics yeah
like you kind of go through like the
entire building inside it almost but
then you know swoop down changing
elevations uh it
it's fun to like be chased in that game
because you're just having playing mind
games with people that are right like
behind you but then also like you're
that's the last few seconds when you're
about to bring it back to your nest but
someone else was already like above you
waiting and killing life yeah it's
almost like we've seen a lot of like i
guess
dog fighting or spatial dog fighting
games in virtual reality because it
seems to be a good fit it's like okay
you're walking around you're looking
around um but this is sort of a unique
game in that it's not just you against
you know targeting things it's more
about your movement within the world as
opposed to like what you're trying to
hit all the time yeah it's also about
the
the dream of being a bird and a
flying over a known city a wonderful
city
our controls are really on the fact that
you can move your head and it's
everything is done with your head and
that's why it's so intriguing for
everybody to to enjoy it and so precise
at the same time so space shooter in vr
it's it's great but it may may not be uh
as intuitive and as precise it's
something else you can you use a
joystick etc our game has a more
simple approach but uh
i'd like to compare it to a sport you
know
the the multiplayer mode
uh as as rules that are
globally fairly simple but in fact
there's a lot of depth uh uh like soccer
you you have to to grab the uh grab the
dupray and bring it back and you are
very precise with your head so
we also wanted to to to set apart from
the from the other games yeah and uh
that was personally my dream
of flying
i did
a many and many dreams about flying
since i'm a child yeah i really wanted
to to have more because dreams usually
you you dream about
a flying but it's two minutes one minute
and then it stops yeah i wanted more so
i wanted to find a way and vr is a way
to make my dream come true and i'm sure
make the dream of many people come
through that's one flyer
did you grow up in paris as well or yes
exactly so this is perfect this is
exactly right it's excellent
what is i guess i'm fascinated to talk
to somebody who has developed and worked
on so many games who's now directing a
sort of a virtual reality only
experience because there's lots of games
that are sort of
using vr as well but like this seems to
be like you're dead set on just like
working within this what are some of the
most difficult sort of
obstacles you've had as a director as a
designer of this game to try and make
this something that people can play and
not feel like they want to like get sick
like something that makes them feel
positive as opposed to negative
in fact so vr is a new medium uh it's a
big challenge but i like challenges and
so uh
it's it's great to be able to develop a
new platform and find
you know those new challenges of of
comfort and also on controls how are we
going to make these the the controls
easy to pick up uh you know on rayman
for example we really tried also to make
the game intuitive and easy to pick up
and play yeah
though there's lots of depth and
replayability and
and very tough challenges also in the
end in rayman and that's that's uh uh
what we are aiming for also for for
fargo flight
so
those challenges are very interesting in
fact to to discover a completely new
medium and study uh the
the the best use we can make and and and
all of that um so when is that out and
on what platforms so it will be released
in fall 2016 and the playstation vr
oculus rift and htc vive awesome uh will
it be a launch title for playstation vr
will it be it's uh undecided yet okay
still figuring it out wonderful thank
you so much olivia for coming on and
showing a sequel flight merci beaucoup
and a good best of luck with the rest of
the development as well thank you
awesome uh thank you so much as well
merci beaucoup to all of you as well my
french is terrible that's better all i
can say
um we have uh i believe mr schaefer in
the wings to come on and talk about
another virtual reality game he just
wooed himself
so let's get him to talk about
psychonauts in the rumbles of ruin in
just a second stay there
jimmy thing here with scott butterworth
and scott you had the chance to check
out some playstation vr titles recently
can you yeah yeah no just last night i
was at the uh the sony press conference
that did this whole big vr event
directly afterwards we're showing a
bunch of stuff that they announced
during the press conference actually so
a lot of games we've already seen like
100 foot robot golf and harmonix vr but
also tons of stuff that was just
announced last night cool can you walk
us through some of the biggest titles
that you saw uh so let's see so i saw
final fantasy the final fantasy 15 vr
experience uh which is in first person
looks like
yeah weird it doesn't really feel like
much of a fantasy game i mean it's just
a straight up like first person shooter
experience basically you're fighting one
giant boss with the help of some of the
other characters from the upcoming game
uh but you can kind of like warp around
the environment but really it's just
like you have the one move controller
and you're aiming at the boss and like
just shooting until it dies and that's
kind of the entire experience you know
if it's going to be multi-player is that
why the other characters you know i was
asking them about that after the demo
and they really weren't willing to
divulge any other information i asked if
there's going to be you know more levels
or a different game play and all of it's
to be determined even the release dates
to be determined so
it was interesting to see those
characters kind of up close and personal
and and to see all that in vr but yeah
it didn't really feel like any final
fantasy game that i've ever played it
was it was a bit of a weird little demo
uh so i don't know if it'll actually
result in a full game but that's what
last night's experience was so wasn't
super crazy about this experience but
then again like final fantasy in vr it's
kind of a
yeah yeah just shooter
was sort of their first gameplay title
that they showed that one was actually a
little bit disappointing too it's just
kind of a very very straightforward
sci-fi shooter it's just you on a kind
of mars looking rocky dusty planet
shooting a bunch of bug alien type of
things okay the environments were pretty
believable it was really cool to get to
walk around and it does have this crazy
peripheral that was just announced it's
basically the successor to the there
there was like what was it the sheer
shot the move shear shot back when the
playstation move was a thing during the
ps3 days sure it's kind of a version of
that it's like this rifle peripheral and
it actually has a joystick and a d-pad
on it so you use that to maneuver
through the environment but you still
aim and shoot using the uh the trigger
and the headset i was talking the other
day you said batman was surprisingly
batman was surprisingly cool so for
anybody that's played the arkham games
if you know like the detective sections
where you're analyzing a crime scene it
was basically that uh but in vr so you
could actually view a crime yeah exactly
it's all in first person so you could
view the crime from multiple angles uh
kind of the same thing as final fantasy
where there were certain spots around
the environment that you could warp to
but because it wasn't action it didn't
actually feel as limiting
you could basically just like scrub
through the playback by twisting your
wrist with the move controller in your
hand uh so the whole the whole
experience is framed is basically a
murder mystery uh where you're trying to
solve the murder of dick grayson which
is kind of a cool narrative conceit uh
according to devs it's only about an
hour long experience but what i played
so far was actually like pretty cool
what else did you check out uh let's see
oh another thing was resident evil that
was great so uh for anybody that saw the
conference that room that you see in
that trailer that you're kind of like
walking through this derelict house with
like peeling wallpaper and all that kind
of stuff that's basically what the demo
was um i think this is actually the same
level that's playable on the
downloadable demo on psn but i got to
play it in vr uh so it's really cool you
play with the dual shock 4 so it's about
what you would expect from the controls
in the movement and all that but you
actually can look around the environment
and you feel a little bit more immersed
actually being in first person in the
world it's kind of hard to feel too
scared when you're standing around a
bunch of other people in a giant room so
i don't know if the immersion is really
going to make the experience any scarier
it's kind of hard to say but it was
definitely cool getting to like explore
this whole environment in first person
in vr you know i can't even play like
horror games like on a straight flat
monitor so let alone like in vr yeah
that's like uh no for me thanks i think
the last game that i would probably want
to talk about sort of number five to
round out the list was psychonauts vr uh
for anybody who doesn't know psychonauts
uh you know the original game came out i
think like a little over 10 years ago
and they finally announced they're doing
a full sequel but they're also doing a
separate standalone vr game that kind of
links the two it's called rhombus of
ruin so they were showing that last
night as well and it's really cool it's
like all the original voice actors all
the writing's still done by tim schafer
so it feels very much like a psychonauts
game but the way they kind of get around
the gameplay since the original game was
more of a platformer uh you're basically
it's a seated experience first person
first person uh and you can transfer
your consciousness to different
characters around the room nice so it
functions as a bit of a traversal
mechanic because everyone's kind of
situated in different parts of the
environment yeah so if you jump into
their mind you can suddenly view the the
room from this it makes sense within the
context of the the game's narrative yeah
totally because it's all about you know
psychics basically the game is about
people with psychic abilities so yeah
you have like a clairvoyance ability but
you can also light things on fire with
your mind or move things with your mind
so it's kind of like a puzzle game meets
the humor and writing of the original
psychonauts so escape the room kind of
thing you got to figure out puzzles to
progress and yeah yeah well yeah i mean
you move the experience along by solving
puzzles i don't know that i really had
to escape anything the scene that i
played was actually took place
immediately after the end of the first
game uh and the puzzles were fun it was
really cool to get to kind of move stuff
with my mind i mean i could pick stuff
up with the controller but it would
actually move as i looked around was it
using the playstation move controllers
or the yes it was okay and like i said
there was a ton of other stuff but for
me those were the five kind of biggest
games that people would want to hear
about awesome uh for more e3 coverage
stay tuned to gamespot.com
hello folks and welcome back to
gamespot's coverage of the electronic
triple 2016. myself and michael are
joined by mr timothy
what's your middle name
no middle name john
timothy j schaefer the president i've
never been introduced with my middle
name before there you go now everyone
knows and now they're going to steal
your identity why don't you just give
out my social i know yeah yeah we can
tell you where you live as well you guys
are on the same bus route right mm-hmm
be careful yeah yeah yeah uh good to
have you here as ever for having him be
on your lovely couch a pleasure with you
andy i know do you want one of our
airheads
you can this this whole set is actually
sponsored by airheads would you like one
you're welcome for letting you yeah
thank you so much
great we don't even need to do our plugs
tim schafer will come on and do it for
you
big airhead yeah
how's your e3 going so far it's great
it's great it's awesome we've been
showing we're showing like a bunch of
stuff like four different things at
least but also seeing a lot of cool
games and
press conferences were exciting and uh
yeah it's a lot of fun what have you got
to play yourself walking around i'm
playing there's a um you know game bound
as a vr version of bound in the vr
section of the sony booth um and uh i
always like to see below can come a long
way yes we have nathan on tomorrow i
think inside and if i could come up with
a third
prepositional phrase
right next to okay next two was pretty
good
but not really we've been waiting a long
time for play inside and i'm excited
about that yeah pretty soon um but we
are not here to talk about inside we're
here to talk about psychonauts in the
rhombus of ruin your virtual reality
experiment you guys have always
been doing this been like messing with
the tech you made some of the most like
interesting games on connect
what's it like been working in virtual
reality yeah we do like to try out new
stuff and virtual reality is it's kind
of natural for us because we always like
to make worlds and then pull you in it
make you want to feel like you're in a
space that's transformative
you're teleported to a different world
and vr just plops you right into that
and it's it's kind of intense because
you um you know it you can tell that it
looks nice when you look at the film but
until you put on the goggles you're in
the world like right now all those
different figments you're seeing you
recognize from the first game i figured
they're all at different depths so it
really feels like you're in this 3d
space all around you full of mental
figments right doesn't sort of come
across a lot of this stuff on on the
screens uh so for folks who
well for folks who have played
psychonauts i mean are you playing
either way it works yeah yeah like
where what does this do is this filling
in between one and two is that what it
does it does it tells the mission of the
rescue of truman sonata which is uh he's
the grand head of the psychonauts and
the father of your girlfriend and if you
play the first game or if you haven't it
still works but you you ended the first
game becoming a cycle not saving the day
and then you hear about truman getting
kidnapped and you all jump into a jet
and fly off to save them and that's it
cut roll credits
and this game picks up right after that
now you're in the jet and you're trying
to find truman zenodo and rescue him but
first you have a little tutorial where
you get to relearn some of your
psychic abilities but now in a virtual
space you guys threat ears have had to
go back to the sort of you've done you
know remasters of some of your older
games and had to like take these
characters that looked you know a
certain way at a certain era and update
them i mean the same thing is happening
here we have these crazy super detailed
3d versions of of characters from the
old psychonauts game what's what they
look like in my head the whole time
right now they look more like that
finally realized finally realized in
luscious 3d this is our first game in
unreal four so right we use all the
bells and whistles of that engine and um
and he's also kind of a warming up of
that uh world the second house which was
shipped 10 years ago right so we got to
call about the actors and some of them
had retired and we're like hey come back
and do this game and you know kind of
hoping their voices were still still
there and that sounded great it's not
amazing um so all these characters sasha
mia and lily and the coach are all there
and um and it was fun to be back in the
studio recording with them and a great
way to get ready for psychonauts 2 as
well so what's the moment to moment
action of the rhombus room like what are
you doing what type of vr game
experience are we talking about it is
kind of an adventure game kind of a
puzzling game we're not platforming we
really wanted you to be comfortable
which means you know very we're pretty
conservative with our emotion where
you're mostly in a chair but you're
you're psychic so it's a perfect fit for
vr like i could levitate to that bowl of
airhead brand candy and i could um
burn it which you would never do no
um
no you can use your uh psychic abilities
to
move objects with your brain telekinesis
rotate like look at them and then throw
them away or burn them or or put them in
the right place to solve a puzzle
but then you also use clairvoyance which
allows you to
is it like i time that see i looked at
right clairvoyance
and you can which means you can see the
world through someone else's eye so i
could jump into your head and see myself
like looking back at myself and i can
look over there and see someone on the
camera and i can jump into their head
and they can look out the window and see
someone jump there and so that's how we
can navigate the world
um instead of just teleporting to a spot
on the floor you're going to another
brain which means you're also seeing how
that person sees the world and that can
be sometimes slightly different too
right yeah and did this stuff get was
this at all connected to the fig funding
of of psychonauts 2 or is this like
sound sort of thing rhombus of ruin is
uh funded by sony or palsy okay and
that's what's and it's on the
playstation vr and the second house 2 is
funded by our crowdfunding campaign
was that called a fig because of the fig
i think that was part of the idea there
the hotel okay
i heard somebody mentioned that to me a
couple days ago i was like oh yeah that
makes sense
although hopefully your fate will be is
the thing getting torn down or is it
getting real because they took the name
away now they can't operate so that's
why i'm closed down
no that's not true
it's getting remodeled remodeled okay
made uh more beautiful unless just just
like psychonauts there you go yeah yeah
um so what's how long is it is this
experience i kind of want to hold off
until we finish it and time it out but
right if this is just an introductory
area it's kind of small and confined the
other areas are bigger and there's more
of them and you're solving actual
puzzles it's not just like
it's not just like a demo or like a
room that you play with it's a real
story and adventure and has a narrative
you go into a mental world in the whole
game just like you do in psychonauts and
so um it's a real full-on game
as i say
do they yeah they all say it's a long
game why am i talking like that i don't
know i don't know mike or just jovial
have you played rhombus of roone you've
played a lot of vr games this week why
have you not played it uh
someone else could have signed it i
didn't make my way over there i don't
have an excuse i'll play it i've got a
couple days left we had a yeah i put you
on the spot
i could have lied
yeah i played the part where you're in
the jet and you're looking around and
then you see like a squirrel on the roof
yep yeah that's a squirrel summer camp
uh is this coming out for sort of launch
a playstation is that a random yeah
aiming for the near the end of the year
okay so around that area what's it like
being like i guess you know with with
connect and all the games you sort of
developed for that i imagine you were
doing a lot of bringing in friends and
family to sort of figure it out and demo
it testing it yeah yeah yeah i mean you
know connect party was a great game the
whole family could play it and we have
had people
uh like my daughter play this although i
think they say you're not supposed to
let little kids play but right she likes
it is that what they say about viewers
yeah it kills them instantly
about psychonauts like yeah don't the
kids shouldn't have kids can play second
half it's totally kid-friendly uh yeah
so what's that been like i guess trying
to develop with this new type of
technology that so many people are
having like a little bit of trouble
trying to get folks like comfortable
with it and trying to teach them the
sort of i guess the language of virtual
reality what's that been like well i
mean it's really exciting to be at the
beginning of something and everyone's
like even the biggest players in the
games industry are like what is a vr
game what is it how do you move you know
like and everybody you know the smartest
people in the industry are trying to
figure out this problem and you know we
think we have a good solution there our
psychic context lets us give toilet
paper to the player perfect yeah but um
the psychic powers i think fit perfectly
well with vr that's a spoiler for one of
the major puzzles
so now you know the solution that's how
you complete that one
um but we're really sensitive to i'm the
first person to get sick if anything
goes wrong right so we're going to make
there's going to be nothing in this game
that ever makes you sick yeah i'm the
best canary in a coal mine for that kind
of thing
um
so so it's like it's a great time to be
doing stuff because everything is so new
and um
but also it's really intense like you're
it's hard to explain unless you put on
the goggles what it's like to stare in
the face of another character right and
their eyes are looking at you
and then you know other games characters
look at the screen and stuff but now
they're really looking at you and it's
really it's really like um
powerful
must be like enjoyable as a designer
especially considering you worked so
much in a in a genre that you sort of
helped popularize very much so part of
all that team at lucas uh and and then
sort of be like maybe it was or wasn't
but sort of became like a known quantity
like people thought they knew what
adventure games were so then you're
probably doing a lot of
like extra work to try and like usurp
expectations whereas here it's like
almost like you've got a blank slate
people don't really know i've just
answered your question for you haven't
they yeah what he said that's true
we um
yeah we're gonna possibly add to that
except for how delicious air heads are
do i get paid every time no no i
certainly don't so you shouldn't i think
you made up for any segment that you for
danny forgot that's true yeah yeah so
what's your appreciation would be that
if i mentioned a different candy right
now like four times would it be
would it be about if i mentioned a
different game
it's also a psychonauts game can i can
we talk about second house two or
rhombus of ruin or headlander you can
talk about headlander if you want or
full throttle okay i've given you a lot
of options can i talk briefly about a
game you didn't make
fine i might fall asleep you know what
i'm gonna ask you about go ahead no have
you played uncharted 4. yeah oh yeah you
have i'm at the very end don't spoil it
i don't spoil it either but i'm into
like one of the final tunnels
okay
pirate tunnel and i've seen some i think
you're going to talk about
um
some pirates some familiar pipes that
have appeared in it can i just ask you
were you involved in those conversations
no i would not i mean um
i mean i don't know if they called ron
or not right we're talking about it um
no what i heard is and i was spoiled for
everybody but the twitter spoiled it for
me
really well that sucks neil uh duckman
sent me a code he's like play the game
play the game now i was like okay okay
i'm getting to it but then the day it
came out people were like have you seen
this photo and there's like a there's an
easter egg there's a fun easter egg that
references
refers to a game that i had worked on
but um
it's a really funny story but they had
spoiled it but i didn't realize the
depth of it like it keeps going i know
in fact
there are some other references to like
that's the second biggest
x i have ever seen yeah which is almost
like with the the monkey and there's
always there always references that are
fun and i ca he was like yeah we're just
gonna sneak in and then like no you have
to ask for permission and then they got
actual permission
like that's
i feel like i'm scared of saying these
names because okay you're behind us
right the powers that be so you got
official permission from the powers of
me and what kept happening to me when i
was playing it was then i i felt like i
was projecting like i kept seeing like
is it me monkey island is in it like no
yeah oh you said the word now okay there
was there was there was one one part
where there's somebody with a telescope
sitting at the end of a set of steps i
wanted that too i was like is that a
reference or just that's right
yeah yeah so i guess we'll have to ask
neil jackman yeah that one goes blind
but um i think it's done in a way that
if you're uh
you don't know anything about that game
it's just fine yeah
he does look younger than all the other
pirates
can we talk about psychonauts too as
well i'd rather talk about uncharted the
whole time but okay if you want to talk
about it because i want to help those
guys out they're struggling
you know these individuals
dylan talks about them they just give
him a chance
um but psychonauts is also good right
how's fig gone
that was a crazy sort of experiment yeah
it was a we um we wanted to crowdfund
this game but also you feel a little
strange with crowdfunding sometimes you
take a bunch of money like what if your
game is a huge huge hit right and you
get rich and thanks to the backers and
you get a t-shirt and that's cool but
it's nice to be able to say like if you
know if this game does really well
you're gonna share we're gonna share and
that's what fig is all about you can
actually share in the profits for the
game and so it did better than any
crowdfunding we've ever done before
right we made almost four million
dollars with that and uh and now we're
going to make this game this awesome
game
is that where the impetus came from that
it sort of felt like the relationship
there you know
we kind of i guess you know when
kickstarter and all of these things
started came off we didn't really
understand what we wanted out of
crowdfunding but and i guess you as a
creator and somebody asking from when he
didn't really understand what you wanted
out of it either did it was it just kind
of like a moral thing or where you
thought like maybe this is just it was
the one just like uncomfortable part of
it where you're
for the first thing that happened it was
more just like we're trying to do this
thing we help us and everyone i think
felt really good about that yeah um but
to have it be a repeatable thing like
this isn't just a stunt this isn't just
like a novelty we're gonna talk about a
whole new way to fund games forever
then it has to be a more not just about
goodwill but also about like
fairness and
and and you know you can't just
go aw shucks we need help again over and
over again and they just keep keeping
all that money and you have to say like
this is the deal if you help us you get
to share the profits and it's fair and
repeatable and i think it's just a whole
new way for games to get funded in the
future uh and how is work on psychonauts
two coming along awesome we have uh zach
mclennan as early designer the lead
designer on bioshock 2 and um really
smart looking taking a really deep look
at all the mechanics in the first game
because the first game was um
you know you know it had a crazy story
and crazy inventive like things that
happened all these mental worlds you
never know what's gonna happen in the
game and we really want to go and um
look at all the collectibles and all the
psychic powers and really tune them to
be just amazing in the second game um
and also like bring back some of the old
psychic powers that people like but also
add some new ones and new twists to it
is there a pressure to make this for you
know for a new crowd as well like
psychonauts always seemed like one of
those franchises that you know had like
an incredibly you know passionate sort
of group of people who played it but you
know i'm guessing you shifted around to
people publishers and they weren't you
know maybe as confident that they would
have that like mass appeal i think yeah
something happened a lot to uh
third-person
stylistic
brightly colored humorous platformers
there was like a period where like oh
there was a million of them you're like
giant citizen kabuto
was in there yeah with like you know
ratchet and jack and rice all those
games and um
and then it seemed like people were like
you know kids want something edgier
darker
more brutal you know
there's a lot of and they do they're
like let's see where we can take games
and how gritty and dark we can make them
uh and i feel like we hit that i feel
like we've definitely made games are as
brutal and gritty as people want i think
and now they're like okay now i'd like
to have some brightly colored shoes and
and
you know be a happy character like i
think i think there's a there's there's
room to go back to games that are funny
and games that have a stylized art and
aren't all just brown and
and bloody and this been tone down the
neck stabs a little bit yeah and i mean
clearly it's working because would you
say 50 as much next abs is yeah i mean
dishonored now there's even quite a lot
of them yeah i mean they've got the
corner market on next next stopping i
think right now it's like a nice too as
a competitor though
uh psychic next steps okay
yeah you go into people's minds maybe
through the neck a couple of times right
yeah yeah yeah yeah got to do with
themselves yeah oh that's so right
here's an idea for you yeah so wait how
do we get started on all the next ads
anyway i think people are underserved in
that area i think people would like to
have an option like you see with like
banjo-kazooie spiritual professor yeah
yeah ukulele we'll have them on the show
tomorrow
yeah yeah great to have you on romp's
ruin out later this year yeah and what
about psychonauts two second house two
we'll just look for updates we just put
out a fig update showing some progress
check your inbox yeah yeah yeah check
your bulletin board what about
headlander when do we see that uh
come have we announced the actual date
very soon very very soon okay i think
i'm not allowed to say the date because
of weird things but it's very soon and
it's awesome headlander
uh final question what's your favorite
candy
i want to get you guys in trouble i've
always enjoyed ava's ever
okay four was enough to shaffer pleasure
as ever to hang out with you uh best of
luck we look forward to seeing more of
psychonauts over the next coming months
uh thank you so much for watching
everyone on our live stream uh we have
one more we actually we're going to have
a little uh chinwag about uh yeah sorry
mike and what's your favorite face uh
about one of our favorite games here at
e3 2016 but actually we managed to get
the god of war folks to come in and talk
about that so stick around we'll be back
in just a second we've got of war
[Music]
[Applause]
hello welcome back to gamespot's
continuing coverage of e3 2016 and we
are on the gamespot stage talking to
developers all day long and i'm
delighted to be joined with corey barlog
sir sony santa monica you guys did a
real good job of keeping a tight lip on
on god of war uh what's it like to find
people out there talking about us
uh
an incredible incredible relief i did
not sleep for the four days leading up
to the press conference
uh partially i mean there was a little
bit of nervousness of playing to a live
orchestra right yes good point playing
an early build of a a game live uh on
live stream for millions of people
to a live orchestra because i it wasn't
hard enough yeah make it harder up the
ante yeah yeah and you know we're doing
so much different with this franchise
totally that i was very
nervous about how it was going to be
received so let's talk about that i
guess what was the impetus behind i mean
fundamentally shifting the perspective
of the camera and then i guess the
perspective of the game uh where did
that come from uh the the roots of it
were kind of the personal journey that i
wanted to tell i think coming back
i said i have a another god of war in me
i think and i have a story for kratos
and it kind of was born out of this
change the shift this new lens that i
sort of see the world in you have a kid
and it kind of changes the way you see
things and and
how i approached problems creatively
i thought oh there's some fascinating
potential here for what kratos would be
like if given a second chance
and stars sort of aligned in that one
right and the shift in camera honestly
uh was born of that like we want to tell
a much more intimate story we want to
really kind of get in close and
initially
we took every aspect of the game broke
it apart put it on in pieces on the
floor and we're looking at each piece uh
and the camera you know 12 people
initially
and
half and half we love this cinematic
camera so we're like we know what i
think we gotta do something different
and looking back at that shift from
resident evil 3 to resident evil 4
even when the director himself was like
you can't make a horror game a resident
evil game with a controllable camera
yeah uh and lo and behold he did
and i think that's the same thing a lot
of people love the cinematic camera but
i think you can get just as much
intensity uh with that closer
so i guess you know you changed a lot
but what were the things that you wanted
to keep what were like the sort of
fundamental things that you could not
lose in a new god of war game
right from the beginning for me it was
kratos and sort of the history of him
you know uh while i want to go in and
sort of reimagine all aspects of the
play experience uh
the sort of through line of kratos this
this history that we built the chapter
one of his life in the sort of greek era
of games was what we wanted to really
maintain so that the really interesting
storytelling can start happening taking
this character that has made so many
horrible horrible decisions and
actually
get you to care and root for a little
bit uh from a gameplay perspective
there's a sort of that accessibility the
that kind of pick up and play mentality
of the game so that
anybody can pick it up it's it's
easy to sort of start playing the
mastery of it comes from really playing
with time yeah so is this a continuation
of the kratos we've already played as or
is this a new incarnation are you
talking about that yet continuation okay
uh so it is like the way i i kind of see
the
the mythologies is kind of like that
hubble telescope image of all of the
galaxies the ultra deep field yeah so
that image shows the universe with all
of its individual galaxies each galaxy
is kind of like a representation of a
mythology you know and sort of wrap that
around the earth and at any given moment
all of these mythological belief systems
uh existed you know they all deal with a
creation myth around their region it's
just separated by geography so that
while the height of some of these
mythological beliefs are at different
time periods uh a lot of them kind of
align with a single point in time uh
and even this one we're not really in
the viking area right a lot of people
think norse they think viking but
there's really this amazing pre-history
sort of the migration uh and then prior
to that the pre-migration era where in
the viking era they always talked about
the gods of abandonment thor and loki
and odin all walk the earth at one point
but not around anymore uh they fight for
them but they're not there and uh
this idea that we're at is is saying
we're at a prehistory point when the
gods did walk when when monsters were
real before they became extinct
it's kind of cool it's a fun space to be
in because it allows us to paint our own
image of norse mythology as opposed to
anyone else's yeah
you were saying obviously about how
you're sort of your personal
did you you had children yourself yeah
so like this like sort of bled into or
at least inspired this this new creative
shift for the game um are we talking
about kratos hassan is this his great uh
son himself
yeah uh where where is the the rest of
the family unit in this situation that's
a very good question uh that actually is
a major part of the story kind of the
answering of that one so this thing here
is kind of just introducing the dynamic
and the relationship but in the the game
you actually find out all the
information much more this is a for me
it's an
an intensely personal game like so much
that i'm pulling
from my own life uh
it could be because i just lack
creativity but i think it it truly is as
as a writer you always try to write what
you know exactly but find more truth
when you're actually building it from
something that is nearby that is true
you know i think even in high fantasy
and science fiction when it comes from a
place of reality
it's
relatable
so many people it's a human level thing
did you have to sell it to sony because
i mean this is one of their you know
most beloved franchises right this is
one of the the when you think about
sony you think about playstation you
think about god of war it's been there
for so long and it's been some of some
of the most enjoyable games on on the
platform so i mean there's obviously a
certain amount of trust involved in
there but what was it like actually like
pitching this idea because you aren't
tearing up a lot of what you know would
make a lot of executives quite scared
yes
yeah uh
i had kept in communication with shannon
studzill uh and when she took over the
studio again we kind of got in
conversations for about a year really
toying around with this thing saying i
think i have a crazy idea and i think
immediately she was like okay i think we
could do this we started bringing people
back together getting that core team
putting a pitch together uh
and surprisingly you know everyone kind
of got it very quickly right you know
and i i think i credited to the concept
that it's it's a very
simple concept you know the idea of
kratos being able to change because of
his child yeah that that idea of how
much of ourselves our real selves do we
show our children and how much of what
we do changes when we know we have a
mirror reflecting our flaws back at us
right yeah and
they kind of all were rallying around
and excited and
and i think that sony wide you know the
the whole organization really backed us
incredibly on this one and what have you
thought about the response from your
fans as well i mean critics at least
within our own little bubble it's it's
it has like you said actually it's it's
been like oh yeah okay this actually
fits like it's been there's a remarkable
sort of understanding right off the bat
what's it been like for like you know
die hard uh god of war fans who may have
been looking for a new god of war
what have you seen like from from those
communities i haven't seen a ton because
i've literally been going nonstop
actually since sunday
i take a little bit of a break here and
there i actually
fell into a reaction video rabbit hole
last night okay and what's up until like
four in the morning
watching i never even knew this existed
right yeah the idea of people taping
themselves watching something uh but it
is the greatest thing i have ever
experienced as a creative uh you sort of
pay for this stuff you pay for
understanding how people react to
various things and seeing sort of the
true emotional reactions they ebb and
flow and we watched uh or i watched some
of the the god of war stuff but then i
just kind of watched everything i was
soaking up every reaction video i could
find because it was just so incredible
and then four o'clock rolls around and i
haven't slept so
it was a
very rough night um but
i think overall the reaction has been
amazing you know it's
i expected it to be exceptionally
polarizing um
i i know our fans uh
they kind of
they trust us
you know so
even i think in this early phase when
people are skeptical they have concerns
that's that's great i think it's
fantastic to question that and
keeping in communication with us and
letting us know the things that they're
worried about that's
that i think was what makes a better
game um
mike what was your reaction when you saw
this let me just say yeah it was
interesting at first like you said the
camera shift that like struck me as more
of you know like over the shoulder i'm
thinking to myself
it's going to be tough trying to
implement what i assume there will be a
lot of melee combat with a controllable
camera right and most time melee games
are this third person action you know
you think devil may cry you think god of
war three one two three and ascension uh
i thought maybe that's interesting that
they're kind of taking this perspective
with uh the kind of combat i associate
god of war with and then of course this
moment like a beginning of the press
conference is kind of a macabre
somber
end to the demo yeah kind of hints at
some themes you might be seeing between
the father and son like a dynamic that's
appealing to me you've seen you've seen
a lot of movies you see in like the road
you see it and yeah right i got a real
sort of the the final chapter of red
dead redemption actually this sort of
reminded me of the last of us kind of
yeah yeah that's dynamic but this is a
very controversial moment
uh for the damage to and something like
this uh
because i think even in the team a lot
of people were talking about like this
is
not how we ended we ended big bombastic
you know monster and you know
i just i've seen so many people doing
that like ending on the monster going to
black kind of thing
which is great
but i think for people to really see
truly that we were trying to do
something different we had to go
crazy ivan on this one yeah like we just
had to
zig when they expected us to zag and
it was a lot of faith i think from
everybody on the team but uh they kind
of all rallied behind it and just made
it freaking amazing another very
interesting part of that demo was seeing
you sort of take control over his son as
well during that moment is that
something we should be preparing for
like getting used to is that sort of
duality persists throughout the game or
is it more of
in that moment where he's showing him
how to fire the bow um
teaching is kind of an important aspect
of the game though sort of passing out
of knowledge from father to son and in a
time where literally survival is like a
footstep at a time uh it means a lot to
pass on information to allow them to
survive in this very harsh world uh and
so those sort of father-son
teaching moments could just be a
cinematic moment but as much as we can
we're trying to make them interactive so
that idea of in the beginning of the
game you're gonna sort of start to nudge
try to get the kid to aim where you want
him to aim you're teaching him but as
time progresses really quickly he's
going to be a kid all right i got a dad
go away go away right yeah they sort of
achieved not a level of mastery but at
least a level of confidence you know
because the kid
is
not just a a delivery system for
narrative he's not just going to follow
you around and kind of give you
information we wanted him holistically
sort of connected to the game so there's
literally a button dedicated
specifically to the kid right and then
put in concert with the actual camera
motion you kind of have this sort of
binary system that allows you to very
simply very easily wherever you're
looking at press the kid button and the
context of what you're looking at
determines whether you're going to
interact in a puzzle interact with the
environment you're going to attack an
enemy and how you sort of load out the
kid how you upgrade the kid uh will
actually affect what it is you're going
to do there right so
it's not we never wanted the the sun to
be a
a burden he's not something you need to
babysit
he is exceptionally competent in the
sense that
when you are not using him he is
passively moving around the battlefield
in situations where there are 15 enemies
and two of them are really difficult
enemies 13 are just kind of less minor
enemies he'll
automatically split the battlefield try
to gain attention of some so that you
could focus on them uh the other ones if
you want him to do something else send
him over there go attack those guys you
know it's very simply single button if
you'll pardon the comparison uh it's
kind of a similar theme i see might be
at play here uncharted 4 a lot of people
have been talking about how the way you
look at nathan drake in that game
actually addresses his character
throughout the first three and now here
like you had said now kratos has this
mirror the sun to see himself through is
there gonna be some sort of
self-examination throughout the whole
game like oh yeah totally he is
it's interesting because
this character that we've been so
familiar with hitting this very
particular note
quite often
throughout that seven games within the
greek era
seeing him kind of
start to make different decisions seeing
him struggle with the concept of
controlling rage you know because to him
godhood is like a disease
that was thrust upon him without any
choice on his part and the side effect
of that disease is rage you know he has
this god side and this human side two
things that were never meant to coexist
together creating this incredible uh
amount of rage that
in that previous era of games he was the
hulk yeah all the time 24 7 because he
didn't know how to be bruce banner and
in this game in this iteration it's like
the
the son
is teaching him
how to be human it's it's bringing out
that sort of closeted humanity that he's
stamped down for so long but it is a
struggle he fails constantly it's like a
us as parents that's just children like
we
fail non-stop it never stops us and if
it knocks us down
it's the getting back up that's awesome
it's not the success the success is
sweet at the end of a really hard-fought
road but
getting back up after each
knockdown after each failure that's
that's what you root for that's what you
care about it's presumably quite a
challenge as a designer to try and marry
these like intimate moments with i'm
assuming we're going to have quite large
scale you know bombastic battles like
we're we're sort of used to
am i assuming incorrectly actually you
are assuming correctly okay we uh uh
with this demo we we kind of felt
people know we can do that people know
we can do big bosses that we can do
these kind of grand set pieces
uh what we need to do is make them
believe in the new kratos and see and
sort of give him a moment of rooting for
him you know of wow i felt something
different when watching this i didn't
just feel
rage and tension and and fear you know i
felt something completely different it's
wonderful thank you so much uh corey
barlow for coming on and telling us all
about god of war when we see more of it
it's one of these games that everyone's
asking to like to see more wow i don't
know man
when i guess we're ready to show it
seems like you you've had an e3 seems
like you've probably you're probably
pretty pretty busy and pretty tired of
showing people we literally are going
back to work almost immediately after
this and
crushed under the weight of being you
know always behind schedule that's
that's right development you are always
a year late you know you never can get
above water but
that's what makes it exciting yeah and
hopefully gallaudet will be uh worth
waiting for thank you so much corey for
coming on i appreciate your time thank
you and thank you so much for watching
here on the airhead stage at gamespot's
coverage upstairs here at the electronic
triple we are done for our second day
congratulations to everyone putting the
show together especially all the
wonderful people in the back who never
get any credit uh you know who you are
thank you so much you know who you are
for watching on youtube on gamespot on
twitch on facebook probably i don't know
you're probably watching there's so many
things now i can't even take can't even
remember all of them uh we are back
tomorrow with a bunch more games uh i'm
looking at it here lawbreakers are
cliffy b in the morning of war 3 halo
wars lego dimensions loads more e3 feels
like it's been going on for
ever but it's not over yet we got one
more day of this so make sure you hit
that subscribe button hit that follow
button and we'll see you guys tomorrow
morning take care
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
now
you